hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel we will begin with full
course video by understanding what
exactly node.js is next we will go
through the installation process of
node.js and make the computer ready for
node.js development next we will have an
in-depth understanding of node.js
architecture and some of its popular
modules next we will see how to interact
with apis using the express framework
based on node.js then we will see how to
use node.js in web applications and api
services then we will look into the web
authentication using json web tokens
then we will look into using node.js
with database systems like mysql and
mongodb and at the end we will look into
node.js interview questions and answers
that summarize every important node.js
concept and serve as a perfect
preparation resource for node.js
interviews so let's start with an
exciting video on node.js so what
exactly is node.js now consider a
scenario where a user interacts with the
web application the user only interacts
with the front end of the application
but there's a lot of work that goes
behind the scenes
now in a web application there's a front
end a server and a database the front
end is developed using javascript and
frameworks like angular and react while
the server is built on java php or
node.js and the backend database that
stores the data usually consists of
mysql or mongodb so node.js is an open
source cross-platform javascript runtime
environment for running server-side
applications it is used to develop i o
intensive web applications like video
streaming sites single page applications
online chatting applications and other
web applications it is used by large
established companies and newly minted
startups node.js was developed by ryan
dal in 2009 and at the same time of this
session its latest version is v13.3.0
now that we know what node.js is let's
go ahead and look at why it was so
prevalent in the field of web
development here are a few points first
up node.js is extremely fast being built
on google chrome's v8 javascript engine
its library is extremely fast in code
execution
note package manager has around 50 000
bundles for developers so whatever
functionality is required for an
application can be easily imported from
npm all apis of node.js library are
asynchronous that is non-blocking it
means a node.js based server never waits
for an api to return data node.js
dramatically reduces the processing time
while uploading video and audio files it
is also an open source platform and is
easy for beginners for web development
the above reasons more than justify the
popularity of node.js platform and why
it is being adopted by large number of
organizations and businesses today so
now moving on let's familiarize
ourselves with the parts of node.js
node.js consists of several components
now let's look at them one by one first
up we have modules now modules are like
javascript libraries which are used in a
node.js application to include a set of
functions now we can use require
function with the parenthesis to include
a module in a node.js application
node.js application has many modules to
provide basic functionality needed for a
web application some of them could be
http util fs url query string stream and
zlip next up we have console the console
module provides a simple debugging
console that is similar to the
javascript console mechanism provided by
web browsers now the console can print
messages to std out that prints standard
output messages and scd-ed to print the
error messages the next component is
cluster now nodejs is built upon the
concept of single threading programming
a single instance of node.js runs in a
single thread to take advantage of
multi-core systems the user will
sometimes want to launch a cluster of
node.js processes to handle the load a
cluster can be added to an application
in this way here's a small code for you
the next component is global now global
objects in node.js are available in all
modules now these objects are functions
modules strings etc some node.js global
objects are mentioned in the table you
have dir name that is the directory name
file name exports module and require the
next component is error handling now
nodejs applications experience four
types of errors we have the standard
javascript errors system errors user
specific errors and assertion errors now
errors in node.js are handled through
exceptions now for example let's handle
an error that would occur when we divide
a number by zero now this error would
crash the node.js application and so we
should handle this error here's a small
code for you
next up we have streaming a stream is an
abstract interface for working with
streaming data in node.js streams are
objects that let you read data or write
data continuously there are four types
of streams first one is the readable
these are the types of streams from
which data can be read writeable these
are the types of streams to which data
can be written
duplex these are both readable and
writable streams
lastly we have transform these streams
can manipulate the data while it is
being read or written moving on to the
next component buffer the javascript
language has no mechanism for reading or
manipulating streams of binary data
buffer is a module that allows handling
streams that contain only binary data an
empty buffer of length 10 can be created
by this method next up we have domain
domains provide a way to handle
different io operations as a single
group domain module intercepts errors
that remain unhandled there are two
types of methods that are used for
intercepting these errors firstly we
have internal binding in this case the
error emitter executes its code inside
the error method next up is the external
binding now here the error emitter is
explicitly added to a domain via its add
method the next component is the dns the
dns module enables name resolution for
example it is used to look up the ip
addresses of host names dns module is
used to connect to a dns server and
perform name resolution by using the
method dns.resolve the dns module is
also used for performing name resolution
without a network communication by using
the method dns.lookup the next component
is a debugger node.js includes an
out-of-process debugging utility
accessible via a v8 inspector and
built-in debugging client this node.js
debugger is not feature packed but
supports simple inspection of code it
can be used in the terminal by using the
inspect keyword before the name of the
javascript file in order to inspect a
file say myscript.js you can use the
following method now that we are
familiar with all the major parts of
node.js let's go ahead and learn about
the node.js express framework
express is a flexible node.js web
application framework that provides a
wide set of features to develop both web
and mobile applications you can assume
express as a layer built on top of the
nodejs that helps manage the server and
the roots now let's have a quick look at
some of the core features of express
framework it is used to design single
page multi-page and hybrid web
applications it allows setting up of
middleware to respond to http requests
it defines a routing table that is used
to perform different actions based on
the http method and url it also allows
dynamic rendering of html pages based on
passing arguments to templates now
moving on let's take a quick example of
a simple hello world program now this is
developed using express framework to
gain a better understanding all right
first up we have the wear express now
this is used to import express framework
into our node.js application now the
app.get method is a callback function
with parameters request and response the
request object represents the http
request and has properties for the
request query string parameters body
http headers etc the response object
represents the http response that an
express app sends when it gets an http
request now the application will listen
to the defined port which in this case
is 8081 and variables host and port will
contain the address and the port
respectively lastly we have the
console.log which is used to show the
address and port in the command prompt
so this is what the command prompt would
look like and finally the output is
displayed on the web browser having
learned about the express framework now
let's move on and look at the node.js
use cases
now it is no doubt that node stands out
for its speed and intensive data
exchange so top industry leaders like
nasa paypal netflix among others
incorporate node.js first up we have
netflix the world's leading internet
television network with over 117 million
users is one of the top companies that
trusted their services to node.js the
reasons why the company chose to use
node.js were application scalability and
data intensive application now you must
be wondering what application
scalability is this basically the
potential of an application to grow in
time being able to efficiently handle
more and more requests per minute and
data intensive application allows
millions of people to stream netflix
simultaneously next up is walmart now
walmart is the world's largest company
by revenue with around 514 billion us
dollars according to the fortune global
500 list in 2019. again the reasons why
the company chose node.js were
asynchronous i o and efficient handling
of concurrent requests now asynchronous
io which is a form of input output
processing allows other processing to
continue before the transmission has
finished nodejs is able to efficiently
handle concurrent requests with the use
of thread pool and event queues uber
uber is an american multinational
ride-hailing company offering services
that include peer-to-peer ride sharing
ride service healing and food delivery
the reasons why the company chose nodejs
were asynchronous i o quick iterations
and active open source community as
mentioned earlier asynchronous io
permits other processing to continue
before the transmission has finished now
quick iterations now node.js is
continually being updated and added new
features that help in further
improvement in the performance of web
servers and finally active open source
community resolves many problems that an
organization may face in a particular
scenario next up we have nasa now nasa
is an independent agency of the united
states federal government responsible
for the civilian space program as well
as aeronautics and aerospace research
the reasons why the company chose
node.js were reduced access times
handling of data intensive tasks and the
fact that the servers are active 24 7.
now nasa has lots and lots of data and
using node.js has really helped them in
reducing the access times it is also
continuously handling and working with
large streams of data node.js is highly
stable which helps in keeping the server
active 24 7. next up we have paypal now
paypal is an american company operating
a worldwide online payment system that
supports online money transfers as
opposed to traditional methods like
checks and money orders the reasons why
the company chose to use node.js was the
fact that node.js has extremely fast
build times it allows tasks to be
carried out with fewer lines of code
when compared to other server
technologies like java and php and
node.js being data intensive efficiently
handles a large amount of data next up
is medium medium is a popular online
publishing platform developed by evan
williams and launched in august 2012.
the main reasons why the company chose
to use node.js were a data driven
applications now these applications are
ideal for being interfaced with node.js
servers b to run a b tests now a b
testing is essentially an experiment
where two or more variants of a page are
shown to users at random and statistical
analysis is used to determine which
variation performs better lastly node.js
server maintenance is simpler than its
counterparts moving on to the last topic
of this session industry trends now
node.js developers are in demand across
the globe since many companies are
adopting javascript libraries according
to forbes it is one of the top 10 most
in demand jobs according to note source
the total number of node.js downloads
increased by 40 in the last one year the
use of node.js in production has
increased dramatically since its release
in 2010. with early adopters such as
linkedin paypal and netflix among others
node.js has seen an exponential increase
in its use in web development the
popularity of node.js is also accounted
to javascript now since javascript is
the most popular language as evident
from a survey conducted by stack
overflow in 2019 many developers can
start working on node.js library with
not much of a learning curve node.js
developers are being offered better
salary options than other web technology
developers according to pay scale the
average salary of a node.js developer in
india is around 6 lakhs 13 000 rupees
per year the average salary of a node.js
developer across the united states is
around 105 000 us dollars per year in
this video we'll help you install
node.js on your windows system so
without further ado let's begin the
first thing you need to do is download
node.js from their official website
so go ahead and type
download
node.js
navigate to their official website
and here
you can see the 64-bit version so go
ahead and download that once the
download is done go ahead and run the
downloaded node.js installer
accept the license agreement keep the
default settings as it is
and then say install
so with that we finished the
installation process
once node has been successfully
installed the next crucial step is
verification now this process ensures
that node has been properly installed
to do so we first open the command
prompt and then type in a few commands
to verify the successful installation we
type in this command
node hyphen v now this command returns
the version and if it returns the
version it means it has been
successfully installed
so here we go it returns the latest
version
now the final step is to update the node
package manager now this npm is bundled
with node.js which consists of all the
repositories and packages required for
development purposes so to do that type
in the command
npm
install
hyphen hyphen
global now that we're done with the
installation of node let's go ahead and
implement a small program for that we
make use of a text editor in our case
we've installed vs code so go ahead and
download vs code once you're done with
the installation this is what vs code
looks like so go ahead and click on file
and create a new file it's going to be a
simple program where you're going to
print a hello world message on the web
browser to do that we make use of http
modules so node comes with built-in http
modules to transfer data across it
so for that we make use of a require
method we create a variable first say
var
http
equals required
and just say http within single quotes
now the http module can create an http
server that listens to the server ports
and gives a response back to the client
to do that we make use of the create
server method so let's go ahead and type
the code
say http
dot create
server and internally it consists of a
function
now the parameters to this function are
request and response now the response is
basically used to write to the client so
we say response dot write and here we
type in the message say hello world
welcome
to this tutorial
once you're done with that you end the
response
so the server listens to a port number
to display the message by default it
listens to the port number 8080. so we
keep that as it is and we end it save
your file say
demo.js maybe demo1.js and say save now
to run the program you have to open the
command prompt so open your command
prompt
and mention the path to your file so in
our case it's our desktop on the desktop
so cd
desktop and now to run it say node
demo1 dot js now you navigate to your
browser
and say localhost 8080 and here we go
our message is successfully displayed so
let's talk about the node.js
architecture and understand why it's so
good
so to begin with node.js has what's
called a single threaded event loop
architecture and this allows you to be
able to handle
many many concurrent clients at the same
time it's just a very flexible way of
being able to scale up your support for
many clients
and then in addition to that we have the
javascript event based model along with
the javascript callback mechanism that
allows you to have this standard
approach to being able to connect with
and talk and discuss
interactions between the client and the
server
it's good to have these kind of
standards where you're not using
something that's unique to a specific
framework or a specific technology this
just makes it so it's a more accessible
for everybody
so if we look at the actual node.js
server itself everything centers it
around the the concept of the event loop
and the event loop has a
an event queue an operation completed um
fire requests threaded pull and then
it'll actually do the actual computation
or the file system interaction
all of this interconnects in a nice
seamless loop the great thing again with
node.js is that it's not new technology
it's been around for almost a decade
it's very very well tried out many of
the largest websites out there are
running node.js
so let's now dig into each of the parts
of the node.js architecture so let's
talk about requests
so the way that the request works is
that you have your framework uh such as
angular
on the client and that will then send a
request to the website and there's many
ways that those requests can happen
through web workers through forms and
through other interactions
but at some point a request is sent to
the server
and so these requests can be for data
they can be for deleting data they can
be for updating data they can be for
interacting with services as mentioned
before but the goal is to have some kind
of request now once that request
actually hits the server and then we
start actually getting into the cueing
and threading process that centers
around the event loop and this is where
node.js really excels because it's able
to use that single threaded model to be
able to manage from just even a few
requests to tens of millions of requests
so it receives the actual request and
starts the event queue and this is where
a single threading process starts is by
cueing everything up appropriately
and then it then maintains the threads
within a pool so you have the cueing
process as one action and then you have
a threaded pull which manages those um
threads as well
and then we have an event loop which you
know goes through actually receives and
processes those requests
and then finally what we're doing is
we're actually they're going to be
interacting with a system and that could
be a database it could be a cloud system
it could be an api file system but we're
interacting with something that's
outside of the node.js server so the
node.js server itself is doing some
actions on the server
but then it's also interact with things
outside of its own server environment
and so let's talk a little bit about
that workflow
so requests come in they go into the
event queue and they get spiraled
through the event loop and then we have
a non-blocking operators which are going
to be doing the input output polling
such as kq epoll and other services and
from there we're also going to be then
interacting with the threaded pull and
we're using the blocking operations to
manage that threaded pull
and that threaded pole is going to now
then go outside of the server and
interact with something beyond the
server so whether that is a database or
file system or api or microservice these
are things that can be interacted with
so let's go through what npm is
so npm itself stands for the node
package manager
no
great shakes there as the name says it's
responsible for all the packages and
modules that are bundled within node.js
so the notepad manager itself really has
two key functionalities and the first is
that reply it is a central repository
for all packages and modules which you
can then search through um online you
can go to
search.nodejs.org and you can find all
of the packages and modules that are out
there
the second is that it's also a command
line or terminal uh line utility that
allows you to install those packages so
you can actually go through and you can
see the version management and
dependencies that within those packages
and you actually can control the
packages themselves
so why would you use npm
so npm is really useful for being able
to extend the project you're working on
so when you're building out a project
one of the concepts i like to use is the
concept of lego bricks um big fan of
lego and
what's great about lego bricks is that
they're all individually by themselves
very small very specific functionality
but if you actually get a whole
collection of lego bricks together you
can build like crazy cool things so
think of when you're working with the
node package manager itself is that each
of those individual pieces that you're
working with um each of those individual
packages are their own lego bricks and
by themselves you can then edit and
update and maintain that piece um
separately from the whole environment as
long as your inputs and outputs they are
really the piece where you snap the lego
in or when you connect lego to something
else um are interactive and open and
well documented then you can actually
then use those modules effectively
throughout your project
um so you can actually then be able to
do that you can do version control on
your codes and dependencies you can do
testing very easily
and then once you actually get to the
point where you go yes i want to release
um a new module you can do that
effectively using npm and it will
actually go through and do the actual
deployment for you
so let's go through the npm installation
so the actual package manager itself is
included with the installation of
node.js so if you've installed and
you're running node.js
locally then you've already installed
the package manager uh but you can also
access it through command line or
terminal window um on your your data
server or in your server phone or in via
the cloud
uh if you haven't now downloaded node.js
here's the website where you can go down
to install it and there's windows and
mac versions of that uh code as well
with the installers which allow you to
get up and going very quickly
uh you want to be able to run the
installer and accept all the default
settings uh just um you know to begin
with you want to kind of have the
standard setup so that you are most
familiar with the normal settings before
you start getting to the point where
you're a master and you're tweaking
things
um there is a way that you can open up
the command window or the terminal
window
and uh once you've actually installed
node.js um to verify that uh it's
actually installed you can write command
node dash dash version and i'll actually
then pull out the version of node.js
that you have uh installed and then
you'll be able to see that you've got it
you're actually up and running
and then you can also do the same thing
for npm we can do apm dash dash version
and it actually will then show you which
version of the note package manager you
have running so you can actually take it
full advantage of that program and
verify that it's actually up and running
so let's actually look inside of a
package so packages themselves are
actually just json files if you're new
to this space json file is a structured
file format that's based on javascript
it's a very xml like format
for being able to
write instructions for the actual
package itself and so the json file
forms that you know really kind of the
the heart of each package you create
um it has all of the metadata that you'd
have about a particular object
and then it provides a route directly to
any of the applications or modules
that the package may be referencing
um in addition and it has any other
additional
information about the project that has
such as dependencies and other files
that need to be included so here we have
is an example of a package and that
would be created
using npm json script
and you can actually take this package
file as it is right here um and use um
the command npm in it and it'll actually
run this package and so you would
actually have a demo application up and
running really quickly
uh you can then go ahead if you want to
you can edit any of these parameters so
like for instance if you wanted to
change the description or the version uh
or what is the the main index script
that would be written you know these are
all things that you can edit very
quickly and easily you can just use text
editor to make any of these edits
and so we have the different metadata
that can be updated
and so this is where we go in and do a
full demo of working with npm
so what we're going to do now is we're
actually going to go ahead and actually
run a demo of using npm and to do that
i've got three windows in front of me
right now so i have this window here
which is my terminal window
where i'll be doing all my instructions
then i also have a
folder which shows where i'll be putting
all of the files and then finally i'll
actually have a text editor in this case
i'm using vs code because it's free
but you can use any text editor you like
to be able to go in and show what the
code that's been created
by mpm in the json file so you can
actually see what it looks like
and then we'll modify it a little bit so
first thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead and create a
new project folder so i'm going to go in
i'm just going to move into
i'm going to do
change directory i'm going to
the project folder
and we'll see down here that we have an
empty project folder um but for this one
i'm actually going to go ahead and i'm
going to create a new directory in this
one and i'm going to call this one
simply learn
and there we are we've created a new
simplyland folder
and we are going to
move into the simplyland folder
and so we're now in the simply line
folder uh there's nothing in there right
now so the first thing we want to do is
we want to take uh go ahead and
initialize this folder as a project
folder for working with npm now to do
this you will have to already installed
npm if you have no js npm comes with it
and if you want to see whether or not
you have npm installed so you can just
do npm
version and that will actually tell you
what the version of npm you have
installed is and it also verifies that
npm is installed so i've gone ahead and
i've been able to validate that i have
npm installed so what i'm now going to
go ahead and do is i'm going to
initialize this folder so to do that
just do npm init and you'll see that the
path is that we're already in the
simplyland folder and then when you do
that
it's going to ask you some questions so
what is the package name we're going to
go with the defaults for right now and
then i can show you how we can edit
those in a little bit uh we're going to
go with just say yes to all of these
just by hitting return
and you'll see here that we're going to
create a new folder called a
package.json folder this is the
instructions that we have in the folder
do you want to go ahead and create this
we want to and it's going to go ahead
and do that and we can see now in our
folder here that we actually have
package.json so we go ahead and open
this up with
vs code
here we are we can actually see what all
of the information is we can go ahead
and we can actually go and update uh
this metadata if we want to i'm going to
leave it as is for right now because i
want to show you a couple of other
things so a lot of times when you're
actually working
with npm
and the reason why you're using npm is
that you want to take advantage of
packages that are freely available in
the open source community that are
supported by node.js and one of those is
a package called express and express is
a lightweight framework for building out
uh web applications similar concept
to angular or react.js
i like using it and it's also a great
way to be able to
show how we can
install this using npm so to install
this
you just start with the command npm and
then you type install
and then we type the name of the package
and we hit
enter
and it goes ahead
and what you'll actually see
is a couple of things one is we have a
dependency in our package above
we also have
so this is in our json package that is
now a dependency it's written in there
we can also go in and under our node
modules we actually see that we have
we scroll down we should see express
there it is express
now if we decide that we don't want to
use
express we can actually just come in and
we can write command npm
uninstall
i can type
express
oops
did i typo that let's try that again npm
uninstall
express
and a couple of things going to happen
one is
in our json file the dependency for the
express file has now been removed
and we can also see that under our node
modules there are no extensions there
so this is kind of cool this allows us
to be able to see um that we can
easily add and remove packages
uh so let's just go ahead and i'm going
to install express again so
install
express
npm install express
all right so it's gone ahead and it's
installed express
now one of the things that often happen
is that when you're working with a
package the actual json
package so you'll receive uh this file
and you want to be able to go ahead and
uh install of the um sub modules that
come with it so and you can go through
you can manually install them like this
or you can actually run an install
command so you can actually install all
of them at once i can just show you what
that looks like
because we're going to actually go ahead
and simulate as if we're going to
install bootstrap
which is another
popular framework
stream
and we're actually gonna go with
and then we'll save that
and what we'll see is under the packages
that bootstrap isn't listed in there we
do have
express there it is right there
so we now come over to
our
new commands we can actually write the
command
npm install
and now
site typo let's try that again
let's do npm
install
it does help to save your file so let's
go ahead and
let's run npm install
and when you do that what we'll now
actually have is not just express but
we'll also see that bootstrap has also
been added
now i don't recommend that you use the
star symbol which will install the
latest version of bootstrap because you
obviously haven't tested your
application against that but it gives
you an idea of
what's happened here now if we want to
we can actually go in here and we can
say
i'm in
install
bootstrap
and it will actually remove that from
your json package so there we are that's
how you work with using npm from getting
started with a setup for a base
initialization of your
package going through to creating the
first package and being able to set up
and control the naming convention for
each of the items within the metadata
that provides the instruction for uh the
package how you can then put in
dependencies such as express and
bootstrap how you can install them and
remove them and actually use do all of
this through command line if you have
any questions yeah please let us know
so let's kind of jump into the
express.js framework
so express.js is a really flexible
node.js and web application framework it
is just something you can spin up very
quickly and build both web and mobile
applications just
a really great tool um you know i use it
all the time for building up my own
applications
um the thing that's so great about it is
it's really simple and so
it's not going to be as have all the the
functionality that you'd have in maybe a
larger scale http service
but with that said it does come with a
lot of functionality that allows you to
not only create websites but you can
also do apis and other routing calls
very very nice
so let's go through some of the features
that express js have
so as i mentioned before it allows you
to build simple web applications and
that can be either a single page
application or a multi-page application
um it also allows you to do middleware
requests and responses so for instance
if you want to do an api
and have that be part of your middleware
you can actually set that up real
quickly in fact in the demo that we'll
do later on we'll actually be building
out four different api calls that you'll
be able to do and you'll be able to see
how you can use express.js for that
and that in then turns allows you to be
able to see how express.js can help
manage some of the routing of the
different um http methods and that you'd
be using via url
and then finally it's just a great way
of being able to uh dynamically test the
work that you are developing so you can
actually build out a solution and test
it right away in express js have it in a
single packet and then once you get to a
certain point you can then check in the
whole packet
even have it as part of your container
and then check that into your
main project
and then if somebody else wants to then
take on the work they can then just pull
that in
so let's kind of go step through you
know a basic example so here we actually
have a full script for creating a simple
hello world and this includes installing
express.js
defining the ports it's going to run on
as well as a basic piece of code so the
first thing you want to do is actually
go ahead and define how you want to
install express.js and this is called
the very first variable which is
requiring that express be installed as
part of node packet manager
npm will then pull in the latest version
of express if you need to define a
specific version of course you can do
that
in this example we're just going to pull
the latest one and then we'll go ahead
and with the second line which will then
install express and when you do it once
you'll see how quickly it installs onto
your local development machine
the next parameters are actually a
callback function so if something
actually happens when you go to the
website where we're going to run our web
application you want something to pop up
and in this instance we'll say hello it
will pop up
the third block is all about where you
would actually go ahead and host your
code and so in this one you'll see that
the
server is going to listen and listen to
port 8081 so that's what that function
actually there defines
and then you can either put in uh the a
specific host address
in the demo you'll actually see how we
define that for localhost but you can
actually then point this to a production
host environment if you want
and then the final line here is a
command that actually sent a
script to your terminal window telling
you that which port and which host that
you are listening to so let's see what
that would look like so here we go see
have our terminal window and we're
actually able to then
run the hello world js script that we
just
wrote and then once we do that it'll
actually then post that we have an
example app listening at
and here we don't have a
web domain address and we do have the
port 8081
and in our browser window it says hello
world
so that's a quick breakdown of
express.js now let's jump over and do a
demo
so the first thing we want to do to get
express up and running on our system is
we have to have node.js installed so
we're just going to do a google search
to let you know where you can find
node.js it's actually at nodejs.org
so we select that link that will take us
to nodejs.org and there are two types of
downloads one is the current download
which has
the latest features and then there's a
more stable version that if you're new
to node.js i'd recommend you to download
next we want to find a text editor and
we're going to go with visual studio
code or vs code as known
it's an open source solution from
microsoft that runs across all the
leading platforms this will default to
our windows platform but you can run it
on mac os and linux as well i really
like it it's a great code editor it
comes a lot of extensions and it's open
source
and next thing you want to do is because
we're going to be developing apis we
want a way to be able to visualize those
apis quickly and a great tool is a
product called postman
again open source and so you can go out
and go to postman.com
uh top right hand corner you'll see a
bright orange download button where you
can actually go and head and download
and install postman and that will allow
you to be able to access
all of your apis that we're going to be
creating in express
you can actually use other tools such as
apigee as well for visualizing your apis
but this one's just great to get you
started so let's go ahead and open up
vs code and we want to go ahead and open
a new folder where we're going to have
our project we're going to just for our
demonstration here we're going to put
this on the desktop you wouldn't
normally do this but it'll work fine
here we're going to create a folder i'm
going to title the file the node express
and we'll select that folder that now
becomes the root folder for our project
in visual studio uh we don't really need
the the welcome
screen anymore so we're going to get rid
of that
and one of things that is great about
working with vs code is you can actually
have the terminal window up and running
as well so let's go ahead and open that
so it's running at the bottom of our
screen and this gives us a little bit of
space
and the first thing we want to do is
actually turn convert the folder in
actually into a project running node.js
so we're going to use npm in it and
they'll actually initialize the project
we have another video that explains how
to use npm or node package manager and
you can go ahead and find that in our
library here but as we go ahead and we
do that you'll actually see that it will
create the default package
json file which has uh the
name of the folder is the default name
of the package but you can actually go
in and edit any of these documents we
want to create a default file that's
called index.js
this is where we're going to write most
of our scripts that allow us to work
with node.js
and the first is writing a script that
allows us to install express and
we'll use the node packet manager to
actually pull and install express
and you can default to specific versions
of express if you want and we're just
going to go with the latest one so we're
just going to put in express and then
we'll go down into terminal window and
say npm install
save express and this will install
express so we can actually test out the
code we're working on and let's take
just a moment to install
great thing we're working with node
package manager is that once we finish
with our package here we can actually
wrap it all up and send it over to any
other developer that we're working with
and then you can actually
run the the package and actually have
exactly the same code installed
and there we are we have everything
installed and ready to go
you can see we actually have all the
modules installed you see that we
actually have express installed as well
and we also want to then make this an
app
and then we'll do app
listen
to port 3000 so this is by default we're
going to be running from our local host
which is uh http server running on
this test machine and we're going to
have express for this project
run on port 3000
and in the once we actually run the
script we'll actually post into the
console
window a
piece of text saying server started on
port 3000
so we're going to go ahead and save this
file
a little control s to save these files
so let's go into localhost in our web
browser so localhost colon sorry yeah
it's localhost column3000
and you'll see nothing has been reached
that's because we actually haven't done
anything to initialize the script so we
want to come in and we're going to go
nodeindex.js and hit return and as you
can see now we have a message in our
console window that means that yep there
we go we actually have everything up and
running
so we can actually see that the service
is running not a very pleasant message
so let's go ahead and change that
so let's change that to
app get
and
require res
and so if you use the get message that's
change
what we'll print
and we'll type hello
there
exclamation mark
and we save that
and we refresh the screen
oh nothing happening yet because we
didn't run the script let's go back in
and we'll run the script node index.js
and now what you'll see is if we refresh
there we are we have our new hello there
message all right well let's actually
start building some apis in this
environment
so to be able to build the apis we want
to be able to pull
content so we can actually
create a new file called users.js
and we're going to create
we're going to go ahead and create a a
user's json packet and adjacent packet
is essentially
a
an array um
consider it like a small database and in
this array we're going to have four
objects each object is going to have uh
three pieces of uh metadata we have an
id name and email and there'll be
id one two and three and then you'll see
that the names will be
john smith and
we'll make up a couple of others
i'm just kind of giving them arbitrary
email addresses
it's just for our demo
here let me grab this copy it and
kind of speed up
the script writing time
there we go
and let's just change what we need
one of the things that's nice with
working with a visual studio
code vs code is there's lots of plugins
and so one of the default features is
that if you
select a variable you'll actually look
for the same variable in the script so
you can if you need to you can actually
change them all
once
but we don't need to worry about that
right now we're just creating a json
packet so we have four items
id one two three and four
for john smith and jack and chris
all right so that's our
array string and we're going to then
make sure that we can export that as
users so we can actually now whenever we
select the term users in our scripts
it'll actually pull in this packet
all right looking good
now let's go over to our main index.js
file and we're just going to go ahead
and we want to
like
store where
the the api is going to be so we're
going to create a
folder called routes and then a
subfolder called
api then we'll call a file in there
called users.js so as we're updating our
scripts we know where to
pull the data from
it's just a standard way of being able
to pull out the values so in here we're
going to say
in this instance express is required
for our scripts
and we're going to also say that router
within express router
correct
naming convention
and the script is case sensitive we'll
also want to create a value later on
that will have a unique id so we're
actually going to
pull in a uuid
package that will actually then allow us
to install
unique identifiers so we use node
package manager to install
uuid
again this is a great example of how you
can go from nothing to something very
quickly
with exp
nodejs because we installed express we
installed uuid and we're off to the
races
so let's have users require
the path for where
our api is going to be located
all right so let's do a basic
get
which will be to pull the record so
we're going to have it pull
all the records so router.get and
we're going to require it to pull all of
the records in the json packet that we
created
so there should be four items to come
back
save that
looks good
make sure that users is consistent
there's our adjacent packet
and
yep everything looking pretty good
all right let's go back to index
and we're going to switch out
this function here from just a generic
get with a generic
statement to
actually being able to pull in the users
so
we have to go
app
use express.json
lab dot use
url encoded
extended
false
and dot use
api
users so
we're going to be pulling them all from
the same location
require
and where we have our api
scripts
okay
and then let's go ahead and open up
postman because we're going to actually
use postman to actually show us what the
results look like because right now the
results
won't show up appropriately
um in our browser window
so postman again is just a api
management tool if you used apigee or
other similar tools that are on the
market mulesoft um you'll see it's very
consistent again this is open source
and
what you want to be able to do is you
can actually go and actually go to the
path where the api is stored
and then you can use all the different
types of commands within
your
environment to be able to you know test
out the scripts so let's go ahead and
create a new project a new request and
we go with the default get but there's
actually quite a lot of different
commands we can use
these are just http commands
we're going to type in the request and
in this instance
it's going to be
let's run our script first
script
let's make sure we're exporting the data
correctly
okay
so we want to run our script so let's do
node index.js and that will
run the changes that we just created so
we can now come over to get we select
api
localhost colon 3000
slash api
users
when we do
that brings back
the
json package with our four
entry points
there there's all four of them
so that's your
first action now let's kind of get this
a little bit tighter let's actually go
in and see if we can filter by id
so we're going to go in and we're going
to modify our script so it's going to be
route
and then we're going to put in the
filter and in this instance it's going
to be id
which would allow us to be able to just
put a backslash against the
end of the url string we just had and
put in a number or a unique identifier
and then that will actually then allow
us to pull in that unique record
okay
that's the data
okay so i have
[Music]
i'm found to
take the json and
print it
so we're going to filter here against
user id
and then
publish the results
else
if it doesn't work then we'll just have
a
generic
error message
we shouldn't see this though in the
demos we're creating
this is just
good practice
so save that
and let's go ahead and rerun
our node index file
against that
folder
and now we can actually come in here and
we do backslash one and that will give
us just one record
and we could change that to 2 or 100 in
this instance and if it's 100
we'll just get a bad request error
message
there's two
all right
so that's get so be able to pull all the
records we know to filter against one
specific record against a specific
parameter in this instance it was id so
let's go ahead and create a new user so
that what we can do for this is we're
going to use the post
command from http to actually push and
post data into
the data source the data sources are
json packet which means that we'll have
to then push a new record into the json
package using our array statements
because json is just essentially an
array
and so we're going to
post and when we do this we have to
create a unique id so this is where we
have to reference the uid i'm going to
do a v4 unique id
which will be
four groups of four so it'll be 16
characters
and then
we'll have
name
and email we'll post
okay looks good
okay so
if
new user
input dot name
and
new user dot email
and then we want to return
the results
okay
all right and so users
dot
push so
we posted which is a http statement and
then pushing into the
adjacent packet array
okay
okay it's looking good
all right so
i think we're good
let's go ahead and rerun our script
nodeindex.js
that allows us to do that so let's go
over to postman so we can actually
connect to
the url i'm going to change
the http statement to post
and
get rid of that go back to users now if
we just do this
nothing's going to happen so we actually
have to go in and we have to update the
body
and this would be the content that will
be passed through and we're going to go
through with a raw
statement
here and we do json this will be
that's the packet we're sending so let's
go ahead and the records we want to
update we only have to update two which
is one is name and the second is email
we don't have to do an id because we're
using uuid to generate an automatic one
for us
and we're going to create records for
staff and her email address is steph
gmail.com
yep looking good
okay so let's go ahead and send that
we sent it
and if we look at the bottom we can
actually now see that we have five
records so a new one's been added we
have our unique id at the top
and then we have name and email which
are the ones that we just created for
staff and staff at gmail.com
all right
so that's posting now the next thing you
want to do is to update a record so that
means we need to select an id
and then be able to update the content
and for that we're going to use the http
put command
so we'll use id as our way to be able to
filter
and then we'll be able to update against
that filter
so
construct found
of course
users
and
then whatever going is
user's id
so we know how to get the correct record
and then pass the record back
onto the screen so we know what we're
editing
so if
so if failed
i'm going to update
the user
and i'm going to go ahead and pull
information from the body for what will
be updated
and for each
diffuser id
then pass
the integer
okay
[Music]
so this is our values to pass against
the id
and in this instance make sure that
we're updating the values of
username
so if we are
updating user
and we're just updating the username we
want to
make sure that that's the value that
gets updated
and then we also want to do user email
we don't want to update the id so it's
going to remain unique and consistent
okay i'm going to make sure that
everything is pushed to the
json package
and then we'll also have a message
saying that
the field has been updated in the json
package
okay
all right so we'll run that script again
and looks good so let's go to our folder
let's change the http
post let's put it as get
just so we can see that we have
uh all of the values in the array from
the jsonpacket
and now we want to say put which allows
us to
update just
one record
so let's go ahead and select one record
we'll select it1 so
we have one record we can go ahead and
for name we can change this
so let's go ahead and change these
so now you see that the email has
changed so we have staff
as the new account
all right our final api that we're going
to create is to delete an account and in
many ways it's actually a very basic api
because what we're doing is we're
grabbing the id and then we're saying
that all the associated records with
that id
um within
that row
as it were in the table just to delete
the whole row
and so
we want to use
again our id as
the unique value that we're
pulling against
so we're going to if users are found
and we're going to
filter those users
i'm going to do that filter against user
id
pass that
and
let go and
post a message to our json packet saying
user
deleted
a
generic message if things fail
okay let's save that and we'll
see we go ahead and we're using we're
just deleting the record now
and we're going to do it by filtering
against a unique id
and then you will then just eliminate
that record
and pass the message that has been
the account has been deleted
okay so we save that let's go run our
script
node index.js
good okay has come over here and
we're going to
show that we can pull any of the
accounts so let's just take one of them
one that's good
so let's go ahead and we're going to
change
the http command to delete
and we actually have to
select an account so we just do one
when we do that it'll actually delete
that record and here we are um it says
that the user has been deleted and we
now only have
three records in the json packet
and we can pull all the records
and you'll see that there's only three
so being able to
pull all the records from adjacent
package we'll be able to create a record
update a record and delete a record
and we can just step through so here's
our json package that we created
originally again this is just an array
it's just a different way of setting up
the array
and then we have our index files which
identifies what are the apps that need
to be installed and where are the api is
going to be serviced out of
and that we're going to be doing this on
the port
um again these are additional tools that
we need to make sure and that we have up
and running um in our script and so the
first script was to get all the um the
records seconds to filter against a user
id for just a specific record and then
for creating a record we actually went
in and we used the uid tool to create a
unique identifier and then we posted in
the data for the new records we did
something similar with updating the
record we didn't have to update the user
id we just had to update the values in
the two fields that we needed to be
updated
in this case name and email
and the final step was to go ahead and
delete a record so these are all
apis that you can now pull into your own
application so you can use them in web
applications or you can actually go
ahead and use them in other applications
such as mobile applications
local applications and other scripts and
this really allows your application to
become
more scalable
and more useful
hello and we're going to go through and
do our demo of building a restful api
with node.js so the first thing we want
to do is go ahead and install all the
correct pieces of software we're going
to start with node.js so let's do a
google search on node.js and you'll find
that
node.js is at
node.js.org so we select that link
and that's going to take us to the
node.js website and there are two
versions of node.js you can download
there's the stable version and then
there's the latest version i'd go with
the stable version you'll find it
available in windows mac awares and
linux as well
and if we go to the next piece of
software we want to go ahead and install
the text editor of your choice um i'm
going to use visual studio code vs code
it's an open source solution it works on
all leading platforms
works really well i like it a lot
microsoft did a good job with this i
also really like it that it's open
source but there's lots of extensions
you can get for vs code um so it's a
great text editor
and we'll also need postman postman is a
tool that allows us to be able to view
the apis that we're going to create so
let's go ahead to postman.com and again
it's another
solution you can download for free and
so we're going to go ahead and select
the download button
and it'll automatically detect which os
you're on so in this case it's going to
be windows but you can also get mac and
linux as well so we'll go ahead and
download those
and once we have everything installed
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a project in vs code and that's
actually really easy to do all you have
to do is create a folder
and we do this right off our desktop
and we're going to call the folder node
rest api and we'll select that folder
and you'll see on the left hand column
that we have the new folder that we
created uh we still have the vs code
welcome screen we can get rid of that we
don't need that anymore so
let's go ahead and one of the things i
like with vs code is you can actually
toggle the terminal window so let's go
ahead and open up the terminal window so
we can actually run that at the same
time and so we're going to
move our cursor to the folder we just
created and there we are you can see
that
and what we can do now is we're going to
initialize this with node package
manager
to make this a package
and it's going to go ahead i'm going to
ask for a name we're just going to go
with the default so we're just going to
say yes yes to a couple of these
yep enter
and
enter
enter and turn
and turn and is this okay
yep enter
all right so now we have a new file and
this is our json package it has all the
defaults in it we can go in and modify
these if you want to uh no need to for
this exercise but you may want to for
the solution that you're putting
together
and we're going to create a new file
called index.js and this is going to be
the reference file that's in the json
package
for npm
and here we're going to put in our
solutions that we absolutely have to
have
for this to run so we're going to
install express and express
is a web service application but it's
very flexible and one of the things that
we're going to use it for today is build
apis
so in our terminal window we're going to
type npm install
save express
this will install express locally on our
machine
and takes a few minutes but it's going
to go and download all the latest
features this is going to be the latest
version of express you can if you want
to um specify a specific version of
software
for these examples there's no need to do
that
so you'll see that everything has been
installed we expand the the node module
we can scroll down and indeed yep there
we are we see express has been installed
along with some other
pieces that are useful
all right so that's our first piece
and the next
is we're going to define our app and our
app is going to
use express
and we want express as a local host on
our local machine on port 3000 so we've
identified port 3000 as the default port
for our application
and
we are going to now create
a an array
for some movies
and we're going to have id title
director and release date
exception great movie
and director christopher
nolan
and
that was released
in 2010 yes 10 years ago
okay so we're going to do and a couple
of items here and just so that we
have some more than one entry in our
array and array is a javascript
uh you can think of it as a very simple
uh table which allows us to have
structured data
uh you can also do a json file you can
also connect to
a database mongodb or something like
that
2019.
okay so we have two movies in our
little array
maybe more than enough right now
a key part is that we have a consistent
structure for the array of id title
director and release date
and so we're going to
create
two
apis one is going to be a get api where
we'll get the list
of the items in our api and the second
will be a post where we'll be actually
pushing in a new item so let's go ahead
and start with the get and what we want
to do is we're going to say get slash
movie
and
we are going to have this run as an api
and so
what we'll do is we will test this in a
moment
and this will be running from our web
browser and actually we'll probably open
up the postman and run this through
postman so
okay
that pause all the movies
and we'll do a another um
get in a moment will filter by movie id
but let's just get them all for right
now
and we are going to
listen
on a server port in this instance it's
going to be port 3000
and
we already had defined the port as a
variable earlier and which
um so we're just referencing the
variable and the port number is the step
the
top in line four
just a text string that's going to get
put to the terminal window
and it is going to dynamically
grab the port the value from the
variable from 3000
and place it in our text string easy
and we want to save the file
and now we're going to go ahead and run
it so we're going to do node index.js
that runs the script
and tells us that we're listening on
port 3000 that's great
that means now that we should be able to
go into postman
and
[Music]
grab the data from an api
so here's postman if you've not used it
before it's a great tool for being able
to manage apis i strongly encourage you
to have a go with this so we're going to
get the get command and we've done any
applications web applications you've
probably used get and post
for the data um that you're
pulling and pushing from forms online
same principle
so we want to go ahead and
we're going to go and
grab get i'm going to type in localhost
and
it's going to be colon 3000
slash
movies because that's the
the name of the
file
and we hit send and
what we get as a response
is
the
data in our query
sorry in our array here we go so there's
our array and the data values have been
pulled back by postman
that's great
so now we want to go ahead and add a
movie
to our array
and we're going to do that we're going
to use the
post
command
and get and post are http
commands
and so we're going to use movies
and
in this instance
we're going to
push the value
into
our list
so construction movie requires we're
going to need
a structure here and that structure is
going to be
the information that's in there the body
and then we're going to
push to
the log
our terminal window
and push
so here we're using
push
and that's a term in for arrays within
javascript where we push the data into
the actual array itself
there are lots of ways of being able to
control data within an array if you're
new to arrays with javascript i strongly
encourage you to
learn more about them there's just an
awful lot you can do with them
and then we want to have a validation
message come up on the screen saying yes
movie has been added to the list so
we'll save what we've just created
and we don't save it it won't show up
and then we're going to re-run
the
nodeindex.js file
you see this we've created here
already
a an api that allows us to pull and push
data
in and out of a variable
okay so let's go back and we're going to
change the
header from being get to being push
so we're going to use sorry not push our
post so i'm going to say post and then
what we want to do is the
value inside of the body
and so let's go over
[Music]
and we want to select body
and we're playing text
and select json so it's going to be
structured
and so here we will essentially copy
the structure we have here so let's go
ahead and just
copy these elements
and we have to give it an id because we
don't have an auto generated id so we're
going to make this id
and then
and it's going to be a number 3.
and then you want to put in
title
new movie i'll put in
director
[Music]
and
we'll have this as
i don't know
new
director
not very creative here today
and then
we need to put in a date
so release underscore date
let's just put in a date
today's date will be fine
um just so you know that we're not
formatting the date column let's
so let's go ahead and we'll select send
and this will actually go and we can see
hello boom movies been added to our list
and we can go back and let's go ahead
and validate that so we're going to
change from post to get
use the same
and
now we go to below
oh looks like we put an error in
our formatting
so let's go
to
pass the json
and we will pass it using express
and this will
clear up any formatting issues
so
app.use express json
express
url encoded
extended
false
and this should help us pass
our
value
and then we'll rerun that script
make sure you save the previous file
otherwise it will run the new script
all right looking good so let's go back
and
let's go back to
our
localhost 3000
slash movies
and there's only two values here
so what we need to do now is change from
get to post
we'll go to body
and what we're going to do is we want to
have
raw jason
and
what we want to do is capture the values
that we have below
and insert
this
file into this new
json packet
into
our array
let you just copy that
it's a little bit cheating but it's
remain same so let's go ahead
and
[Music]
get everything consistent
then we'll change the number to three
we're creating a unique title badging
sorry new title doesn't need to be
unique just the id needs to be
unique so title new movie
director change it to new director
and change the date
i'm not doing any formatting on the data
any date any number really
hit save
movies been added to our list
so it's been added but now let's go back
to get and let's see if we can actually
see the third entry and scroll down
and there we are we've actually pushed
that
json package into our array
so we now have three items in
the hoping added fire our api
okay
so
now let's go ahead and search
our movie database i guess we only have
three entries but you know we want to be
able to so we can do that by using the
get command and what we'll be doing is
we'll be validating against
a specific id number uh so we have three
and we're going to
validate against
just the id number um in this instance
um the way to do it is through the url
so beforehand we had localhost colin3000
slash movie now we're adding in uh slash
movie slash and then whatever number of
that will actually filter against the id
and
that's essentially what we're doing here
right now
so we're going to go into f movies
dot id again we're using the id value to
actually pull from our arraylist
with my variables and arrays mixed up
here today
and then once we actually have the value
we'll actually post back as a json
packet
and
if we have any errors then what we'll do
is we'll throw up message movie not
found so
there we are we're going to pull against
an id
and we should be able to then pull that
up
through postman
into
our terminal window
again the reason why we're using postman
is that this is actually just showing
the values going back and forth we're
not having to render a whole web page
it's extremely fast very efficient
all right
so we saved and rerun our script
all right let's go back and what we're
going to do is we're going to change the
value so we're going to hit send here we
are we see all of our movies using the
get command now what we're going to do
is we're going to use a look filter just
id2 which is the irishman so do slash 2
and there we are we have just the
information on the irishman
so now you can see how you can create a
simple search
all right
so the final action we want to do is to
delete a record in our array
and so
we can go ahead and do that
and we're going to use the uh
delete command to actually do that so
we'll be able to
push um
in a
record we've been able to
view records filter guide games records
now we're going to go ahead and do
delete and so we can do app delete and
then we're going to filter by
specific id number
and when we do this we'll actually then
uh when we put in the url path which
will be localhost code 3000 slash movie
slash and then the id number so this is
inside that one or two probably use two
that will then
delete from
our array
the record for the argument
[Music]
i do the shortcut add a keyboard drop
out of control s
to save files on
windows or command plus s on my mac
and
[Music]
once we've deleted a record we want to
send a message saying that the
movie has been deleted
all right so we want to go ahead
and
let's just check our code
looking good save our file
and we want to
the
index.js file
yep
rerun okay let's go to postman
and grab
the delete
so again we're filtering against the
movie id and then we'll delete that id
okay so we went against the argument and
we hit send
and there it is
now we're going to change
the command to delete
so we hit
one we'll actually delete conception
movie has been deleted it's great
and let's go ahead and
grab our use get to
pull in all the movies that
are listed and it's not going to find
movie number with their id1 it's not
there anymore
and if we get all the movies
we see we only have one movie and that's
the irishman and so our delete function
has worked
there we are so we've installed express
we're using express to build all of our
applications we have our app running on
port 3000
we are using express
to pass the json
effectively back and forth we have a
simple array that array is then being
used to create an api to pull the
details then we're being able to add a
movie then search for a movie a
filtering against an id
and then
we can actually finally go ahead and
delete a movie
all this using
express.js today we're going to be
covering node.js authentication using
jwt or json web tokens so let's get
started so
why are we going to go down this path so
let's cover the key things that you need
to be asking yourself such as what is a
json web token
what is the value of using a json web
token and then what does the actual
structure of the jwt look like
and then let's go through some use cases
of where you'd actually use jwts uh both
in the enterprise and uh
in the real world
and then finally we're actually going to
go through a demo on how you can
actually install a jwt
using express and node.js
so let's dive into what actually is a
json web token
so a json web token is actually based on
an open standard it's one that you can
actually go ahead and research
and it allows a
definition of a compact self-contained
way of being able to securely transmit
information between parties using a json
object an adjacent object is a
javascript array
and it's very compact it's a very tight
way of being able to send data back and
forth
the thing that's great about using a
json web token is that the information
itself is encrypted and it can only be
verified and trusted through a public
private key pair and we'll get into that
about how you can actually get to those
so you know why would you actually want
to go ahead and use a json web token are
there other formats that you can use
well yes there are other formats you can
use but what's great about jwt is that
it is a great way to be able to pass
data from http servers so if you're
building a web application and you have
a web application where you need to pass
authentication over using a jw2 is a
great way to be able to do that
so for instance you may have a number of
enterprise applications that run across
your cloud environment you may have some
enterprise applications that run in your
data center and you want to have
people come in such as your employees or
your customers authenticate once and
then be able to have their id transition
from one to the next jwt is a great way
to do that the content is extremely
secure and we'll get more into that in a
moment but
it is the highest level of security you
can have right now
and the final great thing about working
with jwt is that the actual tokens
themselves are very well documented and
so there's actually a lot of passes that
you can use so being able to
add in jwt into your application is very
very easy to do which makes it very easy
for you to actually implement and a
large scale authentication and
authorization and so authorization is a
key word there um that's something that
you're probably coming across um a lot
instead of just being able to identify
who you are we want to be able to
authorize what you have access to
so let's have a look at the structure of
a jwt there are several key elements um
the first is the header and that's
actually going to break down
what
kind of token it is by default it's
going to be a gwt token and what is the
signing of algorithm so sha 512 is a
very complex and secure algorithm and
certainly the one that i would recommend
that you use uh you can even go higher
than that but um sha 512 is a great
place to start
and then you have the payload and the
payload is the information that's been
actually encrypted within the web token
and so in this instance we have a name
the admin time type um sub name um just
really you can put whatever kind of
information you want in there as long as
it's applicable um to the
service that you're passing the data
into
and then you have your
signature which is
um encoded header and payload with the
algorithm that you've sent so in this
instance it's sha 512 algorithm
so let's look at some of the use cases
that you'd have for jwt
so a couple of use cases would be
authorization so say for instance
you have a application and you want to
be able to authorize somebody to have
access to different parts of the
application and jwt is a great way to be
able to encrypt that data and be able to
pass that data back and forth
examples would be jumping from different
parts office 365 and being able to have
access to different features within the
system
and then another area would be if you're
doing information exchange so
information is being securely exchanged
from one person to another so a
blockchain scenario a multi-um
distributed environment where you want
to be able to have a way to be able to
securely transmit data back and forth
and know that that data is being
encrypted is another good example
so with that let's take a pivot and
we'll go ahead and we'll look at uh
creating a demo uh using our standard
stack of node.js and we'll use express
and postman
and these are tools that you may already
be familiar with if you've seen other
videos that we've created in this series
and we'll go ahead and create a jwt
token
so let's go into our demo of how to
create a jwt uh json web token there's
gonna be some tools that we need to get
started with uh node.js is the first so
let's go ahead and find node.js at
nodejs.org and you can either download
windows mac or linux code
obviously you'd install the one that
would be for your operating system
and the next tool that we want to
install is a text editor we're going to
use visual studio code or vs code
and go to
code.visualstudio.com download this this
will run
on
mac windows and linux
really great
text code editor
and then we're also going to use postman
postman is a tool that allows you to
access and view apis that we'll be
creating with express and you go to
postman.com hit download
and again there's versions of postman
for all leading operating systems
and have those installed and up and
running
so we're going to go ahead and let's
open up visual studio code
and we're going to start by creating our
project
let's go full screen on this get rid of
the welcome screen
and that's going to open up a folder
where we'll actually have our project
we're going to put this on our desktop
for right now let's go create a new
folder
and we'll call this node jwt
[Music]
for json web token select that folder
and we're going to want to go ahead and
use npm to initialize this folder for uh
for node and so let's get rid of the
welcome screen again and let's go ahead
and one things i love about
vs code is going to run the terminal
window right from in here so let's go
ahead and
select npm init
or he knows to pull from the folder that
we're in
and we're just going to select
yes here in a second
for our
yep let's go ahead and create that and
you'll see that packet has been created
and there is a json packet with just
default information about the npm
package that we created for node
and we're going to go ahead and create
an index.js file
that's what we'll be pulling from the
package
and the index.js files we're going to
actually rewrite all of our code and
what we want to do right now is install
express
and express can be used to create the
apis that we'll be able to test our jwt
against and then we'll also want to
install
a
jwt
um
file so let's call this json web token
and from our terminal window we'll just
go ahead
and install both of those and do that by
typing npm install
save
and then we're gonna put express
and json web token
express and json web token
and we'll just go ahead and let those
install
only takes a moment for those to get
installed
all right we're up and running okay
so let's go ahead and start bringing in
some of our apps so we're going to
create
an express app
and we're going to use the get http
header to
have everything and go from the we're
going to actually have everything
running on our localhost and we're going
to run everything off port 3000 we'll do
that in a moment here but we'll have
everything running off a sub
folder called api it's where our web
applications can be running from
and we'll put in a message that
hey there to show that everything's up
and running
okay
and
[Music]
save that
and save you can do control plus s to
save your files
and as you can with a lot of windows
applications i would encourage you to do
that a lot so let's go ahead and open up
postman with no i'm going to go to our
web browser on this one
and
postman
it takes a moment to run the first time
and it comes
and postman again is a tool for being
able to
manage api calls and
so you don't have to write a script
so here we go
and we can go in here and we can
that's where we're going to write our
script but we have to
do a couple of things first let's let's
get everything running so we want to
listen on for port 3000 that's we're
going to run everything off of
and
in the console log we'll actually throw
in a message to confirm that we are
running on
uh everything is up and running we'll
just say okay
uh server started on port 3000
again we're gonna be running everything
off localhost so you'll be able to see
this
um and this is as you imagine just a
test environment so let's go down into
our console we'll run this script node
index.js to run the script it runs
really fast not a whole lot going on
there
and we're having everything running off
the api files so let's go and we'll type
in under our get local host
colon
like slash api
and we hit
the
there's lots of different http headers
um we can use we're gonna use get for
right now
send that
and
hey there welcome to the api service
so to be clear this is just an api we're
creating right now this is not jwc we'll
get into that right now
all right
so
we want to be able to post data
and uh post is actually pushing data in
so we're going to go into uh we're going
to create a login screens again again
this is all api so it's not real but uh
you get the point
and then construct a user
and let's go ahead and what we're doing
here is we're creating
a
an array
of a random user and that they can have
a name of id one that they have the user
is gonna have an id value which is one
um a
username value which is gonna be john
and an email value of john gmail.com
and then we'll make this
a
json
web token jwt signing
and they'll have to sign with their user
and
this is going to use a secret key which
will be our hash
our hash 512
token
and
respond to the json with the token
okay so let's see now
okay and we're going to
hamp dot and this will be our post
api
[Music]
posts
and what we're going to be able to do is
we're going to jump from one app to
another app and you'll be able to see
how we can move the token with it
and the message will read
post
created
all right
so let's just run that script
index.js
runs real quick
okay
so if we come over here and we go to
posts
and hit send
and say message posts created
good
so let's go ahead and try that again
and we want to go to the
login
so go from one app to another app
select post
and
here in the login
we should be able to
request the token
this will be our gwt token
and we hit send we should get our token
and here you can see the the whole token
is encrypted
it's that huge long
line it's very unique
and
now we want to be able to go in and say
okay
let's verify
the token so
we've gone ahead and we've created the
token but now we need to as you go from
app to app we need to actually verify
the token so we're going to get an error
message if we don't verify the token
correctly
so i'm going to put in a function to
verify
the token
and
we're going to
create a bear header
value
which will be
the headers and the authorization for
that
and if type of bearer header
i'm going to have it if it's not correct
it'll be undefined
otherwise
this part token
will be split
and we're going to require the token
for our vero token
else
sense status
403 okay so bearer token is what we're
going to be calling against
to verify our token i'll show you how
that works in just a moment
and this will be to authorize
and to authorize we'll need to actually
go ahead and
use the token so we can actually
put in here
all right so i think
everything's looking pretty good
oh and
if things if we get the error message
means that it's we'll see the the
message forbidden if we don't put in the
code correctly so let's
double check that everything is looking
good
verifying that the token is required
okay
so if it is then jwt dot verify
[Music]
and this will
connect our token appropriately
and we'll be able to
put that in as a part of our secret key
and if it is successful
and put in
that message there
and we're also going to play in the
authorization data
yep looking good
as you can see a lot of the work is just
making sure that everything is aligned
up correctly
okay so let's run our code node index.js
there we go nice and fast
and
i'm going to go in and
localhost
api posts
and change this to post
so this one api which is the api posts
which is
up here
we'll hit send
and you can see that we have the error
code forbidden has come up which is what
we were expecting because we haven't
been able to put in a secret key
and
put in the comment there
forbidden
as we're stepping through the code
and now what we can actually do is we
can go back and we can grab the token
and here is our token below
and we just want the token itself we
don't need the wrappers
and copy that
come over here
and if we write again it's going to say
forbidden but
if we go into
author into
our
headers
we can put in authorization
and then the value
we do bearer and then the key
and once we do this
we now get all of the data that we were
asking for pulled back
which is exactly what we wanted
so you can see here how we can actually
securely
use a jwt to pass values back and forth
across the
application okay
and we hit
authorization we select that and approve
it yep we keep authorizing so if you
don't authorize and you don't get the
data
okay so we have everything against the
api and we have one application which is
called api post we have another
application called api plugin and we're
able to move the data back and forth
using our secret key in our jwt token
and we have everything running on port
3000 of our local host server
and that's our demo
so first of all let's cover why you'd
want to go through this tutorial so
we're going to cover what my sequel is
we're also going to tell you how we're
going to connect with node.js and why
you'd want to do that with my sequel and
then finally we're going to do a demo
taking you through all the steps on how
you can actually do that kind of
connection
so what is my sequel well basically my
sequel is probably the world's most
popular relational database and so if
you think of relational databases that
are table driven mysql is arguably the
most popular
database out there for rdbs systems it
is by far the most popular open source
uh relational database
the entire database is written in c and
c plus plus it's been around for a
really long time and again it's open
source which is great
which means that there are no licenses
or costs for actually using my sequel
and you'll find that companies of all
sizes from small mom and pop shops all
the way up to
massive enterprise global enterprises
are all using my sequel
so you know why would you want to then
take that next step of connecting
node.js with mysql well fundamentally
comes down to the basics of the
differences between the two products
mysql is a database and node.js is a
architecture framework for building out
web applications now again with mysql
it's open source it's free to use you
don't have to pay anything there are no
licenses which if you compare it with
other solutions out there is a big deal
my sequel even though it is open source
it's incredibly powerful it's one of the
more mature open source programs out
there i think apache is probably
arguably more apache web server it's
probably more mature but my sequel is
very close behind it so it has had a
huge amount of investment this is not a
solution that's only a couple years old
we're talking about a solution that's
more than 15 years old
very very structured very powerful and
you can do a lot of really good things
with it
you can actually then
build solutions with it and using php
java really any kind of database um even
other systems and other frameworks will
allow you to interact with mysql
and
it just allows you to work with just
huge amounts of data very very quickly
so let's go through a demo of how you'd
actually use node.js and my sql
so i'm going to go ahead and we're going
to get started by putting our
environment together so let's start by
selecting node.js and downloading it so
go to nodejs.org
and there you have your options for
windows mac or if you want to go for the
source code you can go ahead and
download and install that
the next is to install zap and so i'm
going to go to
zap installers for a quick search and
it's on our apache phrase.org site and
here we have example windows linux and
micros os10
and then finally we want to go ahead
and install visual studio so visual
studio is going to be our ide our
integrated development environment in
this instance we're going to use visual
studio code if you don't use visual
studio code
it's a great free open source solution
for being able to build applications
i'm a big fan of it so i encourage you
to use it
and go ahead and download install that
and we have visual studio um code up and
running so go ahead and we can open up a
new folder
and let's go ahead and create a new
folder and just put a stratified desktop
here and it's just for
kicks and giggles so i'm going to type
in node my sql for our source code and
we'll open up that folder and select
that
and so we now have this folder selected
in our visual studio code editor
and what we want to do is we want to
get rid of the welcome page and we don't
really need that anymore
and
we're going to terminal window so we can
actually see the
scripts that we're writing we'll be
using tunnel quite a bit um in this so
for instance we're just going to
test that we have npm installed we do so
that's great
and we're going to go npm init and
that's actually going to set up our own
node package module and we can actually
see that the json file for that package
has been created
so we go in there we can see that all
the defaults are selected
now you'll see that index.js is the
default file will be created so we're
going to go ahead and we're going to
create our own index.js file and we're
going to add in some instructions into
that file to actually install the
correct software from the mpn package
and the first thing we want to do is
install express
which is a package that's great for
building uh lightweight web applications
not mobile applications i suppose if
you're doing a responsive design then i
guess it would
but in this it's really it's a web
application environment so we're going
to
put in
the requirements for that and then we're
going to also go and require that my sql
gets installed
and
you'll see that for both of them we're
just gonna use npm's default commands
for creating it and we'll go down to the
terminal window and we'll do npm install
and it's going to
install
the express and my sql environment
and as that installs you actually see on
the left hand side under
the folder you actually see
the files starting to be installed
so for instance we have the node modules
and underneath that will be all the
subsequent files that we need
and there we are
everything is installed
all right so let's go ahead and validate
some of these clients make sure that
everything is installed so we're going
to open up zamp which allows us to go in
and
view and see that everything's stored so
we have my sequencer we have apache
installed
we can start and stop and the services
with zam go ahead and do that you can do
this through tele window as well but
the
ui interface is really nice so let's go
into
my
sql um interface
and you'll see that we don't have any
databases
these are all just the
standard test databases and so we have
to go ahead and create one
and so let's
get our
sql database connection created
so we're going to write
const
db equals my sequel
create connection
and we want to create connect to
the localhost in this instance
and user is just going to be a
root user account
which is the standard user account that
comes from my sql uh there is no
password for the root user when you're
running it locally i encourage you to
change that as quickly as you can
because you don't really want to have
a
password free environment
and now we want to be able to then
connect to the mysql
environment
so do real write db dot connect
uh parenthesis error and we want to
throw an error message if the connection
isn't good
so if we do error
we'll throw the
error message
to the log window
and
if we don't
then we'll write my superconnected
all right
and then
we want to connect that to our express
app
the next step we want to do after we
made our connection is to go ahead and
create a database so we'll do both steps
at the same one so we're writing the
script right now and then we'll run the
commands
in the terminal window so we can
actually create a database
and so we're going to go ahead and we
want to create
a database
and let's write let's sql equals
create
database
i'm going to call the database node
mysql you could call it whatever you
want um but this is just a node
nodemysql
script
the tp
query
sql
through error message
rest.send
database created
so we'll throw a message saying that
database has been created let's go save
that
to demonstrate that we've connected and
we've created this so let's go ahead
and
do node index.js
to run that and we'll connect it to my
sql that's great
good first step and then we'll go to
window
i will go to localhost
3000 which is
the default
connection but what you'll see is that
we've actually created the name of the
database has been changed to a node by
sql so we've got an error message which
we expected and so what we're going to
do is we're actually going to go ahead
and
we're going to say we want to listen
and if the error message if comes up to
then
in the console window we want to
put a message of service started on
porsche 3000
so let's try that
node again
yep and server has time for 3 000
let me refresh that
i'm still getting an error message
and what we want to see is
let's go ahead and see how database
hasn't been created
so let's go and connect to
database
database is let's go ahead and click
create db
on port 3000 all right so by doing that
we write that command and that function
and that goes and creates our database
and we'll let you see
but we have now node mysql has been
created
great first start
now we have to go in and create some
tables we have no tables in there
all right so let's go down let's go
ahead and create a table
so what you're seeing right now is that
we're using
the index.js environment within a
package on node.js to actually create
and control everything that we want to
see
in our windows so all of the work that
we're doing for creating a table for
creating the database
for initializing the core files it's all
being done through js and so here we are
going to create a new table and call it
creating it's going to be called the
employee table
and so once we run the command create
employee it's going to create a table
has the employee fields which is going
to have an
id which will be an integer that will go
into auto increment they'll have a name
field
and we'll also put in a designation
and
[Music]
i will have a primary key as well
keep it very simple right now
and let's just
put our db connection so that everything
connects effectively
okay so
everything goes correctly then we'll
have the message employee table created
so let's test this out
and
node.xjs
make sure that the data we have now
actually a database field that we can
connect to so we've got nodemysql so
we're connecting to the correct database
obviously we get an error
and then we'll try that again yeah okay
database so database has a name
and because but note mysql there's no
fields in there yet
so let's go ahead and
put in create employee fields and let's
run the function that creates the new
table and then
voila
we have a new table
and so
the next action we want to do is
actually
populate the table with a record
so
this starts becoming familiar so we're
not going to
put in a a single record we'll call it a
plea one for right now
and
we'll write the
the function
employee one and when we run that
function
uh it'll actually go ahead and
create the lit insert the record into my
sql
and then the name will be jake smith
and the designation
will be
achieved executive officer
certainly encourage you to put your own
self name your own name into this make
yourself your own ceo because why not
and we're going to make this as an
insert record
i'm going to insert into the employee
table
i'm just using some basic sql scripting
here
and what you'll see actually with
visual studio code instead it's actually
providing a lot of prompts to make it
easier to write your code
microsoft is looking to actually add
some ai
to visual studio code to actually start
auto completing
script which will make it even easier
to write your code
all right so let's go run node index.js
we see that i've been connected and
we'll grab the
function employee 1
and let's go over to our express site
let's just go and we'll insert the
command employee one
employee has been added and we will just
validate this by going back to my sql
and we'll refresh it
and you'll see
we click on the employee tables we
should now have an employee in there yep
there we go jake smith
hold on jake
first record
all right so we want to be able to now
select the employee
so let's go ahead and
do that
and we want to be able to easily get the
employee list
so let's use our sql command
and let's do select
star which is everything
from the employee table so we're
actually playing everything from the
employee table
i'm going to query the database
let's throw a message to confirm that
the query is successful
we'll put everything in the console log
results
all right let's give this a whirl
okay so
let's go and run our command
localhost 3000
but get employee
and this guy's employee details fetch
now we go to the console window in
visual studio yep there we go we have
now all the packet information including
the id about jake smith
okay so let's go ahead and see if we can
actually update the employee information
so as you can see now we're starting to
run into just our standard sql commands
and so we want to
be able to update the employee from a
browser
and as you can tell we're not using any
forms or any other types of records
we're just simply interacting
with between the
the browser the server and
the database
and the new name will be updated name
and just make sure we're updating your
program record
i will show that we're matching against
id1
all right so that's from
[Music]
we've now gone ahead and updated
the
jig
jigsmix information
so let's click on
table
and we now see he says updated name i
know not very creative but
it allows you to see a change
and finally we go ahead and delete the
record as well
so it's going to be similar to
update but i'm deleting instead
and i'm going to delete
the record from the employee table
[Music]
and
okay
and then we want to be able to
show that the record has been
deleted
okay
[Music]
deleted and we go to uh
database
see
from the employee table
that there are no entries
the one record that was there has been
deleted
and so this shows you how you can very
easily control everything
from
using your connection into my sequel
right from
node package manager
you can create a table
you can select your records
you can then
update any record that you selected
and finally you can delete any record
that
you want to be able to delete
so what we're going to do is so what's
in it for you so in this presentation
we're going to go through three key
things you know what is mongodb
how do you connect to mongodb with
node.js
and mongodb is part of the mern stack so
we're going to cover what the mer stack
is and how it applies to node.js
so what is mongodb so mongodb is a it's
a
probably the most popular nosql database
out there it's cross-platform and
very easy to scale it's available on all
cloud systems you can also run it
locally which is what we'll be doing
later on in our demo
but it's just a very flexible database
environment for modern
applications
it works on the concept of collection
and documents
um what you'll find is uh mongodb was
originally written in c plus plus and it
is what's referred to as a nosql
database so this is different to a
relational database which is built up of
tables with rows and columns this is a
nosql database as simply a lot faster
and more powerful for the work that
you're doing
and you're able to use mongodb very easy
you can actually go ahead and download
it we'll actually do that as part of our
demo
so you know why connect node.js with
mongodb
well the reason why you want to do this
is that mongodb is a modern database um
it's not uh restricted by the the the
challenges of scalability that all the
uh relational databases have um it's
really designed for building mobile
applications of websites that scale into
the millions and millions of users
so mongodb probably the most important
feature is scalability
the performance of the database is
phenomenal
and it is extremely highly available for
the solutions that you'll be creating so
when you push it out to your solution to
the cloud you can almost guarantee it's
always going to be running
you also have the ability to be able to
scale to very large complex
multi-site solutions in fact one of the
very first mongodb applications i built
was a multi-tenant environment and it
just worked really well
and you'll be able to easily deploy your
searches across
microsoft azure aws google cloud
etc so you know why do you want to keep
connecting to mongodb um i think
probably
one of the other areas that probably
is often forgotten with is just
the concept around big data and you can
i mean when you talk about big data
you're talking about absolutely massive
massive databases
and mongodb is front and center for all
of that
you can do your effective content
management and delivery
um it has an effective mobile and social
infrastructure so um by that it allows
you to be able to build out solutions
that can go to all modern day types of
applications and the data is actually
very easy to manage
through your central data hub
and then finally being able to connect
to mongodb is very easy
particularly as there is a client called
mongoose that makes the connections
extremely easy so you know finally um
let's kind of look into how db is
part of the mer stag
so learnstack is a javascript stack and
it's of javascript solutions that are
built for modern single page
applications and there are four key
solutions in the merge stack there's
mongodb which is your database express
which is your server side uh http
environment react which is the solution
for being able to
create your solutions on the client and
the node.js
which actually manages the whole
environment it's really an environment
that's designed to make it very easy to
be able to build out modern day
solutions so
db is the m in moon
express is the e
react is the r
and node
js is the n so again
as you start working with some of our
other videos that we have um here you'll
be able to um see how all of these tools
really complement each other so we've
done an introduction on uh mongodb
really the best thing now is to get you
out you know your hands dirty by
actually doing a demo so we're going to
go through a demo what i would strongly
encourage you however though is that
this demo really does build on a lot of
the other videos that we've done in this
series
so
you really do want to spend some time on
the node.js video the node.js for
express video the node.js for apis video
really all of those videos help
complement the work that you'll be doing
those linux um mac os they're all
supported you can also get the original
source code and recompile your version
of node.js if you want to
now we're just going to install the
windows version
and the next thing you want to do is
install
your favorite uh
text editor i'm going to install visual
studio code vs code
it runs on all leading platforms mac os
windows and linux it is open source you
can edit it and i like it because you
can do an awful lot with it
uh just a lot of extensions and it's
just a great tool all around
so that's the next thing you want to
install
and then we want to go ahead and we want
to go to
mongodb.com so we can install the
mongodb database
so you want to go to software
community server
and you want to then select
the
mongodb community server
which platform you want
and where it's going to connect with
and you want to select the
download to install that
and that'll take a moment or two for you
to download and get that up and running
once you've done that we want to go
ahead and we're going to open up vs code
so we can start editing and the code
that we need for our new solution
so let's go ahead and create a folder
off our desktop that we'll use for
mongodb so i already have a folder
created called demo i'm just going to
select that and then inside there i'm
going to put in node
mongodb and select that folder
and that's going to open up vs code and
it's going to have our folder in here so
we're going to get rid of the welcome
screen we don't need that
we do want to however open up our
terminal window so we're going to
run that that's one of the things that i
really like about vs code is you can
actually have your terminal window or
command line window actually inside the
development environment you're working
in so you don't have to be jumping from
one solution to another and then we're
going to initialize our package so npm
init for the folder that we're in it's
going to create our
node package manager it's going to
create our default package and we're
going to hit return that's going to go
ahead and start the process
and we're just going to go with the
default
um
settings
that npm is going to give so just hit
return return return a few times and
that will get up and running for you
and our entry point for the application
is going to be index.js
area that's uh
gs package and there we have everything
this is just the
uh the the json package that provides
the instructions that npm would use to
pass the um the program now you notice
that we have index.js as our leading
file so we actually have to add a new
file here and we're just going to tour
this one index.js
so
we actually have a file that can be
referenced
and now we're going to go ahead and
we're going to actually put in
our
default application so express is going
to be required so we're going to make
sure that that
is included in our first line of our
instructions
and then we're also going to
have a path that's required
and
we're going to require handlebars
and these are all part of our express
environment
and don't forget to save your file as
you're going along
and we're also going to have
express
phbs
and this is going to be our express
handlebars
and
we're all going to
allow
insecure
prototype
access
you wouldn't normally do this but uh
because we're running everything locally
it just makes it easier for
you to actually get all the code in
and then we're also going to add in
our body parser
and these are all the required solutions
that we need
to be installed
when you're running this
package
and so let's save the file and then
let's go ahead and run it so we're going
to do mpn
install
and we do
save and this will install express
and we also have install path
handlebars
express handlebars
um
[Music]
and this is where we'll install
the prototyping
and we'll also have
the body parser
installed and we're just going to run
that
this will just take a moment or two to
install
all right there we go
so we have everything installed which
allows us to now start working with our
scripts
so we're going to create an app in
express
and we're going to listen on port 3000
and
we're going to have a message then go to
our console log
and we have everything running off our
local port on local host on port 3000 so
let's go and we're going to select
nodeindex.js
shows us everything's running
which is good you can actually test this
in our web browser if we wanted to
okay so let's start working on our app
so our app is going to
use bodyparser
and we're going to encode
our request
and the goal here is we're going to
create a file that's going to go back
and forth
to
mongoose among to mongodb
so body parts is going to use json to
encrypt
the content
and we're going to do a get command to
get our results
and if we work to if you've seen the api
video then we did that here in fact it's
probably a good idea to actually sit
down and look through some of the other
videos that we've created such as the
json uh sorry the node.js
node.js
for express node.js
for apis and node.js for authentication
uh before doing this video
uh we're going to create a default page
and it's going to say welcome to the
students database
the principles that we're putting down
here you'll be able to apply to any
solution that you're creating with
mongodb
and so we want to have
a simple action
that we're going to
put on here which is going to be
click to gain access
okay
we're gonna put in the path and where to
get the list from
okay
all right
so here is
our basic web page that we're creating
nothing fancy
but it's going to take you to a place
where you can actually get all the
content now what we're going to do is
we're actually going to go and
pull the content from manga
so run this and open up web browser
you'll see what it looks like let's just
go to localhost
close out these other tabs don't need
them localhost 3000
and there we see welcome to the student
database click on the database and you
click on if we click on it now nothing
will happen so yeah nothing there
so let's make something happen
okay
all right so
let's begin extending our app so what
we're going to do is we want to
set
the views
i'm going to do a
join
on our directory name
and app
engine
so let's go for our views we haven't had
pension yet but let's go ahead and
create a new folder
i'm going to call that one views
and let's expand that
actually that should be okay
hps
express handlebars
and
allow prototype access for express
enterprise
so with express handlebars if this is
new to you it allows you to separate
your content from your layout
which if you have developed with
swift for a mobile application
on the mac
using xcode is the same
principle there but for a web
application
so we're just i'm putting out here
some of our
default environment settings
i'm going to set our view engine
for handlebars
and just checking through our code it's
looking good
okay so that provides
that so let's create a new folder under
our views and this one we're going to
call layouts so again this is where we
are splitting our layouts
and we're going to have
a folder called models
at the root of our application and under
models we're going to put in
db.js so the dbjs file
is going to be where we put our
instructions
for our database and so here we're going
to go ahead and we're going to
require to import mongoose a mongoose is
a tool
in node.js that allows you to connect
to mongodb
so we're going to require the use of
mongoose and so we're going to do npm
install
say save mongoose
and that's going to run and install our
local machine so we can actually test
this out
and once we've got this installed what
we're going to do is we're going to
start connecting to a database that
we're going to call student db
okay we're already already installed so
let's go mongoose.connect
and
we're gonna call it mongodb
we're gonna run this off our local host
we installed the
uh community version that has just run
on file logo host and it's going to run
from the port 27017
i'm going to call this one studentdb
so again with our application we're
splitting out
all the functionality so if you want to
reuse elements you can
so we're going to have a new a usernurl
parser
and we'll make sure we capture
everything correctly
okay
so if arrow then we'll
send a message to the console log
and we have either
connection successful or things go wrong
error in connection
and then if there is an error then what
we'll do is we'll have the error message
posted
okay
and then we'll do require
student
dot
model
so this will actually call the model
we're gonna create
and so what we need to do now is create
in
under models we're going to create
student.model
dot js
and this is where we're going to do
our instructions for
our student model so first thing you
want to do is we want to import
uh mongoose
express and the student model
so we've got there let's make sure we
have everything let's capture that
so let's go to
our student model
all right so let's make sure that we
have everything so we want to have
mongoose
and
i'm going to create a new variable
called student schema this will allow us
to structure
what our model will look like this will
be a
a new
new schema
in using mongoose
and our new schemer is going to be full
name
and we're going to break down
our
jason's package so
we're going to put in the instructions
for what
the schema would look like so
we have the type we have been required
this field is required
and
the second value is going to be email
[Music]
type string
this field is required
that's the
message error message you want to send
if
the field isn't filled out
now mobile phone number this will be
just a number
and
we're going to have city
and this obtained will be
let's just make this a string we're just
going to try and keep this simple for
right now
let's fill this required
all right so here's our schema
looking pretty good
all right mongoose
dot model
and connect this to our
student model
so we want to go ahead and save that
okay
okay a new folder and this new folder is
going to be called controllers
and we have a new file under controllers
and that new file is going to be called
studentcontroller.js
let's go in and
see what we're going to add here
so we want to import uh make sure we're
running express
so express is required for our
controller
we also want to set up a variable for
router
so writer express.router
and we want to make sure we're also
connecting with mongoose
so we have a connection to our mongodb
and
we also want to make sure that we have
connection to our student model
so mungus mongoose dot model
and our student model
and this allows us to make sure that we
have
this student model
pulled over
effectively for our controller for our
student controller
okay so let's go to router
get
now render
this and student slash add or edit
we'll come into that in just a moment
so we want to be able to
view title and this will pull in
the insert
student
i'm going to use
under our views
we're going to create a
new folder
and this one's going to be called
student
and we're going to create a new file and
this one will be
add or edit
dot js oh hps sorry
for our handlebar
so you notice we don't have to put the
file extension
uh node.js manages all that for us
so
router dodge post
so this will be
our we're going to get our content and
then we're also going to post content so
the post will go back
as part of our body and
there'll be an id
so we want to then instead insert the
record that we'll be creating
so again if you've been if you've worked
through the nodejs api
video
then you'll start seeing if there's some
commonalities here of being able to
insert or update a record
and
we actually cover that
using just a sample json package this
really takes it to that next level
okay
okay so we want to put in a new student
record this will be student
and we're going to have that full name
is going to
come from our body
and we're going to also capture the
email
essentially we're going to follow the
model that we created
and our mobile phone
finally with a student city
and then we want to
save the record that we create
okay
all right so we're going to manage our
error message
and we're going to put in
similar messages that we've put in
before
so we want to redirect to our student
list
and we're going to go ahead and create
that in a moment
so
let's create a new file student list.hbs
so list.hbs
and here
so what we do is with tuned lists that's
actually going to match then
the
controls for being able to
display the records in the database
and then we'll put
um a message if there's an error then
you know we'll put an error message
there and ask you to report the error
message
we're going to try and not do that
all right so
now the next step we need to go through
is we want to call a function to update
the record
and let's go ahead and we're going to
update their records
and we do the student.find1 and update
command
okay
okay so we will redirect to our student
list as needed if not we'll throw an
error message to our console lot
yeah
looking good
and again this is just an example
but something that you'll be able to do
yourself
i have with it your own solution
and
then we want to like go back to our list
to
then render
the
all records
and here we want to put student and then
how we're going to find the record
and
we'll throw a error message to our
console log
so as you can see we always throw an
error message to the console log
error messages are really useful
okay
all right looks good
save that
okay let's do another router and this is
two
we're going to do the router against id
this will allow us to
get the content
so i'll be able to get information by id
of the student
and what you can see is there's a lot of
the work we're doing here
is very repetitive
um and
you'll find as you create more modular
code that it makes easier for you to
write your code and update and manage
your code
okay so we're going to
get our
view title we're going to put that into
our document
okay
all right so our next router
is
we want to be able to
delete
a record by id
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to find our records for our
student record we're going to find it by
id
and then we'll do find by find id and
remove
okay so we're gonna
to once we've removed your record we're
gonna redirect to our list so we can
show our student list
and otherwise we'll send an error
message to our console log
okay
so i think we have what we need
maybe there's maybe there's one more
thing i think we need to
i think this is good
okay
so
let's go to our
layouts add a new file there
we're going to call this one main layout
dot hbs
and here we're going to put the skeleton
of
our web page together
let's write this out so i'm going to put
in
html
code
and
we're just going to keep this real
simple
header
we want a title
and this is going to be students
database
um i mean we just got students
so
we now go to
going we'll try and find out bootstrap
for we're going to just grab that
and we're going to use
bootstrap to get started
and there are a couple of components
there's a css component and then there's
the javascript component so let's just
go copy the
css component
and then we're going to just link that
into the header section of our
web page
so and then
here's an example of different
components you can create
uh if you're not used if you haven't
used bootstrap before it's an open
source framework originally developed by
twitter great tool
so in our header we want to
put in the link to the css
there's that
and
now i need to also
put in our own styles
so we've got here some styles that we
created earlier on
um for
the work that we're doing you can just
paste those in
so we have a box style that we want to
use that will extend the box style that
you get
with bootstrap
all right so we're going to start
working on our body content
class bg info and so this is actually bg
info is
a css class file from bootstrap that you
can use
and you have the id of box
again we're going to do
another class
which allows us for our table structure
so a little bit of knowledge of
bootstrap is great here
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to put in
the content which we're going to call
body and this will
show up on the screen
so again we're pulling from records
within bootstrap dig through bootstrap
there's lots of content there for you to
be able to take advantage of
okay
so now we want to be able to add or edit
our record
view title
and the
um
the
the the french brackets allow you to be
able to pull records and content
directly from
the code that we're writing
so we're pulling title from insert
record and as part of our
router
command
and then we'll put in our form
which will be student
post
i'm just gonna do a basic form here
nothing fancy
we will put in the
first record will be a hidden field and
this will be for id
so we want to want to generate the id we
don't want to have somebody put that in
and then we will put in
[Music]
our
form elements
so we'll have first will be
the label
it'll be full name
there will be
an input field
this will be text in the input field
and
again we're using form dash control
which is from
bootstrap css
and we'll have
a full name
and
placeholder before name so
where we have name there
will actually match up
with
the value that we're putting in our
model
so here we have student full name
so we're matching everything up to the
model that we created
okay so let's do this for
our
remaining form elements
and again as you see we can put this
together really quickly
so i'm going to put in for as well be
email
and we'll do
mobile
and city
and
here we keep going
and final group
yeah we'll be able to have the
type of
tool for bringing in mobile
so as you can see because we're using
just standard html here you can actually
reference external libraries such as
uh javascript libraries for
formatting the field that you're in
regular expressions things like
that and let's put in our final value
which will be for city
and normally when i'd be writing this
by hand i would actually be copying
pasting sections of code and just
changing the values as necessary
just to make it easier on myself but
here i'm just typing out everything for
you so you can
see the
whole process
okay all right so there are our values
of course remember save your files as
you're going along
everything looks good
and we're matching up our values
with our
records
and we want to have a button that allows
you to submit
you also want to have a button to select
view all if you want to be able to view
all the records
okay
looking good
okay let's go back over to list now we
want to be able to
pull our records so
[Music]
this will display
the
list of students
in a table
right
let's go ahead and format that table
so we're going to put together our
format here but then we're also going to
add buttons at the bottom so we can
actually add a record to the database or
if we want to edit or delete a
particular record from the database
i'm going to call this one
create a new string record
for a string list
i'm just going to type all this in for
you
and you'll see how we put placeholders
for the values as we put them in
these are our table headers
okay
body content
and what we're going to do here is we're
going to add in
[Music]
an element that allows you to create
a row for each item listed
so if you have two or more items they'll
appear
as an individual row
on here
and again what we're doing is we're
pulling in the values to be able to
pull from the model that we created
earlier on so this being the data that's
been submitted so we have it put in the
value for the email full name
and mobile and city
we're not going to show id
so it's pulling out all of this data
that we created earlier on
so we have everything posted into our
list
as documents
so let's go into a hbs file
and
it's our list
let's bring our
file entry here
[Music]
this will be for city
then
this is just a placeholder
at the end
of the list
oh yeah you know what we're going to do
is we're going to add in
[Music]
reference for the id
so we want to edit the document we can
and then we want to do the same thing if
we want to
delete the document
so href
calls
student
and then
just delete
now delete based on the id
there we go
passing that instruction over
so click
[Music]
simple
i'm going to ask him are you sure you
want to
delete if somebody clicks on the record
they hit cancel then won't get deleted
if they hit okay then it will get
deleted
this is why you can actually write
js in line
okay
and
then we want to
close out where
the row will end so i have
each opens and closes
the record
just tying up some of the html there
save that
okay looking good
back to our root index file
so
see now
we want to
also require
our model
and then
we have our
student controller
also be
a require
of where it's going to pull the student
controller from
okay
and this is just the instructions on
where we can actually find
the content
okay looks good so let's do node next
xjs
everything's safe gonna re-run
everything
and we got an error
let's go check out where our error came
from
so let's go in to our files
this is one that we created
so
[Music]
error is in
string controller see where's the era
oh we need to
have our much we need to export our
module to our router
all right let's go open up
database
and we can just start
seeing where the records are
just installing the latest updates here
so
we need to go ahead and in our
connection string so it's on localhost
that's the port
let's just double check that make sure
we're
completely aligned so here's our
database connection
and
there's our port and student database
and we did this with one go to mongoose
for connecting to
so i'm going to connect
and here are where our records are being
stored
so we're going to create a database and
we're going to call this database
it's going to be called student tb
student db sbk sensitive
and collection names students
let's go ahead and create a database so
there yeah there's our database
and
let's go we run our index js file
and everything
was successful
this is good
all right
so everything should have passed
successfully good good good
database connection is good
so let's go to localhost
and
here we are so we can start actually
navigating through our application
so we see we have our setup we have no
records
so let's go ahead and create one
and we go through you can actually start
stepping through the different layouts
that you've created so here's our layers
separate
to our
code
so there's some spacing we probably need
to add that so let's go ahead and just
add that
and
let's rerun our code
this is the phone bits where you know
everything is
just tidying up okay so you know it puts
in one line one space because we didn't
put in the actual html code for being
multiple spaces
so we're going to go in and select
insert so let's put in
smith and we do smith at
gmail.com
[Music]
and let's just put in a random
phone number
there we go we don't have any formatting
so we could put anything in there and
the city uh i know where am i um this
i'm in delhi so submit that
hit submit and it takes us to a list and
voila
we actually have a list with a record in
and if we go back to our database we can
actually refresh it and now we actually
start seeing our records being created
and we see the id is automatically
created and there's our
records
okay let's go back
and now we can select edit we can edit
the record
so let's change our city to
bangalore hit submit
all right city is now bangalore
and if we want to we can
edit it again
and so this is
pulling in
yeah if we do a delete it's going to
ask us do we want to delete
okay
little bit of formatting applying there
and the records are all good so again
make that smith jones
but because you need to hit submit
wouldn't update the record
so we hit submit updates the record
we hit delete it's going to say are you
sure we say yes we are
and ah
it has
congrats that record okay so let's go
back about code
and
because we have everything separated and
actually now just go to
our student controller
and we'll find our delete
you guys delete and we had
a
uh
you had a couple of minor errors there
it's where it's good to test out your
code
okay let's run that again
and refresh everything
so we'll go to our database we're going
to go create a new entry
let's call this one john john gmail.com
we'll put in a phone number
you see that the formatting is just
playing from
um
our
uh bootstrap so there we are there's
john do you want to delete they say yes
yeah easy there we go also
and we hit refresh the record should be
gone yep it is
and so we've created an application
where we can update applications
we can create an application we can list
all the items
and we did all of this
using
just open source solutions through
node.js and that was with using express
some of the components come with express
mongodb for our database and then
mongoose to connect to our database
we're going to be going through some of
the simple questions that you would be
asked during a node.js interview let's
just get started
so the first question you're probably
going to be asked is you know you know
what is node.js you know do you know
what it's for and essentially node.js is
one of the most popular if not the most
popular uh open source cross-platform
javascript programs and it allows you to
build out web applications that run on
the server it's extremely flexible it
allows you to implement a lot of
solutions outside of just the core
programming runtime and allows you to
build solutions extremely quickly in an
open source mindset for devops
it is used essentially for creating
client size web applications
we'll see this later on and you may want
to talk a little bit about
using express js and how you can build
out apis
to work with node.js and connecting to
databases such as mongodb
and that is also really good for being
able to store
a data intensive applications that are
asynchronous and event driven in their
model
and this is important when you're
talking about
creating applications that can scale
rapidly
so you're gonna then ask be asking how
does nodejs work well nodejs itself is
actually built on the v8 engine and the
v8 javascript engine is the same engine
that runs javascript in your chrome web
browser extremely fast
it allows for
high output and non-blocking out through
your i o input outputs and is a single
threaded event loop
so you're going to be then asked you
know where can you use node.js and and
the reality is the applications for
node.js keep expanding um but there are
some core applications that you can work
with node.js right now so such as web
applications distributed system and
network applications
probably referencing the web
applications is a really good starting
point because here you can actually talk
about maybe some examples that you've
done where you're building out some of
these web applications
indeed one of the things that you want
to be consistently doing and peppering
your answers with is examples of work
that you have done
now it doesn't matter if those examples
are purely experimental or
training examples that you've done the
fact that you've actually worked with
node.js and created a distributed system
or a web application
is really valuable because it shows that
the person that you're meeting with that
you have knowledge and understanding and
practical experience of applying the
theory of working with node.js with the
practice of working with node.js
so be asked about you know your answer
essentially the io refers to the
transfer of data in and out of
a system and that's really it you know
there's a reason why google calls their
conference io it's the transfer of data
in and out of our brains at that
conference the application is same here
it's about moving data in and out of
systems through using node.js
and that every um event can be tracked
whether it's on a physical device a
network or files within a system again
it's input and output
so let's go through and you know you're
going to be asked yo can you explain the
difference between front-end and
back-end development and this is a
question that i get asked a lot when i'm
meeting with clients um you know people
get really confused about what is the
difference between front-end and
back-end development
bottom line front-end is what gets
resolved inside of your web browser or
the app on your
mobile device back-end is what gets
resolved um essentially um what we call
the the back office or server side
applications but it's becoming more and
more synonymous for what gets run in the
cloud
so web applications um really get a lot
of the functionality of a web
application gets run in the front end
anything with css html5 uh client-side
javascript so we can get right in the
front end everything else such as
connecting to a database um gets run
behind the scenes in the back end
and so you know anything that's going to
have like graphics is going to be on the
front end
apis are going to be run on the back end
and then just finally some of the
scripting languages are used on on the
front end
so html css javascript those are all
common
core scripting languages that you would
use
you can use frameworks such as angularjs
and react.js or vue
those would be a front-end frameworks uh
backend frameworks will include java php
python and node.js or some of the
back-end technologies you'd also
throw in there
net as well i mean it's just the whole
you know litany of front-end and
back-end technologies and frameworks
that you can use um and this is actually
a good point to kind of explain the
experience you have outside of just
working with node.js but other
technologies that you've been working
with that potentially that the client is
also using
so another question you're going to be
asked when you're looking at node.js is
you know can you tell me about npm and
so when somebody asks you what is npm
the first thing you're going to respond
is do you mean node package manager and
the reason why you want to respond like
that is that you want to qualify their
question with understanding that you
know what they're talking about but you
want them to verify that and so node
packet manager is npm
and it's responsible for packaging all
of your modules that you're working with
in node.js and we have a whole series of
videos that we've done on node.js and
every single one of them
includes references to mpm
so you're going to be asking you know so
okay you tell me um what it is you know
can you go into a little bit more um
details can you provide two main
functionalities and so one of them is
being able to
manage online repositories of modules
and packages
so you can go to like search.nodejs.org
and you can find a packages that you can
install into your solution
such as express.js
and it also provides a command line
utility that allows you to manage uh
your packages very quickly uh through
terminal window or command line
i use vs code a lot visual studio code
and it has a command line utility built
right into it that allows me to interact
with npm
so what are some of the modules in
node.js and so you know modules um in
node.js they're essentially like
javascript libraries so you can think of
some of the javascript libraries that
you may have used the functionality is
somewhat the same but they're designed
for node.js and to run on the server and
there are ways in which you can go ahead
and create some of those modules so for
instance
if we're creating a web server you can
actually use the require commands to be
able to require that the server be there
so the example we have on the right hand
side
shows that we really do need to have
http which is a web server and we
require that to be installed and so that
if you're running that
npm package it will actually install the
http server and then you actually write
some code to actually then listen on the
local host port 2000 for where you'll be
running your application
and there are just you know there's a
whole bunch of modules that i come
with node.js right out of the gate and
here are some of the modules that you
have and we also referenced that just
earlier on http is a core module for
running a
web server
you have a utility function that is
useful for developers to
assess and features within your node.js
project you have a url
module for any url passing you'd be
doing
and you also have a stream which allows
you to be able to stream data in and out
of your system and be able to manage how
that's being worked and then zlib which
allows you to compress and decompress
files so that you can keep uh your
storage of files um to a minimum
so a question you're going to be asked
is you know why is node.js being
preferred over backend technologies such
as java and php and particularly java
it's a very mature stable language it's
been around for more than 20 years you
know php
runs some of them the
most powerful and largest uh websites
out there such as facebook so why would
you use node.js well the first response
is kind of a gimme but it is really fast
and if you watched any of the videos
that we've done on node.js
building out solutions and developing
the solutions you'll see just how fast
it is
the second is the
really kind of the secret sauce with
node.js is the node package manager and
no package manager allows you to install
additional functionality such as express
or as a database into your
solution
really quickly and there's over 50 000
bundles available for node package
manager
if you're building out a
real-time application that's data
intensive and you need to have apis
quickly developed then node.js is
another great it's really the great
solution for you it allows you to build
out these solutions really quickly
and there is a easy synchronization
between the server and the client due to
the code base
and then finally because the structure
of node.js is javascript if you are
making the pivot from being a front-end
web developer to node.js it's just going
to make it a lot easier for you to pick
up node.js because you have that common
language of javascript
and on top of that javascript is the
world's most popular
scripting language
so let's talk about some of the
differences between angular and node.js
and so the reason why this question may
come up is the person interviewing you
is seeing whether or not you do know the
difference between a front-end
framework and a back-end framework and
this is one of those questions where you
can go well
there are differences but the
differences are because they complement
each other um so angular is a front-end
development framework whereas node.js is
a server-side in framework other
differences though between the actual
frameworks themselves is that angular is
written in typescript which is a
modification of javascript node.js is
written in c and c plus plus
angular is used for building out single
page
client-side web applications and so
that's a key word there is client-side
whereas node.js is about building out
fast and scalable server-side network
applications and so
again the two complement each
other angular splits web applications
into the mvc and model view control
components whereas node.js generates a
lot of database inquiries it does more
than that as well but you can think of
node.js that glue to your database
so let's talk a little bit about when
you're connecting to a database with
node.js and so um you're going to
probably be asking what is
the most popular database used with
node.js and there are a couple
mongodb is largely the most popular
nosql cross-platform database
mysql is also very popular and that's a
more traditional relational database
you would go with mongodb for really
more modern solutions when you're
looking at creating an application
that's going to really scale into just
managing masses and masses
of data that has to be
created read updated and deleted very
very quickly
for
some of the other popular libraries that
you use for node.js express.js is a very
popular one and i really like working
with express.js allows me to build out
web applications really quickly
more importantly it allows me to build
out apis very quickly and which you know
apis are essentially web applications
themselves but being able to do that
very quickly with a framework like
express.js is very useful
uh mongoose is an application that makes
connecting to a database really
easy so
here is an example of express.js which
is a in itself really a flexible budge a
solution that you can do lots with and
mongoose which is a more
focused solution
which allows
you know to you make it easier to
connect to your databases
so you know what are the pros and cons
of working with node.js there's lots of
ways we explain this earlier on that you
can actually build out
applications that run on the cloud why
would you you know what's are the pros
and cons so a pro is that uh node.js is
extremely fast a processing an event
based model uh it really is fast a con
is if you have something that is a very
heavy computational task it's not so
good at that um now i will caveat that
this is that node.js is getting better
all the time and so
you might have to be provide an example
of what a very heavy computational task
is and that may be uh calculating
a risk on an insurance application
against
many many variables that may be
something that's seen as computationally
very heavy but what you can do in that
example is you can offload
the task to another solution that's
designed for it and use apis to pass the
data back and forth
pro
javascript is uh used for building out
your applications with
node.js great lots of people know
javascript
a
restriction and again this is evolving
as javascript itself evolves is that
when you do a call back you may end up
doing lots of nested callbacks um if
you're doing something that's very
complicated again another way around the
con and so this is one of the things
that i always look for is if you have a
blocker or a barrier
how do you get around that barrier and
so for instance when you're talking to
your recruiter
you can say look the reason why i use
node.js is that it's fast it's event
based driven i can use javascript there
are some challenges and but what i do to
get around those challenges are and
that's where you can say that you know
you may run the complex script off and
you may write that in net or java or php
and then use an api to do the response
back into node.js so you get the
benefits of both worlds but minimize the
investment in having to manage a complex
environment such as java versus a
relatively simple environment with
node.js
the node package manager makes it
extremely easy to access just an awful
lot of functionality
with over 50 000 packages there's a
package for that
so from being able to have a
tool that creates unique identifiers
that you might need to have for
generating content that gets posted into
a database through to being able to
connect to databases through you know to
running so many different solutions and
the npm package manager with its access
to so many different packages makes it
great
for
getting access to all that content now
khan is working with relational
databases with node.js isn't as easy as
a nosql database now you can do it and
there are ways around that and
what i would do when this question comes
up is always kind of pivot to say hey
this is how you can actually then
get around building out that application
pro for node.js designed for streaming
huge amounts of data in and out a con is
that node.js is single threaded so it
can be cpu intensive
but again there are ways around that and
a good way around that is scaling your
solution in elastic environment such as
the cloud
so what is the command used to import an
external library and so to import an
external library the command is the
required command so an example we have
here is uh you can start a variable and
the variable's going to be for http and
you're going to then require the http
service and that means that the
application itself won't run unless the
external library the http library is
installed okay so those were our
introductory questions for node.js let's
kind of pivot and take a look at the
intermediate questions that you would be
asked
so what does event driven programming
mean so event driven programming means
that if something happens something else
will happen in response so for instance
if you click a mouse
that mouse click is an event that means
something has to respond to that event
just think of it as cause and effect
it's just the basic motion of physics so
that's what event driven programming
means
you also look at it as a callback
function
so that when an element is executed
something will happen in response
so what is an event loop in node.js
so an event loop in node.js is when you
do an asynchronous call and
what that essentially means is that
you are sending out
data and then non-blocking input output
from node.js is pulling data back in
what is an event emitter in node.js so
an event emitter has really two areas of
focus one is that it manages uh the
classes that hold all the objects uh
within your event and we have an example
of this on the right hand side
and then whenever an event actually is
thrown uh the functions are then called
on that event synchronously
so for instance we have in our example
on the right hand side we create an
event and then we have the functions and
that executed in a series from
that event
so let's talk about the api functions in
node.js so there's two types uh one is
an asynchronous non-blocking function
and the second is a synchronous blocking
function and the difference between the
two of them is asynchronous is that
there is no structure to the order
for how the
api is resolved synchronous means that
when the feedback from the api is
received you have to execute
the response in a series for how the
response is sent to you
so what is a package.json file so the
package json file is at the heart of our
node.js
package where we actually will
initialize a solution a folder to be a
node.js
package
you'll find that the package itself
holds all of the metadata that's
particular to the project you're working
on such as project name version
requirements it is you have to have
installed in the root of the directory
for the project
and again look at any of the videos that
we have on node.js we do have
demonstrations within those videos that
actually then go through and break out
how to create that root package and
you'll see how you can actually then go
ahead and update the instructions or the
metadata within the package
so here we have an example of what that
metadata looks like so again this kind
of continues that question of what is a
package.json file and you may be asked
you know what is the metadata and why is
it important and the metadata is a
basic
json collection of pairing of
key details such as name version
description and then the custom version
that you put so for instance under name
you could create a name for your project
there can't be any spaces
what is the version and the description
and what is the main or starting path
for the solution typically that would be
index.js but it could be anything.js but
index.js is typical simply because
index.html is the starting point for a
typical web application
so how would you use a url module in
node.js
so with the url module what it allows
you to do is really two things one is
that it provides the resolution and
passing of a url
for utilities in your application
and then it allows you to
extend your module with built-in
solutions and split up the web address
into a readable format
so in this example
we have the url and the response it
would give
for that url which would then be a year
and month um and it'd be in a readable
format so it would read out as
2020 and then the month
so
what is express.js and you've heard me
mention this a couple of times in the
video we actually have a separate video
on express.js um expressjs is a web
application framework that allows you to
build out web solutions
for both mobile and traditional desktop
right inside of node.js so it's very
easy to use
um being able to install and webjs is as
simple as requiring express to be
installed in the example that we have
here on the screen it's a full solution
of showing how to actually build out a
solution with web.js
so in this example you start off the
first two lines require express to be
installed and the store comes from node
packet manager then we have a simple
application that will then send to the
browser window
a hello world message confirming that
express is up and running and then the
third block of content starting with
virus server actually will define the
port
where your application is going to run
so in this instance
the port is going to run on localhost
and the
port will be port 8081
and so you can actually go to localhost
colon8081
and when you do that that will trigger
the application that will forward up the
message hello world and it's all coming
from express.js
so what are streams in node.js so
streams are objects that allow you to
read and write data continuously back
and forth within your application and
there's really four different types of
streams there's readable writeable
duplex and transform
the readable stream through which data
can be read
the writable strings that you can
actually write to
a duplex is a stream where is both
readable and writeable
and
transform our streams that can be
manipulate the data
while it is being read or written
so how do you update and delete a
dependency so say for instance we want
to install
something like express so if you wanted
to install express what you would do
is you would just write them inside of
your project you want to go to terminal
window and write in the command npm
install express
if you want to update the dependencies
within your node package manager to
update all of them all you have to do is
write the command npm update all
dependencies
and then if you want to explicitly
uninstall a dependency such as
express.js
that's using the uninstall command and
so that would again be going to terminal
window and you would type npm uninstall
express
and again it's really easy to create a
simple server in node.js that will run a
simple command
the http service is actually built into
node.js you don't need to use express.js
i typically use express.js when i want
to do a web server because typically
what i find is that i will want to go
and do something more complicated but if
you want to do something that
illustrates just the core functionality
uh within node.js you can actually just
require the core http service that
actually comes as part of node.js and
then you can actually then go ahead and
tell it to create a service and then to
write in plain text a command
or text string such as in this case
it'll be hello world and that would pop
out and then the final line is to then
listen that if you go to a web browser
that's on port
127.0.01 or localhost
and go to
port colon 8080 once you actually go to
that that will trigger this application
and you'll get the text hello world pop
up on your screen
so explain synchronous and non-blocking
apis in node.js
so all the apis
in node.js are asynchronous which means
that they are non-blocking which means
you can run them continuously
and scale around that which is just
fantastic it's one of the reasons why
node.js can scale so fast and the eighth
means that the apis can return data send
data after it's been called and really
increase the efficiency of events as
they are triggered within node.js
so how do you implement async and
node.js and so the example that we have
on the left hand side allows us to
trigger async and it's using the async
function
and as you can see in this example uh
it's actually something that can be done
very quickly in this example we're
actually
making a command to logo host and app
that's running on port 3000 and then
depending on
what we get if there's an error message
and then we'll have error message go to
the console log which is the terminal
window and if
we get a response to an application
then we'll actually get a positive
response which would be fetched response
so
again very quickly and easy that you use
the async function uh to be able to
build out and you to get your
asynchronous code
so what is the purpose of module exports
so
a module export is a way to encapsulate
your the entire code for a solution in a
single package in a single file and then
you can then
share that with other developers so
you're all working from the same
environment
so what is a callback function in
node.js a callback function is
essentially that once you run and you've
triggered an event and the response has
been given
you want to be able to then have a
callback to validate that the task is
complete
all right let's move on to the final set
of questions which is advanced node.js
questions
so what is reppl in node.js so repl
stands for read eval print and loop and
this is a reference to the
unix and linux background that node.js
has
so raffle will form the following tasks
the read will be actually
passing the javascript you'll read that
and store it in memory eval
takes and evaluates the data structure
print will then print the results often
on the console window or onto a web page
and then loop and loops the above
command until the user presses ctrl c
twice
what is the control flow function
so the control flow function is a piece
of code that runs between several of the
asynchronous functions and that's it it
actually controls how those functions
execute
so how control flow controls the
function calls and it does it through
four ways one is it controls the order
of execution
it collects the data it limits the
concurrency and then it also calls the
next step in a program again this is a
management tool for how your functions
are called within node.js
so what is the difference between fork
and spawn methods in node.js
so the essential difference between the
two of them is that if you use the fork
method it will actually trigger and
create a new instance of the v8 engine
the engine running node.js
and will then run the application in
that new instance
with spawn it's somewhat similar it
doesn't actually generate a new v8
instance so it's actually creating a new
process but it's within the same v8
instance as the previous application
that it was spawned from
explain to me what is the use of buffer
class in node.js
so with the buffer class what you're
looking at doing is you're actually
controlling the raw data of a set of
arrays and integers and the memory
allocation outside of the v8 heap buffer
class is used because pure javascript is
not compatible with binary data
what is piping in node.js
so
piping is the ability to connect the
output of one stream to another stream
that could be a data stream it could be
any stream that you're working with
but it does normally get used to pass
data from one stream to another
so what are some of the flags used in
the rewrite operation files
so r dash is used for read w's for
opening a file for writing
a dash is opening a file for appending
so the collection that you have here you
don't have to really memorize all of
them but to have a few of them in the
back of your mind is always a good
reference point
so how would you open a file using
node.js
so
the syntax you would use would be the
fs.open and that would then open up a
file
explain to me what callback hell is
so callback hell also known as the
pyramid of doom is when you have too
many
nested unreadable and unmanageable
callbacks intensively cycle within each
other and they're constantly reading to
each other and they're not able to
resolve the solution
and
this is a you know it's a big problem
and this is what why it's called
callback hell because you're not able to
finalize the the app you're working on
what is a reactive pattern in node.js
and so reactor pattern is a concept of
non-blocking i o operations
can you explain to me the test pyramid
for node.js so the test pyramid and this
is standard for testing uh for all
devops is really split into three key
areas you have unit tests integration
tests and then end to end or e2e tests
the unit tests are tests that you
actually do in your raw code
that you're working on and the goal
there is to be able to validate that the
code you're writing is consistently
working
integration allows you to um have tests
that integrate your raw code that you're
working with in your application with
other areas of an application and then
end to end is the whole system the whole
interface as it were for your solution
describe the exit codes of node.js
so annexa code is a specific code that
identifies the end of a specific process
and examples of exit codes are
unused uncalled fatal exception
fatal error
internal javascript evaluation area
these are all good examples of exit
codes
so what is
a middleware can you explain the concept
of middleware in node.js
so
with middleware it is the ability to be
able to connect to a system and get data
from it
that's outside of node.js so
this may be executing a type of code or
updating a modifying request in response
to a specific type of object
finishing the request response cycle
can you explain to me what are the types
of http requests that you may use when
working with node.js
there are actually quite a lot but four
of them that you might use would be get
post
head and delete
and these are if you've done any web
application before particularly worked
with forms inside of a web application
you're probably very familiar certainly
with get and post
again it's the request to retrieve data
post is generally used for changing
stating and data
head is similar to get but also ask for
a response if there's no body content so
if you're using if you're developing an
api this would be a good one to use and
delete is used to delete the
predetermined source
so how would you connect to mongodb
database and with node.js and you use
that using the client and the
example we have on the left hand side
and illustrates that
what is the use of node underscore env
and so this node underscore emv is an
environment variable that stands for
node environment in express server so
the example we have on the right hand
side allows you to illustrate how you
would do that for say a production
environment
so what are some of the various timing
features in node.js so
the timing functions that you could use
here set timeout and then clear timeout
and you to schedule code execution that
you'd have inside of your application
you also have set interval clear
interval to execute a block of code up
multiple times in your application
set intermediate and clear intermediate
to
execute code and that is at the end of
your application
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simplylearn click
on the link in the description to know
more
let's go ahead and begin with what is
react react is a javascript library used
to build fast and interactive user
interfaces for both web and mobile
applications now one thing that makes
react extremely powerful is the fact
that it's open source any user can
access its source code modify it and
enhance it in a typical model view
controller architecture react defines
the view part of the application it is
also responsible for how the app looks
and feels fun fact react was built by
jordan walkey an engineer at facebook
now let's go ahead and see how react
works in real time consider a typical
web application say instagram the entire
ui of the web page is divided into
several components we have the search
component a profile description
component stories component and a post
list component these components make the
code easier to debug and always remain
discrete components also make
development and maintenance of web
applications faster as multiple
developers can work simultaneously on
different components of the same web
application now let's see why react is
so popular these days the act helps in
creation of dynamic web applications it
also provides performance enhancements
now there are several performance
enhancements like virtual dom and
one-way data binding we'll learn about
these topics a little later in the video
react uses reusable components now this
helps decrease the development time
react involves unidirectional flow of
data react also has a small learning
curve compared to other frameworks like
angular react is much easier to learn
react can also be used for mobile
applications react recently released an
extension called react native that is
used for developing mobile applications
that are cross-compatible it also has
dedicated tools for easy debugging now
let's dive in to the features of react
first let's understand jsx jsx is a
syntax extension to javascript using jsx
we can add html to the javascript file
all coding in react is done using jsx it
also helps in making the code easier to
understand and debug ultimately jsx is a
combination of javascript and html now
let's consider a small example cons
simple here is a javascript notation h1
tags indicate html again the semicolon
indicates javascript note that the
semicolon is not mandatory however it's
a good practice to include it moving on
the next feature is virtual dom dom
which is an acronym for data object
model actually defines how documents are
accessed and manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the web page in the form of a tree
now let's see how this actually works
react creates a virtual dom that is the
exact copy of the real dom traditionally
whenever something changes in the web
application all objects in the real dom
are updated this makes it extremely slow
let's see how react counters this now
consider two objects whose states have
been changed react now compares the
virtual dom with the virtual dom
snapshot that was taken right before the
update by comparing the new virtual dom
with the pre-update version react
figures out exactly which virtual dom
objects have changed now react only
updates those objects on the virtual dom
this makes a big difference when it
comes to speed coming to the next
feature performance react uses virtual
dom as discussed earlier virtual dog
impacts the speed of the web
applications we also took an example of
instagram and learned how multiple
components can affect the development
time they help improve performance
drastically the next feature is one way
data binding this means information
flows in only one direction one way data
binding is specifically used when
information is displayed and not updated
remember that the components of react
are functional in nature that is they
receive information through arguments
and pass information via their return
values the next important feature is
extensions react has many extensions
that we can use to create full-fledged
front-end applications it provides
server-side rendering which means that
the application is rendered on the
server rather than in the browser react
native which is a react extension is
used for developing mobile applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development now let's look at a few of
them react native lets you build mobile
applications using only javascript a
react native app is a real mobile
application and not just a web
application running on your mobile
devices thousands of applications like
facebook instagram pinterest skype use
react native the next popular react
extension is flux flux is the
application architecture that facebook
uses flux implements a unidirectional
flow which makes it easier to understand
what actually is going on now let's see
how it works when we trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them to the stores a store is
what holds the data of an application
stores will register with the
application's dispatcher so that they
can receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views actions define the
internal api of your application they
capture how anything might interact with
your application the last feature of
react is debugging react applications
are easy to debug thanks to the large
and active developer community you can
practically debug react codes within
your browser now notice the small react
extension icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code and also easily debug
it moving on let's learn about the
building blocks of react components
state and props are the essential
concepts that one should know before
implementing react they are the
foundation on which react is built now
what exactly are react components
components
are the building blocks of any react
application react divides the user
interface into multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element is viewed in the
application react components remain
discrete and are processed independently
another feature is reusability
components can be reused multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time consider the following
code snippet a component is implemented
as a javascript class having some state
and a render method state is the data
which we want the component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the ui looks and feels to the user the
next concept is state state of a
component is an object that holds some
data this data influences the output of
a component every time the state of an
object changes the component is
re-rendered onto the screen now let's
see what props are props or short for
properties allow us to pass arguments or
data to components properties help make
components more dynamic it is important
to define all the properties their types
and their default value props are passed
to components in a way similar to that
of html tag attributes now consider the
following code snippets this shows
exactly how properties are passed to
components also detailed illustrations
on components props and state will be
shown in the upcoming videos so stay
tuned for that
moving on let's go through some of the
things that you should know before you
can actually start working on react you
should be familiar with programming
concepts like functions objects arrays
and classes one should also have a basic
knowledge of javascript and a
familiarity with html don't worry if you
feel like you're not good at them once
you start working on them you'll get a
good hang of it finally let's go through
the impact of react on the it industry
and get insights into the salaries of
react developers statistics show that
react developers earn way more than
other web developers according to pay
scale the average salary for a react
developer in the united states is a
whopping 91 000 us dollars the average
salary for a react developer in india is
7.25 lakhs per annum over the recent
years react has gained immense
popularity and is being adopted by many
companies according to the data by
google trends react has had a better
growth scale compared to other
frameworks like angular and vue
statistics show that front-end
developers have wholeheartedly adopted
this lightweight framework forgoing
other available options if you are
skilled and have a knack for front-end
development react can help you gain
fantastic career opportunities lastly
talking about a few companies that use
react devotionally we have facebook
instagram netflix dropbox whatsapp among
others to set up the react development
environment we need two things installed
node and a text editor of your choice so
let's begin by installing node.js we can
head to the official node.js website
save download
node.js so here you can see the windows
installer depending on your system you
can either download the 32-bit version
or the 64-bit version so i'm going to go
ahead and click on the 64-bit version
since it's already installed on my
system i'm not again installing node you
can follow the installation guidelines
and download it once you're done with
node installation you can go ahead and
download a text editor of your choice so
i'd suggest vs code so let's head to the
vs code page say download vs code click
on the first link and download the
64-bit version for windows once you're
done with the installation of both node
and your text editor you can start
creating your first react application so
for that let's create a folder
i'm creating it on my desktop while you
can create it in any of your drives
let's call it
first
react now open your command prompt now
you can type in the path for the folder
that you just created so say
cd
users
first react now go ahead and type in the
command npm
install
hyphen g create
react
app okay so this command installs all
the necessary react.js modules now to
check if the version is correctly
installed you can type in create
react app version so you can see the
version here now let's continue and
develop your react application type in
the command create
react app
and you can give a name to your
application so i say my app
now this should take a couple of minutes
okay once you've successfully created an
application
they say to begin by typing the
following commands so let's do that save
cd
my app and npm start this should
typically start your application and
here we go
all right you can also open your
application in the text editor that
you've downloaded so let's go ahead and
open vs code vs code file
open folder go to your desktop or the
drive that you saved your folder in
first react
my app and i say select folder so as you
can see all your modules have been
imported you can click on app.js and
start editing what exactly are
components components are the building
blocks of a react application wherein
each component represents a part of the
user interface now to make it more
understandable consider the facebook
home page the entire ui can be broken
down into several elements say we have
the credentials component the sign up
component the image component and the
logo component notice that each
component adds something to how the home
page looks right reusability is one of
the salient features of react components
one component can be reused several
times across the application and this
improves the development speed
components can also be nested one
component can internally consist of
several other components in its minimal
form a component must define a render
method that specifies how exactly the
application looks and feels a component
can also receive properties from its
parent components also you'll get a
better understanding of all of these
when we start working hands-on so don't
worry so moving on let's look at the
different types of components first we
have the stateless functional components
and then we have the stateful class
components now functional components are
typical javascript functions that return
html now they can be contained in a dot
js or a dot jsx file coming to class
components these are regular es6 classes
however it's mandatory that they contain
a render method that in turn returns
html they can also be contained in dot
jx or a dot jsx file okay then let's go
ahead and build our first react
application using components all right
so i've opened my text editor that is vs
code to build my application also i
suggest you watch the react installation
on windows video to help you get started
the video briefly explains how to
install node and how to start building
your first react application in my case
i've opened a folder called react
component tutorial and here in my source
folder i have app.js now app.js is the
main component that gets rendered to the
dom let me show you that here in
index.js you pass app.js which is a
component that gets rendered to the
react dom so app.js consists of several
other components that can be nested so
as you can see app.js is a functional
component and before moving on let me
get rid of all the unnecessary code so
let me delete all of this
and return
an h1 tag that says hello welcome to
simply let me save it and if you look at
the browser you'll have hello welcome to
simply learn now let's go ahead and
display another message say h1
this
video is about
components let me save it and let me
check the browser
it gives you an error so jsx uses a
conventional rule which states that all
html tags have to be enclosed within a
div tag so for example i say div
and i enclose it so let me save and
check my browser again here you go so
multiple html tags have to be enclosed
within the div tag moving on let's
create a first functional component to
do that i'll first create a folder in my
source folder say components within that
i'll create a file say functional
component.js
all right so the first thing we have to
do is import react so i say import react
from yeah the general syntax for a
functional component involves the
keyword function
and say
functional
component
now you say return an h1 tag or i've
already used h1 tags so i'll say
paragraph and i say
this is
a functional component all right before
explaining to you how these components
are exported and imported let me show
you the general syntax for a class
component so i create another file say
class component dot js i again import
react from react the general notation is
using the class keyword followed by the
name of the class extending from the
base class react dot component so going
ahead i say class class component
extends react dot component now the key
feature of a class component is the
usage of a render method so i say render
within braces i say return a paragraph
tag saying this is
the class component all right so moving
on let's see how these components can be
nested into the main component that is
app.js components can be nested into the
main component using import and export
keywords so as the name suggests export
feature is used to export a particular
file or a module and import is used to
import a particular file or module into
the current existing module so we have
two different types of exports you have
default export and just export or named
export so a default export is used to
export just one object be it a function
a class a variable from the file and
there can only be one default export
profile and when you're importing it you
can specify the address and use the word
import before it so let me show you how
it works let's go back to our editor and
then functional component and here i say
export default and the name of the
functional component that is
functional com so let me save this and
going back to my app.js i say import
name of the functional component that is
functional com from and i pass the path
this components slash functional
component also let me get rid of these
unnecessary
files here now let's define functional
component in our app.js component so
here i say functional comp let's compile
it and check our browser here it says
this is a functional component moving on
to my class component it's the same
syntax here as well i say export default
name of my component and in my app.js i
import it
import class comp from
the path and again i'll have to define
it in my return method i save so let me
compile it and check my browser it says
this is the class component one unique
feature of default export is that i can
rename the file while i'm importing it
so for example i can rename it as say fc
and while i'm defining it i'll have to
make sure i use the same naming
conventions so i say fc again and when i
check it it says this is the functional
component there's literally no
difference the next type of export is
the named export or just export so a
named export can be used to export
multiple objects be it functions class
etc from a file now there can be several
named exports from a single file one
hack is that while you're importing it
cannot be renamed so let me show you how
this works okay so let's create another
class in our class component so i'll
just copy paste this
let me give it another name say class
com1 and the message that i want to
display is hey i'm another class all
right so when i'm exporting it i don't
want default so let me take it off and
say export here all right
in my app.js while importing it i want
to import both the classes so i'll
include them within curly braces here i
say class comp comma class comp 1 and
then again i define it here class comp
1. let's compile it and run it and here
we go here you can see hey i'm another
class so we've successfully exported
both the classes from the class
component and imported it back in our
app.js component one advantage of using
named export is the fact that i can
choose to import the classes that i want
to now say for example i do not want to
import class component here so let me
take it off and here let me
comment this now let's compile and see
hey am another class the second class
got imported while the first class that
was defined earlier is not imported here
all right so next up we have higher
order and pure competence now i won't
get into the nativities of it because
they're advanced topics but to give you
a brief insight higher order components
are basically functions that take in a
component and return a new component the
whole ideology behind higher order
components is to facilitate the
reusability of component logic okay so
let's see how this works let's go back
to our code editor let's create a
component in our components folder let's
call the component
click
dot js all right so here we define a
class i use this snippet rce here we go
we get the entire format using the small
snippet rce and here i'm going to make
use of a button now see i use the tag
button and i'll say
clicked
one time every time the user clicks on
the button the value gets incremented so
for this i'm going to use a variable say
count and i'm going to use the concept
of states so let's go ahead and define
our variable count and initialize it to
zero so for that i'm going to use
another snippet called r const and here
this dot state equals my variable count
initializing it to zero so let's define
the count variable in a render method so
i say const count equals this dot state
so every time we click on the button the
count value has to get incremented right
so we make use of an event called on
click equals
this dot
update click
now update click is going to be another
method that we have to define now so
every time the button gets clicked this
method is called so let's go ahead and
define the function
so it is update click equals it's going
to be an arrow function and i say
this dot set state is nothing but count
this dot
state dot count plus one okay and here
we say
count times all right so once this is
done let's import our component in
app.js so here again
i say import click from components click
and let's define it here so let's check
our browser every time we click on the
button the value gets incremented all
right so let's go ahead and create
another component say counter.js wherein
every time the user hovers the mouse on
the button the count value increases so
let's go ahead and do that i say
counter dot js i'm again going to use
the snippet rce to create a class
component and here in my div tag i
define a button and say incremented
to for now i say x so now let's go ahead
and add the event say button
on
mouse
enter
i'm going to call the method this dot
increment count okay so once you're done
with that let's go ahead and define the
increment count method i'm going to copy
the same code that i've mentioned in my
click.js so i say copy this all right so
one change is that i change the name of
the method and
call it increment count again let's
define the count in our render method so
i say const count equals
this dot state and here i change x to
come now let's go ahead and import it in
our app.js so i say import counter
from
components and countdown and let's
define it here all right let's save it
and let's run the code okay so as you
can see you see another button here
incremented to zero and every time i
move my cursor on the button it
increments mind you i'm not clicking i'm
just hovering my mouse okay to learn how
higher order components work we'll have
to pass counter.js and click.js as
parameters to give birth to an entire
new component so for that let's go ahead
and create another component for our hoc
let's call it
higher order dot js okay so i say import
react
from react after that i say const
updated component equals
original component that's going to be an
arrow function again and within curly
braces i define my class that is class
say new component extends
react
dot component inside let's define a
render method
that returns the original component with
a modification that is i want to type
the user i want to append the user
before the actual message is displayed
all right so let's go ahead and close
the tag and return new component and
let's export this say export
default updated component
now we import higherorder.js in our
counter.js and click.js and pass these
components as parameters so let's do
that let's go to our counter.js and here
i say
import updated component
from
dot slash higher order component and
here while exporting i say updated comp
and pass this as my parameter let's do
the same to click.js here i import
data.com from higher order component and
here i pass this as a parameter now here
in a higher order component we've
defined a property name and initialized
it to the user so we'll have to include
this in our other components that's
counter and click so let's do that and
here right before incremented to i say
this dot props
dot name let me save it let me do the
same thing here and say
this dot props dot name so if we go back
to our browser here you can see it says
the user clicked zero times and the user
incremented to zero okay so this
basically shows how react implements
reusability of components moving on our
next topic is pure components now
another way to create class component is
by extending pure component from react a
pure component avoids unnecessary
re-renders now how does it do it it does
not implement the should component
update method now you learn about this
method a little later in the video now
this method enables re-rendering of
components to the dom but a pure
component on the other hand ensures a
shallow comparison of states and props
and checks if a re-render is actually
necessary only then does it render to
the dom a react component can be
considered pure if it renders the same
output for the same state and props so
let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code and create two component classes
one for a regular component and the
other for a pure component now using
this example i'll show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create a
purecomponent.js file i say pureform.js
so here i'm going to use a snippet rpce
that is going to create a pure component
class let me get rid of this export and
here in my div tag i'll display the text
say i'm
the pure component all right now let's
go ahead and create a regular component
let me call it
regularcomponent.js and here i'm going
to use the snippet rce and the message
that i want to display is
i'm
the regular component so to draw a
comparison between the regular component
and the pure component let's create a
parent component for the two so let me
create one here i'll call it parent
component.js and this is again going to
be a regular class component and here i
display the message i am the parent
component to change the state of the
component we're going to make use of a
constructor so let's use the snippet our
const and here let me create
name you can give anything and i say
simply learn now we make use of the
component did mount lifecycle method to
set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're going to learn about it
a little later in the video so moving
ahead i'm going to make use of the
method and say component
did mount and here i say set interval
the first argument is going to be an
arrow function and the second will be
the time interval and i'm going to be
setting it to 3 seconds now within the
arrow function i'll make use of the set
state function to set the state of my
property however i do not change the
name i keep it simple on itself moving
on let's import pure component and the
regular component into a parent
component and then pass name as a
property so to do that first import
purecomp
from your component and then i say
import regular com from regular com.js
and here let's say regular comp name
equals this dot state dot
name and i say pure component name
equals this
dot state dot name now let's include the
property name in both our regular and
pure components so to do that let's just
say this dot
drop dot name
and here i again say this
dot prop dot name and finally let's
import parent component into our app.js
component so here i say import parent
com from okay and here let me define
parent.com
so now if you look at the browser we
have i'm the parent and regular
component simply learn and i'm the pure
component simply done we've got the
result as expected now to check if the
pure component is actually re-rendering
or not let's include simple console.log
statements so here i say clg snippet and
here i say
pure
component
render and in my regular component i do
the same thing i say console.log regular
component
render now let's do the same in our
parent component as well here and say
parent
component render all right so let's go
back to our browser and inspect it in
our console
first the parent component gets rendered
then the regular component and then the
pure component after that for every
three seconds only the parent component
and the regular component is rendered
for the same state and prop the pure
component is not re-rendered so in
conclusion pure components optimize
react codes and also improves
performance so coming to the last topic
component life cycle so basically
comprehend life cycle explains the
stages the component goes through the
entire life cycle of a component can be
divided into three parts we have
mounting updation and unmounting so the
first thing that gets invoked in the
life cycle is component will mount it is
invoked right before the initial
rendering occurs then we have the
rendering method now once the component
is inserted into the dom component did
mount gets invoked coming to the next
phase we have updation when a complaint
receives props component will receive
props gets invoked set state is called
when the state of the property changes
so every time there is a change react
decides whether the next component state
should trigger a re-render or not to do
that should component update method is
called component will update is invoked
right before re-rendering after
re-rendering component did update is
called that makes updates to the dom and
the last phase is unmounted component
will on mount method does all the
necessary clean up and erases all the
allocated memory and cycles moving ahead
let's learn about another striking
feature of react.js called props props
short for properties allow the user to
pass arguments or data to components a
pairing component can pass additional
information to its children using props
properties help make components more
dynamic props are passed to components
in the way similar to that of html track
attributes now we'll look at this a
little later in the video props in a
component are read only and cannot be
changed one thing to remember is that
props are sent by the parent to the
children components hence the children
components cannot make any changes to
these props now that we've learnt about
props in brief let's go ahead and create
our application using props if you're
new to this tutorial i suggest you go to
the react installation and react
components video on our channel so back
in my code editor that is vs code i've
opened a folder called react props
and now i'm going to create a component
a class component and i'll call it class
props dot js so let's create the class
component i give rce the snippet
and here i display a message saying an
h1 tag basically
[Music]
all right
now let me get rid of export here and
import it in my app.js main component
here i say import
class props
all right now we define the class
component in our render method
let's say
all right
now if you go back to the browser you
see hello learners welcome to simply
learning now let's say we want to
individually welcome every student
instead of retyping the message for
everybody we can pass their names as
props now let's see how to do that now
we pass the name as a property from the
main component that is app.js to the
child component and render this onto the
browser so let's do that so here
while i'm defining my child component i
say name
i save it and here in my child component
instead of learners
i say i use a keyword this
dot props
dot name
let me save it and if you look at the
browser we'll have hello learner one
welcome to simply learn now let's go
ahead and welcome learner 2 and learner
3 so i again say class props
name
equals
learner 2.
all right so if we save and look at the
browser we'll have all the three
learners displayed on the browser we can
also pass multiple props to the child
component now say for example we want to
welcome the student from a particular
place so we say welcome learner1 from
place x
so i can here
define another property say place
[Music]
and say place
similarly i can do it
for the rest two
say place y
now let's go back to our class props.js
component and here say hello
learner1
from
this dot props
dot
place
let me save it and if you look at the
browser now we have hello learner1 from
place x place y and place z we can also
display whatever we want between the
opening and closing tags when invoking a
component now this is facilitated using
props.children reserved keyword now let
me explain to you how it's done with an
example here let's split the self and
closing tag into
an opening and a closing tag and in
between them let me display a message
within the paragraph tag let me say
and in my
child component
after my h1 tag
let me use a paragraph tag and here
let's use the reserved keyword this dot
props dot children
so let's save it
and now if you look at the browser you
can here see the message displayed child
component so prop stop children can be
used when components do not know about
their children ahead of time this is
commonly seen in components like sidebar
and dialogue that represent generic
boxes so let's go ahead and create a
button tag and check again
so here
i'll split it and add a button tag
and say click
and let's check our browser
here we go
we get the output as expected all right
we saw the usage of props for class
components similarly we can use it for
functional components so let's go ahead
and create a functional component let me
call it
i say import
react from
react
and then i say function
function props
and here i return
an h3 tag
i'll say this is
functional component
and i'll return another h3 tag
saying
hello learner
so let me save this
and let's export it
export
default
function props
[Music]
and import it
in our app.js again
import
[Music]
function drop from
function problem
and here in our render method let's
define it
let me call
function prop
name
let me give learner 4
and
place
place say a
let me close it
and back in our functional component
instead of learner
i say
props dot
name
let me save it
now if you look at our browser it gives
us an error it says props is not defined
so let's go back to our code editor and
pass props here
to our functional component also
let me define hello props dot name
from
props dot place
let me enclose it within the div tag
here
[Music]
let me save it and now if you look at a
browser here we go we get the output as
expected let's begin and learn what
exactly is a state in react typically a
state is an object that stores the
values of properties belonging to a
component now these values can change
over a period of time either via user
interactions or network changes and the
state helps facilitate this
functionality every time the state
changes react re-renders the component
to the browser the state is initialized
in the constructor a state can also
store multiple properties a method
called set state is used to update the
value of the state object now this
function performs a shallow merge on the
new and the previous state
conventionally a shallow merge ensures
that the previous state values are
overwritten by the new state values
moving on in our previous video we
learned about props and although props
and state dictate and control the
behavior of a component they have
significant differences so let's go
ahead and draw a comparison between the
two firstly props in a component are
used to pass data and event handlers to
its children while state on the other
hand is used to store the data that has
to be rendered on the web page props are
immutable once said by the parent they
cannot be changed state holds volatile
data and can be changed over time props
can be used in functional and class
components while state is restricted to
class components props are set by the
parent component while a state is
generally updated by event handlers now
that we've learned all about state let's
go ahead and build an application to see
the working of state all right so in my
code editor that is vs code i've created
my application say state and here in my
source folder i have my app.js file now
here i'm going to get rid of all the
unnecessary code that i'm not going to
be using also i suggest you go through
the react installation on windows video
to help you get started with creating
your first application so let's create
our class component say class app
extends react dot component and inside i
have a render method that returns an
html tag
let's display a message welcome
let's follow the jsx conventions and
enclose all the html tags within the div
tag so i say
div
class name equals app we also have to
import the app.css file import app
dot css
so we save it and if you look at the
browser we have welcome now let's
beautify our code to do that let's add
some styling so here in my app.js class
component i say styles equals
and i say font
style and i set it to say bold and i say
color
say teal and here in my h1 tag i say
style equals
this
dot
styles so let me save it and if you look
at the browser now we have welcome in
teal and it's bold now let's go ahead
and create a class component to
understand state so first i create a
folder and i call it components and
inside this folder i create a class
component and i call it new comp dot js
and i use the snippet rce to create the
class component to give you an insight
into what we're doing today we'll
display a message asking the user to
subscribe to simply learn once the user
clicks on the subscribe button we
instruct them to click on the bell icon
and finally we display a thank you
message now to do all of this we're
going to make use of state and as
mentioned earlier we initialize the
state object in a constructor so let's
use the snippet r const to create a
constructor now in the state object we
initialize a property let's call it
message and we display a message saying
subscribe to simply learn let's save it
and here in our render method let's say
class name
equals app and let's create an h3 tag
and within the tag i display the message
so i say
this
dot
state dot message let's save it and now
let's import it in our app.js component
so i'll get rid of export here and here
i say
import new com from components and
newcom and let's define it here and say
new so we save it and look at the
browser it says subscribe to simply
learn all right again to make our code
look more presentable let's add in
styles so i'll just copy the same styles
that i've added here and i'll paste them
here and instead of bold i make it
italic
and
i change the color to say
purple and again in my h3 tag
i define style and initialize it to
distort styles so let me save it and now
if you look at the browser it's in
italic and it's in purple
okay so moving ahead let's create a
button that reads subscribe and once the
user clicks on it the button should be
subscribed and the message displayed
above should instruct the user to click
on the bell icon to do that let's first
create a button the message that i want
the button to read is subscribe however
this message gets changed once the user
clicks on the button so instead of
explicitly mentioning subscribe here i
create a prop i say sub and i say
subscribe here and back in my render
method i say this dot state dot sub so
let's save it and if you look at the
browser now you have a button which
displays a message subscribe now once
the user clicks on the button the
message displayed should change to click
on the bell icon to never miss an update
so let's create an event handler for
that so here
button on click i call another method
and let's call the method
button
change okay so this method should update
the state and change the message and sub
values to do that we make use of a set
state method now a state can be updated
in response to event handlers server
responses or prop changes now all the
updation can be done using the set state
method now this is the general syntax
used by the method we'll however look at
this further in the demo now the set
state method conventionally encues all
the updates made to the component state
and instructs react to read enter the
component and its children with the
updated state now let's go back to our
code editor and look at the working of
this method now here i defined the arrow
function button change if you are not
familiar with arrow functions i suggest
you read up on them and this is the
general syntax and here i say this dot
set state and inside i change my message
to
hit the bell icon to never
miss an update and my sub value changes
to subscribed
let's save this and now if you look at
the browser when we click on the
subscribe button the message changes to
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update so moving ahead let's use a bell
icon so that the user can click on it
once he clicks on the image the image
changes and the thank you message
appears on the screen so for that i have
two images i have bell a and bell b so i
drag and drop both the images in my
components folder all right
now let's import these images into our
new com.js file
here i say import bell a
from
bell a dot png
and again i say import bell b from
bell b
dot png all right let me save it to
display the image on the screen we make
use of the image tag now this tag has
two attributes one is the source
attribute that specifies the url and the
other is the alt attribute that
specifies an alternate text for the
image so here in my component i say i
make use of a paragraph tag that will
help
display the image in the next line and
then i use the image tag now since my
image changes once it's clicked i have
to define a property and pass the event
handler click that will update the image
so here
before specifying the source let's go
back to our state and define another
property
that is image url and let's set it to
bell a since that is the image that i
want to display first let me save it and
here in my image tag i say source equals
this dot state
dot image url and then we have the alt
tag and i do not want to display any
message so i leave it as it is now let's
save it and if you look at the browser
we have a bell displayed however now
let's change the dimensions of the bell
i do not want such a huge bell so back
in my vs code i define style
with width say 30 pixels
and a height with again 30 pixels let me
save this and now if you look at the
browser we have a smaller icon so once
the user clicks on this image the emit
changes and the message displayed here
gets updated to do that we'll have to
define an event so let's go back to our
vs code and here in my image tag let's
say on click i define a method say this
dot
image change and now we define this
method here i see image change i make
use of an arrow function again
and again i use the set state method i
update the image so i say image url is
now set to bell
b and the message
is updated to thank you
happy learning
so let's save this now and if you look
at the browser we see the image and once
clicked on it the image gets updated and
the message changes so finally let me
refresh the browser once and show the
full execution let me refresh following
the instructions let's click on the
subscribe button and now it says hit the
bell icon and once i do that the image
updates and the message changes this
video on react.js helps you build two
fun applications using the library
as you all know react is a widely used
javascript library to build user
interfaces for applications
this video will make you realize why it
is adopted so widely
so first we'll build a calculator app
and then we'll move on to building a
spotify clone this time we're going to
introduce you another very interesting
project using this javascript html css
so called calculator application so
let's get started let me try to delete
first those files which we really do not
need it now
we delete this all
yeah now i'll be creating a new folder
now and give the name called
calculator app
and in this calculator app once again we
need some new files which is called
index
dot html
and we also need one more that is called
app.css
and another one that is called app.js
so these three files required now first
of all i would start with
index.html file where we'll be creating
a template of my code
now
let me go and create this template and
here
i have a god body with me
let's start with the
first
tag here that is called h1
and this h1 we are giving the name
called calculator
calculator
so that will be my h1 heading
after that i will start working with the
div tag
now within this div
i would have to create lot many classes
i may not have lot many cs classes but
we can give some classes here so we can
say class equal to
container
okay so within this div tag we're going
to create a table now because i want to
organize it
so i'm starting with the table within
this table
tr tag
and within this track i need a td
now in this td i need few things called
call
span
equal to three
another value
and here
i want to offer the text box
input type equal to
text
okay input up to text id equal to give
the name called result
that will be the final outcome while uh
pressing all the different buttons id
equal to result and
class
equal to
screen remember i haven't created those
css classes but but we're giving some
names but later on we can utilize it
while creating those css classes
table data is getting closed let's get
started with another td
now insert this td we need another text
box
input type equal to
text
and
here in this input text sorry i would
like to better say button because i'll
be having
buttons
okay
input i'm equal to
button
value
equal to
c
and uh on click
equal to i may not have any function
right now but yes i can create
a function but let me give some dummy
name here i'm saying clear
screen
okay so that will be the function will
get called
and after that class
equal to
clear
yeah so this is my
button tag
after this the td tag is getting closed
after the td tag the table row is also
getting closed
after the table row which is getting
close we're going to start working with
another table row
okay and in this table row i'm going to
create one more td
so let's go ahead and create
another td here and inside this td i'll
be having another button we get created
so i'll just say
this is my another button now input
equal to button value equal to
one on click equal to i'll be calling
another function called display
okay
and inside this we're giving the value
call one
okay and class equal to member
class equal to
number
and here after that tag is getting
closed
okay now you have to start another td
tag here
okay like that we have to keep on
creating the multiple buttons so let me
copy
and paste another table data
now here
again value equal to 2 on click product
display
give the value call 2
and class equal to what
number
like that i'll keep on creating multiple
buttons but first check how it actually
looks like it
now i can see the buttons like in c one
two three
but yes i'm gonna create few more
buttons one after another
okay so i'll go here
and create a few more buttons so this is
where the table data is getting closed
okay i'll copy this
and paste it again
how to create
the button
like in three four something like that
so after this two we're giving the value
called three
yeah
i'll get the value called three
so val equal to two value equal to three
display three
and then afterwards
just giving the value call
forward slash
and here also you're gonna keep the
value call
forward slash
and here class equal to
operator
after that
you have to do the value count 4
and then followed by 567
so here we give 4
four
five
six
after six we're giving call minus
[Music]
okay once again it will be what type of
operator
okay after this
minus we'll be talking about call seven
then we have to have eight
okay nine
okay after that we're giving for plus
and display
plus plus equal to operator
operator okay so here
you can see the table data is getting
closed and here the table is also
getting closed
and after this table row you can start
working with
another table row here
and
after this table row we can start
working with again
td let me have this
again
inside this i'll be giving the option
called decimal which is value equal to
dot and here we get the value called
decimal
okay
now display zero
so after giving this dot to basically
take what the value
zero which we haven't put now
we'll be talking about value called zero
so here
the decimal value we have given it td is
getting close let me have another one
zero
so like that we have to keep this now
after that
we'll be once again
taking this and this time rather than
giving this zero
we'll be using this call as a button and
value equal to
equal
or click equal to
solve
okay and then this soft will not be
passing anything
it will write a normal function
and plus equal to
equal
okay
so
table data is getting closed
so we will be using another table data
now
so here it will be the button only
okay we will be using
value equal to
multiplication
display
plastic and here we'll be using operator
okay
so table data is getting close table
rows getting close table is also getting
closed here
okay so your dev tag is also getting
okay that's it
okay so that's the only thing which we
wanted to make let me try to refresh and
check
awesome
so we have got
all those
necessary calculator behavior
which
we wanted to
reveal
okay
now our next statement will be once we
are giving this c then we have to call
one two three
and then forward slash
followed by
four five six will come down
okay so let me check whether we have
used six or not
okay so we haven't used six
so let me check here
four five six
so let me go back here
four five six let me copy this
and paste it later on
before
minus
six
equal to
number
okay so we're almost set now
so we are having this uh
look and feel
in this we are giving one two three four
five six
and after this we have a call minus and
then plus related behavior so we are all
set now and after that we'll be
basically applying the css as well as
the javascript look towards my code okay
thank you
well everybody we are all good to go now
but i just want to first check whether
my
uh this outlook is looking properly or
not see what my expectation is after one
two three forward slash i really want to
bring four five six to the next
and then seven eight nine and again
forward still but i can think this is
absolutely unorganized
so after this when we say
this uh forward slash which we have used
after hyphen
okay your td is getting closed here
okay so here the tr i also want to close
here
okay and after this tr i also want to
start
another tr here
okay so that i can put them into the
another level now
so under this tr i can use this td now
so after this minus
after four five six
minus
once again i would like to start
another table over here
okay so that it let's go to the next row
so here
after td
we're closing this dr
and starting
another tier
okay we're starting another tier after
that we talk about 789
okay plus
see here talking about 789 plus here the
table is getting close and it is
starting right now like this
see that looks better now
okay but still few more things which i
would like to make it even more
organized but that's not a problem we
will do it a little later on
okay because you can see eight is
missing right now
so here
seven
we copy this
equal to eight
eight
yeah that looks better now so now they
are basically completely organized
so the moment i expect my application
so we have a call
dot here then zero then equal to and
then multiplication
okay so it looks
better now
now i just would like to perform
the overall look and feel so i need to
go ahead and use what css because
without css i really can't utilize this
in a proper way so i have to start
working with a css friend now
in css front
how to start first we will go back to my
code and here in my css we will start
working with
font family but before font family i
would like to start with the body part
now
body
background color i'm using called t
that looks nice
okay so
i will be using this app.css
in my html to see the look how it has
been appeared right now
so in my index.html file
on the top under my head section
link
style sheet
okay now see it looks better now
going forward
in my css
we want to use
some h1 correct tool so here
we would like to use h1
texture line
center
color
white
margin top
margin top would like to use 50 pixels
this is for h1 let's check
perfect so it is now coming in between
next statement
will be called screen so we say
screen
so in this screen we use the background
color
diagram color
black
and two pixels
after that color
white
font size
medium
next width
we're using this
then we talk about pressure
we would like to say 10 pixels
and then
margin
save auto
then margin bottom
that i'll be using 10 pixels
so in the proper alignment
okay
look
that's how exactly we want that's for a
screen where the exact outcome will be
visible to me
and rest of the details will be showing
you one by one and now we'll be talking
about call input
okay
input
type equal to button
for input type equal to
button
okay
input application button of type
over the
button i say
background color
change to what
right what else i can say
let's smoke
okay
and
when the button is active
what i want
let me copy
and put a little button and here i say
active
and this color should be orange red
like this
you can see now how it is basically
looking like
okay active the color will be like this
okay i'll be talking about operators
operator should behave different so i'm
saying dot
operator
in this operator we are saying
background color
background color orange
okay then padding
i want five pixels
okay then i want color
that should be black
after this i'm using call border
sorry
that border
i'm using this called solid
and then black
and
after this bit
i'm using 100
then height
height is 40 pixels
then cursor
it has to be pointed
okay that's it let's check
perfect so they shall turn back to what
prior
orange color
and uh
you can see the moment you take macros
to white
perfect and now those were type number i
also want to change them
so for number
for number i want to say the same option
padding i want 5 pixels
then i need height
of type 40 pixels
then i say color
awesome so they looks nice
now we left with few
other type of options i can dot and
equal to
okay that i'm talking about called
decimal or decimal i need to have a
different options with me
okay so
let me try to copy this
paste it and i say for
does it
so for decimal background color will be
light blue
padding 5 pixels color black border
solid
okay black two pixels with hundred
percent height forty pixels five encoder
pointer
perfect
okay looks nice but i have changed the
color to light
now
i talk about
clear
okay
now come back
and say
clear
okay in this color background color is
changed to light salmon
light salmon
padding 5 pixels color black
border same width 100
height 40 pixels
fine so cursor
pointer
file margin
auto and margin bottom
merging bottom differences
let's check
perfect now it looks beautiful
okay
now
here after giving these details we're
talking what called equal part dot equal
so for dot equal also i'm just copying
the same
so you recall
background color id color
just change to
lightly
light green
and
after this
since it is a equal so we say padding
five pixels is okay color black fine
border fine with hundred percent high 40
pixels
color and cursor pointers just i don't
need to
it's for dot equal and i want
for container
container
in this container width i want 40
percent
red 40 percent background color white
okay
now here
writing is 15 pixels
so display block
so first of all you call width
okay
display block
which we're taking margin
okay in merchandising to pixels
auto
okay
now align cells
go to
center
okay border radius
border it is let's just say 10 pixels
okay now using box shadow
block shadow 5 pixels
black padding
so these are details
okay
we have it
background color we are taking it now
align cell
display block border radius padding
and then
adding 15 pixels we have given audi i
don't need to give it again
margin
okay fine
box let's try
awesome so it's looking beautiful now
okay so this is where exactly my
application
works like that
and table when we talk about
everything with
okay
that's it
super
so it's now giving me the proper look of
how
my application should be here i can just
see about the container what we have
done
with 40 we're taking background color
let's bring it below then align cell
display block
okay margin
okay
and border radius
and uh
fine so i think we're all good now
so that's it so we'll try and implement
the javascript part well everyone so our
css file is ready our html is ready it's
time to just uh
go ahead and talk about my
final portion that is called gs part
where i want to basically perform some
calculators
now here i just say function
display
function display which takes
a valve as in parameter and say
document dot
get element by id
here i'm saying
result okay dot
value
okay
plus
equal to
whatever we're adding it just basically
try to apply
calculation on the top of that
okay there's a function
after that you have another functions
available here called function solve
here in the song
we just use the value called let x equal
to
document dot get element by id
result
okay
dot
value sorry
value
okay and say connect
y
equal to
perform the calculations for the will be
using one function called
eval
and type
access and parameter
now the next statement will be again
document.
get it meanwhile id
result
dot
value equal to y
okay
now
later on
i'll like to use another function here
function
clear
screen
result
three functions are associated with me
and these three functions
are the part of this javascript file
which i'll be calling it
at the end before
the water tag get closed so here
script
equal to
f dot x
that's it okay let's try to execute now
here
two you can see the values
i will say plus
equal to 8 absolutely i say c is clearly
divided by
equal to three awesome so friends your
calculator application is ready
congratulations to all so it is a very
simplest form which we have developed
this is your html which is a template
for you this is a css which is your
complete
the area of like how the look and feel
will look like in of this template
beautification and here last year for gs
which is smaller logic but really
meaningful
okay if getting your learning started is
half the battle what if you could do
that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
let's start with uh creating a simple
demo on react.js and we are going to
create a simple application
that will connect to an online music
streaming service called spotify and we
will call our application music app so
let's get started the first step is to
first get the node.js platform and
server installed to do that let me go to
google and let's just type node.js
and here is the website
nodejs.org there are two versions
available the lts which is the stable
version and the current we'll prefer the
stable so we'll click on that and you
can see we have an option which is
called save file the moment this file is
saved to the disk we just need to double
click on it and keep clicking on the
next button to get it installed on our
system and we also have a documentation
available here so which explains most of
the features of the node platform and
there are binaries available for
different os's mac windows etc so you
can select the right witness 32-bit
64-bit and the right os
and then go ahead and download the
specific
version that suits uh your platform and
you can see here that there are
different there are also help files
available that will allow you to go
through the installation documents for
node.js installation on linux etc so to
start with uh i'm opening up the command
prompt and here is where we're going to
call the node package manager using the
node package manager which is
pre-installed with your standard node.js
installation we will initialize our
react application so we would say react
dash app and
we want to now go and create an
application called music app in this
folder so as a prerequisite for the demo
all we need to do is install node.js
from node.js.org the official website
just download it and install it and
that's when you open the command prompt
you fire npm which stands for node
package manager init for initialize
react dash app is a standard keyword to
initialize and create a skeletal
structure of a react.js application and
the name of the app is music app so
we'll hit enter we'll give this some
time and you can see it's uh started
downloading the core
react.js libraries and it is attempting
to create uh
our application so it's installing all
the prerequisite packages and scripts
that are required initialize and create
a new react.js application called music
app now once this application is created
all we would require is an online editor
so you could use an offline or an
on-premise editor as well so any editor
of your choice it could be atom or
sublime text or webstorm and
for this demo uh we're going to use
visual studio code which is
a free editor available by microsoft and
you can just google for visual studio
code again this is not visual studio
professional edition etc that we use for
building our c-sharp or mbc based
applications this is a lightweight
editor for building javascript based
footstep full applications so so while
this installs let's go and take a look
at uh visual studio code so this is the
visual studio code editor and this is
the editor that we've
installed directly downloaded from
visualstudiocode.com and installed it
and all we need to do is open up this
folder that would be created with all
the prerequisite files in it we just say
file open folder and we would open that
folder within our visual studio code
editor so we'll give it a while until
that application gets generated and once
it's created uh we will again implement
the component based design and
architecture
and the data flow between the components
and we also look at connecting to a live
data source which is a json set of
characters that we would consume which
is a restful service
the set of music tracks
exposed as a restful api endpoint by
spotify which is a premium streaming
service we will connect to that and we
will look at
accessing some of the music tracks on
that website okay so we've got uh the
application created here so let's
minimize this and
we'll open up our editor all we've got
to say is file and open folder and
let me go to the react.js demo folder so
this is the music app that got created
and that's exactly what we're going to
open up here so we'll navigate to
that folder it's called music app we'll
select it
and have it opened in our application so
you can see here we've got a note
modules folder this has all of the
pre-installed packages that make up the
react.js library we've got a folder
called public which will have the
index.html file that's the root file
that will launch so this is the single
page application that we typically
create
in react you have a single page which on
which we're going to load multiple
components so that's the index.html and
then we could go and create
a folder structure
currently if i open the source folder we
can see a single app.js file and that
basically is
the file that has uh the source code in
javascript for a single component which
we are interested in adding on to our
page as of now so we just have one
component which is the default root
component that's the app component and
it has its corresponding css file
and then we've got
the a public folder with the index.html
file which is going to be
the root html file that launches
when we run our application
so let's uh go right up here and let's
add
a link to an additional file so i'm
going to link to another style sheet
okay so we'd say relationship is equal
to stylesheet and the type is going to
be text
and css
and
we will reference a file called
reset
dot css and this is a file that we look
at
adding up later on it doesn't exist at
this point in time so we will connect
this and that's purely for styling
purposes
so that we can have
all of our css styles defined there next
thing i'll right click on the public
folder we'll create a new file we'll
name this file as reset dot css so
that's going to be the css file that
will have all of the css
styling that we're going to apply and
i'm going to use a ready code snippet uh
for the css code so let me just uh okay
so i'll all i'll do is uh i'll just go
and pick up
a ready css file that i can just go and
use
if you look here i have a set of
css files that are created that we're
just going to use
within our application and
and that will avoid us spending a lot of
time on the styling so that we can focus
on our core concepts uh which is
actually learning how component based
architecture works and how do we set up
components and have data communication
between them in react so uh here is a
file called
reset.css
let me just fire up
notepad and i'll just open up this file
copy up the text here and i'm going to
just paste it within
myreset.css and if you look at the code
uh very simple it's all about uh styling
so we've got uh article aside etc all
html5 tags set up as display block so
they take up the entire width of the
page we've got some padding margin and
font size etcetera defined we've removed
list styling for the unordered and
ordered list specifying the line height
for the body tag so basically uh just
styling up tables and so nothing nothing
to do with react here it's just about
simple uh css that we've added up uh and
now we need to actually go in and dive
into create creation of the components
that we need so let's right click on the
source folder so i'll select the source
folder we'll right click there and
that's where we're going to create a new
folder which is called components okay
so this is the components folder now
that's going to hold
all of the components within it within
the components folder let me create
another new folder and i'm going to call
it app and this is exactly how we are
expected to structure all of the code
that we have now i already have a css
and app.js which are the root components
that were added by default and all i'm
going to do is i'm going to move them
within this folder called app okay so
there's a proper segregation of
responsibility and
all of the code that
deals with a particular component is all
added into respective folders and this
really improves the maintainability of
the application uh going forward now we
need some images and i'm just going to
make use of some
set of images that i've downloaded from
the web and
here are the set of images that i have
so i'm just going to copy all of them
and we'll come to our music app and
we'll go into the components and app
folder and that's where we're going to
add all of the files and you've seen all
of those image files getting added so
these are just icons and images we're
going to use for our music tracks inside
our application now uh let's move to the
app.css file and
this is where we've actually got
so the app.css file is the file that's
going to style up
the
all of the style rules that we've added
into the root app component and
this is what we'll have to revamp so
i'll just get rid of this code and
we'll probably add something for the
body tag the html tag and the root
element let me say hash root and let's
set the height to 100
coming to all of the html across the
page we'll give it a font size of 10
pixels
and
the h1 elements
let me give it a padding of
0.77
and 0 let's set
a background color give it a background
color and just select
some random color here that can be
applied then we'll set up the text
alignment which is going to be the
center of the page we'll set up the font
family the font family is
and this is part of
sans serif what else do we add let's add
up the font size 1.8
and also the color so again
these are standard uh html and css
elements so
nothing really that
has to be done that is specific to
react here so again we are bringing in
the highlight class so there is a class
called highlight that we will create
later in the uh html view of this
component and we'll set this to a red
rgb component so combination of
113 and 238 okay so that's uh pretty
much done let's move on and also add up
for the anchor tag let's add up some
text decoration and set it to none so
that the anchor tags don't come up with
those underlines and of course we'll
provide a color of hash okay so a white
color there now coming to the h2 element
for the h2 element let's have font
family and again i'm going to use
so i'm going to use
the font family that we defined here
bracket and we change this to probably
1.55
okay now coming to the app tag uh let me
just save this and create a copy of it
uh there was some content that
i did delete and
i can simply go and make use of it so
i've just undone all of the deletion so
this is uh something that i can't uh if
i can use something i can just probably
use it from the tag below so let me
start with a height here and let's say
the height of the header is 100 of the
app sorry not header padding 0 17
the background and i'm going to change
that to background url so the background
url or let's say the background image
will have a url property okay and that
url is going to be dot slash
pg1.jpg so that's the image that we've
added some in the previous step let's
also add
background size so we'll add background
size and set it to cover i'll also need
a background position set it to center
let's have background repeat which is
set to
no repeat so that we don't have the
image
in a grid format uh and then
i would need this bit of it let's take
up the font family we'll maintain the
same font family let's use font weight
the font weight is going to be 500 and
the color is going to be hash
so that's a white color then we come to
dot app dot playlist so that's going to
be uh another class that we are going to
use dot but app dash playlist is what we
we're going to name it and let me say
that the display should be flex
flexible display and we will justify the
content to leave spaces
in between all right so that finishes
that bit and now
uh let's write up a media query for the
responsiveness of this page so this is
media for only screen and
max width is going to be one zero two
zero pixels okay and the class name that
we'll provide later is obviously app
playlist so for this screen size we
would align all the items
to the center and we change the flex
direction okay so we seem to be good
with uh the css for the app as of now
and that's the app.css
that we created let me save everything
okay let's check
for any kind of
additional so all three of errors no
errors now things are good in the app
css and it's time to move to the next
step of building this application uh now
we'll have to go and add up
the code for
the app.js file so let's dive into the
app.js file and this is where
we will actually need to go and add
all of the code that is required for the
app component so all the code that's
relevant to
the app component we are going to add up
inside this specific component itself
which is going to be obviously the
app.js file so we have skeletal code
which is import importing the react
library and
let me get rid of the basic sample logo
we'll have app.css that's getting
imported here
besides that a lot of other files that
we'll have to get in so uh let me import
playlist and this is these are the
components that we'll create uh as we go
forward and
we're going to get this from the
playlist folder
and the component the file is going to
be called playlist so we'll add that
then we'll have to go and also import
search bar so what we're basically doing
is we're going to split this app into
different components there's going to be
one component that manages uh the
playlist of all the tracks uh one
component will uh act as the search bar
so that's the search bar component that
we're going to add so searching for
tracks will be managed by this we'll
have another component that we'll create
that will get imported into the root app
component which is a search results so
this is going to display the record set
with the set of results as an outcome of
the search criteria so search results
slash
search results and finally we'll go and
import spotify that's the spotify
service from so we'll create a utility
folder which will hold
the code that connects us to spotify so
that's what we are adding up next so all
of the imports are done one component
that manages the search bar so that's
search bar search results let me correct
the spellings there that search results
that spotify and playlist so that's done
now let's move on to the class that
we're going to create here so let's
create a class app that goes and extends
react dot component so that's going to
be a react.js component so that's a
constructor we discussed about props or
properties and state management and
that's what we are implementing we are
using the super keyword as a best
practice so that all the properties are
initialized in the constructor and also
we pass the values up the chain to the
superclass which is the root component
class now we're going to initialize
a variable called state that's going to
manage the state and we are interested
in tracking our search results so we'll
have multiple results so we'll store
that as an array the playlist would have
different names so we'll just call ours
new playlist that's the default name and
we will also store a list of tracks
which is going to be playlist
tracks so playlist tracks is going to be
a list of tracks and let's close
this block okay and this two is going to
be initialized within the constructor so
we'll add it here and now we need to do
the binding we discussed uh data binding
so let's look at
creating a search variable which will
hold this dot
search dot bind and bind to the context
of this very class so we are passing
this pointer then we'll create
another variable called add track which
to this dot add track dot bind and all
this functionality is what we're going
to add going forward so right now we're
just setting up the bindings then we'll
have capability to remove a track so
we'll say remove track so remove track
equal to this dot remove track dot bind
and
let's fix that so and all of these two
is going to be initialized as part of
the constructor so that's where we're
going to add it then we need to update
update the playlist name so we need
functionality that will help us to
update the name of the playlist so
functionality that helps us to update
the playlist name so this dot update
playlist
name is equal to this dot
update playlist name dot bind and this
is the pointer that we'll pass i need to
save the playlist so this dot
save playlist
equal to this dot save playlist dot find
and pass this and then i would also need
to remove the track that has been
searched for from the playlist so remove
track search go to this dot
okay remove track search and
dot find and finally one last function
that executes
all of these which probably will bind to
bind to this context so all the
declarations are done in the constructor
now we need to provide the definitions
for all the methods that we actually
have added here so let me select this
tab inside and let's start with the
search function so we define the search
first it takes
some variable value that it searches on
and then i'm going to say spotify dot
search i'm going to search for term dot
then and that's an observable so the
moment it the search returns a value
it's going to call this
callback function and that's when we
want to set the state and we're going to
set the state for search results to
whatever is passed by the system so the
search results are going to be returned
as a callback and that's what we store
as an updated state now coming to the
add track method so let's scroll up and
we'll say add track and this will take
the track to be added let's declare a
temporary variable called tracks equal
to this dot the current state of all the
tracks that are there in the playlist
now if tracks dot find i'm going to call
the find method so if we are able to
find which means that the track is
already there in the playlist then we
would not want to add it if it's not
there in the playlist that's when we
would want to go and add it the triple
equal to is an equality operator that
will check for both a watch value match
and a match on the data type as well
okay so if the track is uh already saved
to nothing if the track is not safe just
track the track id because that is the
track that will uh have to be added if
it's not if it's already there then just
return if it's not there then we've got
to go to this variable called tracks
we'll use the javascript method called
push and we will push the current track
into this tracks array and then update
the state so we want to set the state of
the playlist tracks and this is how uh
your state management that we discussed
in detail is actually being practically
implemented here okay so the track has
been added now let's talk about the
remove track so that's the remove track
function and that's the track that we
want to remove so let's let tracks equal
to dot state dot playlist tracks those
the set of current tracks that we have
and
let track search another temporary
variable equal to this dot the current
state of the search results then let's
take the tracks array equal to track
start filter so filter is of javascript
function that will again allow you to
remove a certain value create a
temporary variable called current track
use the lambda operator and if the
current track dot id is
not equal to the track dot id which
means this particular track is not there
in the list
okay so you need to remove that and
again i have a method called as unshift
which will actually get rid of the track
in the array and then we've got to so
we'll search whether that
track is existing in the tracks array if
it is then we simply want to remove it
if not we do nothing so we set the state
we need to update the state of the
playlist because the track has been
removed so the playlist tracks will have
to be updated with this tracks array
okay then we go for remove track search
that's the next method that also will
take a track as a parameter okay here we
are going to say let tracks which is
another temporary variable we'll give it
this current state of
search results and then we're going to
say tracks equal to tracks dot filter
current track current track dot id not
be equal to the track dot id and then
this is where we would want to say this
dot set
state
and we'll pick up search results
and let's go and assign that to track so
that's the updated uh set of tracks
after making that change let's remove
this and correct it okay so that's fine
so the remove track
is now the remove track in the remove
track search is now in place let's add
the do these functions which actually
again takes track as a parameter and
here we'll say this dot add track okay
so it adds the track and then it
removes the track from the search
criteria so the search component which
is managing searching of the tracks it
will go and remove it from there after
adding the new track so that's a
combined
operation we want to execute then i've
got update playlist name which will take
the name of the track to update and this
dot set state the playlist
name is what we need to update with the
name that is passed to this function
then we've got to save playlists so here
let me create a constant variable
constants are variables whose values
will not frequently change we'll take
all the track uris dot state dot
playlist tracks
will be
dot map create a temporary variable
called track track dot url so we
actually want to go and
now save this on a spotify so that's the
reason we'll access
spotify's safe playlist method this dot
state dot playlist name comma track uris
and if that is successful we then go
into a callback so that's the callback
anonymous function where we're going to
say this dot
set date and the playlist
name that we want to create on spotify
will be called new playlist so that's
the custom name that i want to provide
and the playlist tracks
define that this closes here
okay so that's for the update on
spotify
now here is where
the render method is going to return the
html now this html is the view
and react simplifies this by having the
javascript and the html in the same
file so you can actually go and access
the variables you've declared in the
script directly in your html view
and synchronize and bind the data
together so it helps
from a maintainability perspective so
even though everything is in the same
file it's well classified and
differentiated into different code
blocks so we'll add the anchor tag and
we'd say href is http localhost so
that's the default server port on which
this application will run okay and we
want to give it a custom url name of
music or file so the h1 terminates will
then say div class name equal to app
within that this is how we're going to
inject a search bar that's going to be
the search bar component injected here
and on search so that's the custom event
we will call a method called search so
on search we just call we bind to a
method called this dot search then we'll
open up another div here we'll have
class name equal to app dash playlist
and if you remember that's exactly the
css
class name that we referred to in the
css file we have another component
called search results
that we're going to inject here
and
that's going to be search results here
search results will be equal to this dot
state dot search results so that's how
we can actually go and bind so that's
simple data binding the component is
going to be displayed with the data
bound and if somebody says add if if i
click on the add button for search
results
do these so it will add that new track
to the playlist by calling binding to
the duties function and it will remove
it from the search results text box then
we have another component called
playlist and here the playlist tracks
will be bound to this dot state dot
playlist tracks okay so on the top if
you look here we started with defining
all the function declarations in the
constructor then we provided the
function definitions okay that's how and
this that we passed refers to the
context of the current uh component
itself so whatever you put into the app
component or into the respective
component those values will be then
passed out here to these individual
functions okay so that's with the
playlist couple of things we'll have to
do is if somebody changes the name of
the track so on name change is going to
be another custom event where we'll have
to call this dot update playlist name
and we also have remove functionality so
to remove a track we would say equal to
this dot remove track on save equal to
this dot
save playlist okay so that's done and we
close this so we seem to be pretty much
on track the export
app will make this all of these
functions accessible across other
components it's very similar to the
public access specifiers etc that you
provide in other programming languages
so that's done we've created our app
component now let's create another
folder under components and we've got to
define all our various components here
this folder is going to be for the
search bar so we'll name it search bar
we'll add two files within it the search
bar dot css okay and another file that
we'll need here is search bar
dot js
so that's in terms of the search bar
let's start with the css file so we'll
start with first styling search bar we
will say that the display should be flex
flex
direction should be column we want all
the items to be aligned at the center so
that's align item center then we'll add
up padding so padding top
is going to be 6.94
rpm and
margin
bottom is going to be 6.33
rem all right now let's add up for the
search bar so that's search bar we'll
add
for the input element we want the width
to be 287 pixels the padding to be 0.88
zero the border should be one pixel
solid white the border radius
will give a slight rounded edge uh to
give a web 3.0 look and feel so we'll
set up the border radius then we've got
uh margin bottom so we've got a bottom
margin that we want to add up then we
have color so let's add up the color c3f
so that's the color black then let's add
text alignment of
center and let's add up a font size of
one rem okay so that's how we've set
this up let's add
the search bar input is going to be
so if someone focuses so focus is the
got focus so if someone clicks inside so
the end user goes and clicks inside the
text box so we change the outline to
none okay and
so for the search bar we are interested
on input and if the input is
focused so that's the event that we are
looking for and then we would have a
button called search button so on the
search button the cursor will set it to
pointer so that's the cursor pointer the
width we set it to 8.11
rem the padding we are going to set up
to
0.77 rem and 0 the border radius
we'll set it to 54 pixels so we get a
slightly uh well defined search button
with a nice little border let's also add
background color hash 1 db 954
that gives me a color then i've got
my text alignment let's set that to
center then we've got a font family
let's set up the font family to the same
standard font 80
and it's a part of the sans serif family
then we'll set up the font size
to 0.83
rem correct this
and finally
we will need
transition so all of these are basic
css properties so that will add a slight
transitional effect with a delay of
that many milliseconds
so transition background color we've
provided what else let me scroll up
let's also provide a border here so we
remove in fact let's remove the border
we we would not want a border on the
button that would look odd so i'll get
rid of the border and color we'll
specify as per our standard color that
we've been using okay so that's the
color we've specified and then i've got
font weight of 500. finally we'll take
the search button and on the search
button we will register for the hover
event so if someone takes their mouse
over the button that's the over the
event in that case uh if we hover around
the button we would want the background
color to change so it will appear to
have a slight little glow there a mouse
pointer moves over the button okay so
that's the opacity and
the rgb combination so that completes uh
the css file for the search bar and we
obviously now need to go and get the
code in for
our search bar component and that's
exactly what we are going to do next so
let's start with setting up the code for
the search file first thing let's go and
import react from
react
next thing we would want to do is import
the search bar dot
css file then we define a class
called search bar which extends
react dot component we define our
constructor and we go and
pass these parameters to the base class
we also define
the state we'll just need one variable
here which is
the term to search for in the search bar
and then let's say this dot
we'll define a function called handle
term change which is going to be equal
to this dot handle handle term change
dot
find so that's going to be the first
function then a function that will do
the searching for us
which is this dot search so that's the
search function and we'll have it bind
to this
then we've got this dot
handle enter so the moment we enter into
that search text box handle enter dot
find this
so the functions are ready now let's go
for the first one which is handle term
change
we'll pass it a system defined keyword
of event this dot set state and for the
term
we will use the event keyword we will
get the value that is there inside that
text box the moment the search term the
user has entered changes so the search
criteria changes we trap the updated
value then in the search function we
will update the local property props dot
on
search
okay so we'll access the on search and
pass it the updated term and then we got
the handle enter on which
uh we're also going to pass the system
define event keyword so if there's any
data flowing along with the event we are
interested in it in this case the data
is the key code that the user is
pressing and if it is 13 that indicates
that's the ascii key code for the enter
button so if the enter is hit then the
user is completed entering the search
criteria and we need to start searching
and that's where we write our render
method that's going to render the html
view and we return the complete view
here so that's the view now that we want
to return let's say diff class name
equal to search bar then on the input
text box we will use placeholder equal
to enter song album
or artist that you want to search for on
change
on the on change event the moment the
term changes we connect that to handle
term change we already have an
function that manages that and the
moment
keys are pressed and released so on key
up is where we would want to connect to
this dot handle enter okay and this is
place bracket that i have to put up here
so in the render function uh we're going
to return a value i shouldn't forget to
export the search bar okay so that's uh
what i want to export so we've exported
that okay so at the end of this
what we've done is we've written a
render method we've written our div tag
here is where we'll go and close
the div tag we've added an input and
here is where i'm going to add a button
provide a class name called search
button and the moment the end user
clicks on the button we're going to
connect it to this dot
search and we close
the button back within the button tag
search so that
completes the
render function so in the render
function again let's run through all of
what we've written we started with
extending react.component we then added
a constructor passing props to the super
class constructor we created
state we set it to a value of
term and null so the state currently we
defined as term then we said handle term
changes search and handle enter should
be functions
that we want to add then handle term
changes
we defined search we defined and handle
enter we've also defined then we used
render render we said is going to return
to us
the html that we've specified okay we
dumped all the html that we want this
component to return to us
so on change and on key up are
two functions that
or two events that we connected to where
we called handle term change and handle
enter then we added a button where we
registered for the click event and
connected it to this dot search so all
the three functions uh that we
are actually written uh so two things we
have completed now uh in the app class
okay if you look at the app class we've
actually defined a set of functions here
that deal with uh the playlist and
adding applications etc adding tracks
removing tracks
then we've created
the search bar okay so we saw that the
search bar also we have specified a set
of functions
and all the functions that we defined we
have taken care to structure every
component separately so the search
component is doing something completely
different which is managing the search
bar we have the core the root app
component in which we have imported all
of the other set of javascript classes
uh that we are creating and that's how
the entire application is now structured
so and that's the core
concept when you're working with react
where you would actually have every
separate
block of
code or every separate functionality
handled in a different component
altogether so we've completed the search
bar component as well so two components
done and two components good to go so
we've got to start up on the next set of
components that we will need to build
and the next component is the track
component that will manage individual
tracks so a new folder a new file called
track.css
and
track.js so that's going to manage
the tracks for us so let's start with
dot track we would say display is flex
align items
center border bottom one pixel solid
rgba
to 56 0.8 that's the opacity then let's
come to track action so we'll use all of
these classes uh when we write up the
html view we'll add a padding here of
0.5 we'll set up a font size
of 1.05
set up a transition color of 0.20
s
border of 0 pixel and
a background color of rgb a
0 0 0 0 color ash so that's the color
that we continue to use then we bring in
track another class track action and if
we hover over this class we want
the gb values
change to 265 265
265 5 is the last parameter so that's
the hover
then we have track information so track
information is the next class that we're
dealing with we'll add the flex
parameter first display flex
and
then flex
direction
is going to be column let's have justify
content set up as
center and let's have height as
180 pixel so that's a track information
let's have another track information and
the h3 tags nested inside that for all
the h3 tags nested inside that we'll
need a margin bottom of 0.22
rem finally let's have track information
and paragraph tag we'll have the font
size
of
0.83 rem and a font weight of 300 and a
color as well that we'll add so let's
add up a color here rgba 2 6 256
256 and 0.8 okay so that's uh that's in
terms of the css and let's move to the
track and we'll move into the javascript
file so let's move into so let me take
what we added in the search bar i'll go
to the track.js
this will change to track dot css
okay the constructor this will change to
add track so add track change this to
add track this is
remove track change this to remove track
get rid of this and that's going to be
the add track function and here we're
going to say uh this dot props
so we'll modify this this dot
props
dot on add this dot props dot track and
then we have the remove track so that's
going to be the remove track function
this function is not required so this
dot prop start on
remove
and this is the track that we would want
to go and remove we'll add up another
function called
render action so this is going to be a
function uh that we are defining called
render action and in this we'll just
check if this dot props dot is
remove if this dot props dot is
removable so in that case
we would want to return so this is a
view action method that we are adding
which is going to go and add this button
with a class called as track action that
we've already written the css for and
this button will actually get added
via this render action function and this
dot
remove track is
what it's going to map to let's close
this
this is going to point to this specific
function so that's uh the closing button
tag okay so the closing button tag is
what
we've added there and the binding is
what we have done to this dot
remove track and we will terminate this
here so now the render action uh let's
also have the return here and we just
add up the button and this is going to
add track so you can look at how the
component is completely dynamic uh in
nature so we have two buttons that are
going to be added this button with the
hyphen is going to remove the track this
button uh with the plus sign is going to
add the track and uh you can actually
see how simply it was done in a render
action function so the render action
function actually helped
with uh checking that if
on the value of the props and if the
user
depending on
the action performed you will actually
be able to remove a track or add a track
from the existing playlist okay and then
the class name here is now going to be
track the class name for
uh the enclosing div inside it so let me
get rid of this the class name for the
enclosing div here
is going to be
track dash
information within it we'll add h3 we'll
bind to this dot props dot track dot
name so the name of the track is going
to get bound here then in the paragraph
we will find to this dot props
dot track dot artist
and
with some gap this dot props dot track
dot argo so that's what
we've data bound to
and then let me add an iframe an iframe
allows us to
very easily inject some content into the
page within a small embedded window the
source parameter of the frame is going
to be https
open dot so here i'm connecting to the
spotify stream
spotify.com slash embed slash track and
close this so that's the spotify stream
that we're going to connect to and this
dot props dot track dot id so that's the
track id the width is going to be 300
the height parameter this the height
parameter is going to be 80 of the
iframe and
the frame order is going to be 0
and the allow
transparency so that's the opacity we'll
say true let's add allow
encrypted media so if spotify has
encrypted media that also would be
embedded here and we can also have the
title set to preview so that's uh with
the iframe okay at the bottom is where
we would want to so this could be an
empty element and we can close it
right around here so we wouldn't need
this part and then here i'm just going
to say this dot
render action so we call the render
action method
which will actually give us plus minus
button to add and remove a
new element okay and that's uh what we
can actually go and add up there so
let's check now whether
all that we've done is good to go fine
so everything looks good uh in terms of
the track component now and
we have all of the functions in place
it's now time to jump into the
next component that we would require
after the track component and
that's going to be the track list so
this is going to be a list component
that will comprise of a list of tracks
inside it so we'll create a new folder
call this track list
and that's going to have
track list css
and it's going to have track list dot js
so that's the track list
component now which we're going to go
ahead and use
and the css we don't need much so let's
just say track list
and we just provide a width of 100
okay that's all we need uh in the css so
let me add this in the css file save
this
and come to the js file now which is
going to have
the track list code that we will need to
add up so here again i'm going to say
import react
from react we'd also want to import
track list dot css
and
we
also want to go and get track because
this component is going to be made up of
a collection of tracks
individual tracks so we want to get this
from track slash track and we'll define
class track list which is going to go
and extend
react dot
component
we just need the render method here
because this just needs to go it does
not really have any state of itself it
simply goes and returns a list of
individual tracks
so this class name is going to be
track list
and we'll find to this dot props dot
tracks dot map create a temporary
variable
and this will go and return
the track component
which is going to bind to individual
track data the key is going to be track
dot id so the key is going to be track
dot id
and on add on adding a new track we want
to bind to this dot properties dot and
we already have on ad defined so that's
what we'll connect to add up my
base bracket here okay and
then we would also need
is
removal
equal to
this dot props dot is
removal and the on remove will do this
dot prop start on remove so that's for
the track removal and
so we've got our track list
uh oh yes we'll have to go and
also close the tip tag correctly and
also we need to go and export so we'll
have to go and export
the track
list
so we've got one more component done
which is track list and let's move on to
the next component now so we've got app
which is root we've got the search bar
that takes care of entering the search
criteria we've got individual tracks
that are searched and returned and we've
got a track list that manages a set of
track records so the track is more
relevant to the playlist and then we've
got the search results also to manage
once we search for some
set of tracks so we'll add a new folder
which manages search results
and this is going to have
search results dot
css and it's going to have
search results dot js
okay so we need a search results dot css
and js and here in the css file we'll
keep it simple for the search
results so we'll say search results
we'll set up the width of 50 percent we
set up the height of 950
pixels
we'll say
overflow y is
scroll we'll say padding is 0.88
rem background color will be rgba
23 23 0.7
and we will use the box model so we'll
provide a shadow dropping shadow of zero
four pixels to pixels to pixels hash
and then uh
let's add
a scroll bar so
webkit
and mozart are the constants specific to
mozilla and chrome browsers
so they target certain animated features
etc or properties
that are specific to those individual
browsers that's the reason we use those
constants
and then we'll also add a media query
that if it goes with a max
with 1020 pixels
in that case dot search
results
width is 90 percent
with a margin bottom of two
okay so
we're going to add the hyphen so it's
hyphen webkit scroll bar zero pixel
width
and we've set
transparent background so that's that's
about it with uh the css i need to get
to the uh js file now let's move to the
search results uh js file
and that's where we will now have to go
and add up
the component code for search results
and let me take
pick this up from track list add it up
here this would be
search results and
we need the results will return to us a
list of tracks so we'll have to get uh
track list this would be track list
and i'm just going to return class name
will also be
search results so that's the component
and this is going to export out search
results so it's accessible across
other components then we've got h2 with
results
let's go and create
track list with a set of tracks and we
will bind it to this dot props dot
search results and on the on add we are
going to bind to this dot props dot on
add so we already have that so that uh
basically completes
search results and
that leaves us with the last component
which is going to manage the playlist
for us so we'll add up a new books we'll
add up a new folder in components
and that's going to be playlist
and within that we will have a playlist
dot css
and
a playlist dot js
so that's our
playlist component now that
we're going to work with and the
playlist component is
uh we'll first set up
the css that we will need
to add up to the playlist and i'm just
going to
pick that up from my code snippet so
that's my playlist and let me get all of
that css here so that's uh just a css
for the playlist nothing to do with
react again pure css uh let me get uh
into the js file and that's where we
will need to go and add all of our
component code so again let me go to the
track.js
the track list rather let me get this
and add it out here we'll make some
small changes this is going to be
playlist
i need to import the track list
because the playlist is going to contain
a list of tracks
this is going to be
playlist and
let me
here this will be playlist and we'll
leave this
for later okay let me also get
the constructor in so we'll add up the
constructor here and just one
function that we will need here which is
handle name change you know if i need to
change the name of the playlist
so handle name change and that's exactly
the function that we will need to write
code for so that's the event
and this dot props
dot on name change
that's when we'll say event dot
target dot value so we get the updated
playlist name coming to the render we
now need the input
input
is going to be on change equal to this
dot
handle name change
the default
value we have already provided with a
hard coded value which is new playlist
so that's the default value if
not provided then we'll just pick up the
default value then we've got uh track
list so track list is what i will add
the tracks i'm going to bind to this dot
props dot playlist
tracks
so we're going to bind this to playlist
and here we will say
is
removal equal to
true and on remove
equal to we'll bind that to this dot
props
dot on remove
finally we'll need a button we will use
class name equal to playlist dash
save that's what we've added in the css
click equal to this dot props
dot on save and here we're going to say
save to
spotify so that's with the
playlist and yes we need to go and
export playlist and not track list
now we'll need to uh do a quick look up
in spotify so let's go to this website
called developer.spotify.com
and once once we sign in
and create an id it takes us to our
dashboard
that's where we can create a sample
application the name of the application
will be musical file okay and
we'll say that we are building uh
some kind of desktop app for example for
which we want to uh connect this to and
we'll also need to provide so we'll say
next
refresh the dashboard so it's
asking me for a login so let me login
once more so moment i login that's going
to be description and i'll say maybe
this is why i need it i'll say no not
commercial integration agree with the
terms and conditions and we will say
submit
and that's the application that has got
created and now i can say edit settings
and
the redirect url here is what is
important
so it should accept connections from
http localhost 3000 that's the port on
which we will host our application okay
and we'll say save okay so that's uh
now there's a client id that is
generated here for my app which is
unique so i'll just copy that up let me
come up to my application under the
source folder i'm going to add a new
folder called util and under that a new
file called spotify.js
so we will start with
adding our code to the spotify.js file
that we've just created as a new file
within the newly created util folder the
first line of code is going to define a
client id variable that equates to the
client id that we will generate on
spotify so this is going to be the
spotify generated client id which is a
unique id associated for the developer
to connect to the spotify api and we
will look at uh the source of that as we
go through the demo the next variable
that we'll create is the redirect url or
let's call it redirect uri and that will
equate to localhost colon3000 which is
the port and we'll create another
variable called the access token let's
also create another constant variable
called spotify and this will work like a
function expression so we'll equate it
to a function called get access token
and we will say if access token is true
then return the access token now let's
declare a constant variable called
access token match which will be equal
to window dot location dot
href dot match and we will say this is
equal to access token which will be
equal to and we will give a reject
expression to do a pattern match
ampersand so that we can actually get
into the url and extract
the token information from that and
hence
the pattern match is crucial here
another constant
variable called expires in match
equal to window dot location dot href
dot match here we will read the expiry
information using another edge x
expression from the url ampersand
asterisk so that's the second constant
variable we've created now we will say
if access token match and
expires in match in that case the access
token should be equal to access token
match of one then we create a variable
called
expires in equal to we'll do a typecast
to number and we will take the first
parameter from the expires in match
that's done then we will say
window.settimeout
and we're going to say access token
equal to comma
expires in multiplied by thousand then
we will say window dot history dot push
state and we will say access token we
pass the second parameter as null the
last parameter as slash and close this
and we will return access token else
we will say const access
url equal to https
accounts.spotify.com
slash
authorize
client underscore id equal to dollar
client id ampersand response type equal
to token ampersand scope equal to
playlist dash
modify so we are actually building the
url that will now get generated so we'll
say modify dash public and redirect
url equal to dollar redirect uri so we
have constructed the url now that will
go out and get generated in the browser
and here we are going to say window dot
location equal to access url then we'll
add the search criteria function which
accepts a term as a parameter to search
on here we will say constant access
token equal to spotify dot get access
token so we get a reference to the same
access token return we call the fetch
function and we're going to pass
https
api dot
spotify.com slash
v1 slash
search question mark that's the query
string that we will add type equal to
track and ampersand g equal to dollar
and we will pass term comma as the
header information we will need to pass
the authorization where we will say that
the bearer is dollar access token dot
then response
return response dot json dot then so the
return of this function once it
completes we will then call the next
function so json response
and then we will say
return response dot json after that
another then block so we'll now say json
response and if
not
jsonresponse.tracks
in that case we will return
an empty array else
we will return
jsonresponse dot tracks dot items dot
and we will pass
we'll create track as
a variable with a lambda expression and
we'll create a temporary json object
with id and that's where we want to
associate track dot id that was returned
as the search result the name is going
to be associated with track dot name the
artist is going to be associated with
track dot artist of zero dot name the
album is going to be track dot album dot
name and the uri we will equate track
dot url so that completes uh this block
will open the next and we this will be
the save playlist which will take the
name and the track uris and here we will
check if not
name or not track uris dot len in that
case we simply return out of the code
and then we declare a constant variable
called access token which will be equal
to spotify dot get access token so we
get a reference to the access token we
then declare headers authorization
bearer is going to be dollar access
token and we create a user id and now we
will return the fetch result where we
will pass https
api dot spotify dot com slash v1 slash
me so that's the url comma headers will
be the header information then we call
the then function declare response as a
variable use the lambda expression and
access response dot json we use the then
block to declare json response
here we say user id equal to json
response dot id and then we return fetch
https
api dot spotify
slash v1
slash users slash dollar of user id
slash
playlist so this is how we've
constructed the urls manually here we
will say assign headers to the headers
variable we'll assign method as post so
the data is sent as part of the body and
not as part of the url and as the body
we will say json.stringify
to convert this parameter name and then
we will generate a response variable to
response.json
and then we'll create json response with
the lambda operation we'll create a
constant playlist id which is equal to
json response dot id we will return
fetch
https
api.spotify.com
v1 users
dollar user id slash playlist slash
dollar again we are constructing the url
so playlist id will be replaced here
then we will say tracks
and close this comma and here again we
will say headers would equate to the
headers variable be constant headers and
this
close here okay everything fixed now so
here we're going to say headers should
equate to headers and
the method is going to be post and the
body is going to be json dot stringify
uris
track uris and we close this we close
this block we close this block and we
close this block so that completes our
code of course one more thing we have to
do which is export this class out so
export
default spotify and that completes the
code for
the spotify.js
which is part of our utils class so
let's move on now to the next step so
uh here is uh the client id that we'll
have to exactly match so i'll copy this
client id and provide it here so that's
the client id uh that we actually need
and we could also store it
out here
so that's the uh client id and that's
the redirect url that we've also defined
there and we just create an access token
if your access token is true we return
access token so the access token is
something that we are going to do a
match from uh
the moment we try and connect with this
particular url and you can look here
that this is the access url that we are
trying to connect with okay with the
client id and post fixed with the
redirect url right and then i've got a
simple search function which returns an
observable so we try to fetch data using
the search term that we provided okay we
try to fetch data using the search term
provided if we are successful we get a
response of the data and accordingly
we'll iterate over the json response and
get a list of tracks out of it and do a
mapping of this json object to the track
id name artist information album name
etc and here
just like a data access layer very
similar to a data access layer we've got
a save function which will save this
data to spotify as well so i've got a
save playlist and i've got search so
these are the two functions which will
go and connect to the spotify service uh
by using this client id
and it will allow me to
access that information in terms of
returning a stream of json data and will
then allow me to
go ahead and push that json data into
our application so now we
actually need to start up the
application so i'll go to the terminal
and rather let me go to view and bring
out the terminal so this is the
integrated terminal that's there in the
tool and it just opens powershell from
which you can actually fire your
commands so i'm going to say node
package manager npm start to actually
start up this application so that's
going to do a full compile and
so we will fire this up give access so i
need to grant access
to that port 3000 let's give it time to
run and that's the app now that
you can actually see here so this is uh
the search bar that we actually had okay
then we had the results we had the
playlist now the results is going to
consist of
a set of tracks which are maintained by
the track list and then you can take
individual tracks with the plus and
minus button and add them into the
playlist okay so that's how
it's typically going to work okay so as
you can view here i'm just going to
search for an artist
and we'll click on the search button it
goes to spotify tries to connect there
and says
that i need to agree to the terms and
conditions and i've just agreed to that
so the very fact that it actually uh
gave us uh a confirmation link the
moment we tried to connect and execute
our application uh that's proof enough
that it actually went and connected to
the
service there and tried to return a
value to us so this is what we did we
just added an artist we said search
and you can see now it's successfully
connected i've got a list of tracks
available from this artist and you can
see the plus buttons getting added on
the fly so that was the render action
these are
buttons that got added onto this list of
tracks dynamically the moment the search
results returned a value
so i can click on this plus sign and you
can see that the track gets added to the
playlist okay as in when i click here so
i've added a couple of tracks
if i go back to my dashboard of my
musical file application and that i've
created here in the developers portal of
spotify on
developers.spotify.com it's blank so now
i'm going to click on save to spotify
okay and that clears the playlist
so let me come here
and
now when i come out here we saw that it
actually got
successfully connected out here now i'll
have to log in to so this was the
development app that we actually created
on the developers portal of spotify now
we will go to spotify.com
so i'll just go to the spotify website
and it says do you want to launch the
web player and all that so let me click
on that so it just launches
and can you see here this is the new
playlist that just got added right and
there were four songs that i'd actually
added to the playlist and you can see
here those four songs have got added out
here okay so i can go here and
i can delete this playlist and say i
want to delete it okay so there's no
playlist now i'll go back here
i'll add two tracks and i'll say save to
spotify so that's how you actually saw
that the new playlist you can see the
new playlist has come back here okay and
that's the playlist the playlist has got
generated again and that's the new
playlist that
got created and we deleted it but it
still got created again and that
indicates the connectivity
that we successfully created with this
react app and the core concept of the
react app was breaking it down into
components which is the search component
then we created the track component we
created the track list to maintain a
list of tracks
then we created the search results which
will generate a list of results which
further contains a track list and this
is the embedded iframe which gave us the
response which is scrollable here and
you can see that the iframes we created
allowed us to scroll this
with this embedded web page inside the
iframe container so with that
i hope we've been successful with
explaining the concept of component
based design and architecture with react
and how important it is to create
individual components and the benefit of
that being that you can isolate change
requests to a certain component you can
promote reusability wherever you want
the same feature to be implemented on
the page you can just inject that same
component and the same implementation
and the same features can be reused so
it promotes reusability it promotes
flexibility to change it isolates your
change request to single components
preventing the massive effort of
recompiling and retesting the entire
application as a whole
in this session we'll be comparing the
three cutting edge ui development
technologies that is react.js angular
and vue we learn about the key
differences that make them so distinct
all of these technology stacks have been
replacing pure server-side technologies
and we've slowly progressed from
server-side applications to more
distributed applications where a part of
the job is done on the client side and a
part on the server side and now we've
transitioned to something known as
single page applications or sba and all
of these technologies that you see on
your screen right now are based purely
on javascript as a result they're
lightweight and aren't dependent on any
third-party runtime tools so let's
compare the three technologies and learn
about the factors that make them stand
out first we'll look into the salient
features now react is a front-end
javascript library while angular and
view are javascript frameworks now
although the terms library and
frameworks are used interchangeably
they're significantly different now
library is a set of classes or functions
and the user is in complete control to
call them frameworks on the other hand
are like models they have limited
choices and come with a blueprint of
their own and as a result the user
doesn't have much control so javascript
being an interpreted language where code
is executed line by line makes all these
tools very efficient mainly because
converting the code into an intermediate
code would require a runtime environment
and would definitely encounter a delay
now these are avoided and as a result
these tools are fast moving on react is
used to develop mobile and web
applications and angular is used for
single page applications and you can
also develop hybrid applications using
the stack mainly because it's purely
based on css html javascript and jquery
single page applications as the name
suggests are built using single page now
the entire page is broken down into
several components wherein each
component performs a specific task say
for example one component handles the
login the other one would display icons
and images and so on all these bits or
components are then put together to form
a single page application and moving on
react was developed and maintained by
facebook while angular was built by
google and view was developed by evan
unx google employee now react represents
the view part of the mvc framework and
angular is a full-fledged mvc framework
in itself and view on the other hand is
focused on view and the model layer of
the mvc framework now what exactly is
the mvc framework now mvc framework is
an object-oriented design principle that
mandates the separation of control
meaning one thing can only do one thing
so the model deals with the entity
classes the data and the business logic
while vue deals with the representation
and the ui logic of the application and
the controller drives the functionality
of the two any changes can be easily
factored and isolated and as a result
testing becomes a whole lot easier
moving on now let's look at the use
cases from the business perspective in
terms of react we have top websites like
facebook instagram netflix that use
react on the other hand we have angular
that is used by nike hbo forbes sony and
vue is commonly used by alibaba.com
grammarly 9gag and adobe moving on we
have performance now performance is a
very crucial feature now the moment you
build an html view and render it into
the browser this view to the user is
basically just html tags however if you
look at the internal working the code is
actually converted into a balanced tree
structure this b3 algorithm is extremely
fast so when the user makes any changes
to the ui the changes are reflected
immediately this is facilitated by the
b3 algorithm so as a result the
performance is improved so how does
react make use of this tool it uses a
virtual dom dom is an api developed by
w3c it stands for document object model
and defines how the document is accessed
and manipulated this dom parser converts
the html code into an inverse balance
tree structure so react uses the virtual
dom while angular uses the real dom and
vue uses the virtual dom again now the
virtual dom looks at the differences
between the current and the previous
html pages and only changes the parts
that need to be updated angular on the
other hand updates the entire tree
structure regardless of any changes made
or not and view again only updates the
ones that have changed since there is no
time spent on making unnecessary changes
to the entire tree react is extremely
fast on the other hand real dorm
updation is time consuming risky and
error-prone vue also ensures faster and
bug-free performance now let's talk
about data binding the core reason why
we would use single page applications
now consider a scenario where you log
into an ecommerce website as the user
one then you should be able to see the
items in your shopping cart while user
two would be seeing different items in
their shopping carts and so on so
identifying the user and retrieving data
corresponding to that specific user is
facilitated using the help of data
binding data binding is a process that
allows an internet user to manipulate
web page elements using a web browser
now it is used in interactive components
such as calculators tutorials games etc
now react supports one-way data binding
meaning you can take the data from the
view and push it to the model or vice
versa angular on the other hand uses a
two-way data binding while vue also uses
a similar two-way data binding in react
every time the model state updates the
view changes accordingly however the
reverse is not true in case of angular
any changes made to the view are
immediately reflected in the model part
of the architecture view follows the
same principle now this hugely
influences the performance due to
one-way data binding react is modular
and fast improving the performance
angular's two-way data binding adversely
affects the performance and view on the
other hand performs according to the
input type moving on to scripting
languages react combines ui templates
and javascript logic resulting in a new
language called jsx so react only
requires the knowledge of javascript
angular uses templates again in html you
can also inject javascript code into
html using a clever implementation in
angular called directives so you can
create a class and then inject it into
html angular also does something better
you can also write code for an angular
application using a newer language
developed by microsoft called typescript
it is a compiled language and is very
similar to java and c-sharp in terms of
syntax now vue again uses html based
template it uses html5 throughout for
the ui and the combination of javascript
for business logic all view templates
are valid html and can be passed by html
parsers let's move on to testing now
just is a framework or an api that is
developed by facebook and is used to run
tests on react applications to ensure
that they are bug free now it is
embedded typically in every react
library and requires zero configuration
now angular on the other hand uses the
jasmine framework now this framework
allows various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases this also
ensures that the application is error
free the view cli or the command line
interpreter has built-in options for
unit testing with the help of jest or
mocha now view typically has single file
components and hence these components
can be tested in isolation this makes it
modular and extremely fast now let's
talk about community support since all
these tools are open source they have a
large developer community there are a
few popular github repositories for
react such as react.js101 react.js.org
and so on you can raise queries solve a
few and connect with the larger
community that's working on react here
are a few repositories for angular view
also has a few popular repositories you
can commit download third party plugins
and also explore these stacks even
deeper all of them surely have a very
happening community at the time of
writing there were about 1 million
repositories 5 million comments and 1
million issues with respect to react
here are the figures for angular and
here are the figures for view according
to npm stat over the past two years
there have been approximately 360
million react.js downloads there have
been around 38 million downloads for
angular and around 63 million downloads
for view now let's look at the future
scope learning a new technology always
comes with questions like what's in it
for me what's its growth potential how
far will it take me in my career and so
on so let's go ahead and see the growth
rate of react angular and vue according
to google trends over the past 12 months
react has been on a way faster upward
trajectory than angular and vue which
have considerably lost their momentum
now this indicates that react is growing
faster than the other two with respect
to popularity industry adoption and
community support in this session we are
actually going to look at
how do we connect react.js with node.js
so a very warm welcome to this session
on react.js connectivity with node.js
and in this session we are going to
focus on how do we connect our react.js
application with the node.js platform so
we are going to dive into creating a
hands-on demo which will have two parts
to it we would have the client
application that we will first create as
a react application we will then create
an express gs application with node.js
and we will then try to connect both of
those applications together so
express.js is a rapid application
development framework that allows us to
create a web application very quickly on
the node.js platform and we'll use it to
create a custom api and then connect
that endpoint to the react.js client
application so let's dive into our demo
and
let's start with creating our client and
node express applications and see how to
set them up and then get them connected
to each other let's start with our
hands-on demo and we will first go to
the node.js website nodejs.org we can
download the lts version which is a
stable version of node.js moment i click
on this it will prompt me for a download
it will download the msi file and then
all i need to do is double click on it
keep clicking on the next button and
install that would install node.js for
us next we'll open our editor you can
use any editor of your choice so i'm
going to use
an editor called
visual studio code and let's open up the
terminal here and i also have the
command prompt open where i've navigated
to a folder that i've created called
react.js demos now we'll invoke the npm
package manager which is invoked by the
command npx so npx will not only install
packages but also execute them once they
are installed so once they are
downloaded it will execute the package
and
we will use npx to go and create a react
application called client so while we
give it time for the installation to
complete we can then open it
within our editor so we'll give it time
so that the installation completes
so the installation is completed and so
we've seen here that the installation is
now completed and let's uh go and open
up this project so i will say file and
open folder and
let me pick up that folder and we will
open this application called client so
that's my client app let's fire up the
terminal so
okay so that has launched the terminal
for us
and here
all we need to do to fire up this
application and get it running is npm
start which will compile and start up
this application that is created let's
close this we'll go to the browser and
now let's say localhost 3000 so that
gives us a startup page the sample
default startup page for the first
client application uh and this is going
to work as a client we'll now go and try
to create uh the backend uh application
which is going to be another application
that we will set up and to create that
let's say npx
express
generator api okay so this will uh
create an express application on node.js
called api and let's give it some time
for installation okay so that's done
clear this screen we'll come out here
we'll open another instance of the
editor we'd say open folder and that's
the api application we'll say select
folder and the api application is opened
let's go to the terminal now in the
terminal we will attempt to install all
of the packages that are required that
would be logged in the package.json file
so the package.json file here would be
listed uh so you can see we have a list
of packages that it uses and npm install
will go and install all of these
packages that were pre-listed here so
let me ensure it's executed correctly
and we'll fire that once more that's
done so npm install has installed all of
the packages required and let me
terminate this run by pressing a control
c so this terminates
the client application that was
executing and now we will say npm start
so that this application executes and
let's refresh
so that's the standard express
application now that has got installed
now let's go to the api application
we'll go into the bin folder and here
we'll have a file called www we will
change the default port number from 3000
to 9000 let me stop this application
from executing we've just updated the
port number now let's go to the routes
and we'll create a new file in the
routes folder called test api dot js
here we will say variable express
equal to require express
and here we'll say variable router equal
to express dot
router and here we will say
router dot get will open this
so that's the default route root route
is going to be slash for which we'll add
a callback function which will take the
request and the response parameter and
next pointer in case there is another
function to call post that and here we
will just send a simple message saying
api is working okay a simple message
sent out for the root default route and
we'll have to export this so we'll say
module dot exports equal to router all
right so that's uh done let's go to the
app.js file and here let us import that
so here is where we will import this by
saying app.use we want to use the test
api file and that is
test api router and this is exactly the
same variable name that we will declare
here which will be equal to require and
we are going to say routes
test api all right so let's try
launching this now we would say npm
start after adding this code let's go
out here
and 3000 test api is going to be the url
to hit it's not 3000 but 9000 now
because we just updated the port so 9000
test api and there we have a message
which says that the api is working
properly so this is tested now let's go
to the client application in the client
application let's go to the app.js file
okay this is the file that
we would have to revamp a bit so let's
uh revamp this here we will declare a
class app which extends so that creates
a new module so it extends
react.component
and here we have constructor we will
accept the props
here i would pass props to the super
class constructor and
set the state to api response
currently it just has an empty value
next we'll add up a new function called
call api which will generate a call to
that
api url which was http localhost 9000
was the port and test api
was the url once this is called we will
then call the then function declare
response generate a call to response.txt
and then we will again say this dot set
state
api response
is going to be equal to the response
that comes in from that url which is
nothing but a string which says api is
working another function called
component will mount so the moment the
component is initialized on the screen
and loaded we will generate a call to
this function we created called call api
then comes
the render function in the render
function we would go and return a div
class name is app this would be app
header the standard logo after which
in the paragraph we wouldn't need the
link here right after the header we'll
add a paragraph where we will print this
dot state and the variable we created
called api response and we will data
bind to that so that largely completes
the return so we simply create this
application uh that's the react
application that will talk to this api
that is and this uh url that is hosted
on node communicate with it get a simple
string as a response print that string
inside this
react application so once that's done uh
we have the component wheel mount which
is a life cycle method here it's a life
cycle event that gets triggered the
moment the component loads and that's
when uh we have actually gone and
executed the call api custom function
let's go to the api application we'll
terminate the execution here there's one
more step uh that we'll have to perform
which is cross origin
resource sharing which means that to
allow the react application to
communicate from another hosted domain
to this particular domain server we will
actually have to enable cross origin
scripting and sharing otherwise it will
block the request coming from another
application so for that we'll have to
install globally cross origin module and
dash dash save indicates that it's going
to do a global install for all
applications
that are on this particular system so
we've installed this
and we'll clear the screen let's go to
the app.js
and right here is where we would want it
to go and use cards so we will say
app.use course so that it uses this
particular api and here is where we will
declare the cause variable and go and
import the new library package that we
just installed which is quartz so looks
good and now let's
fire up this application with an npm
start let's also fire up client with an
npm start and now when i go and
try looking for localhost 3000 which is
the react application the react
application
should go and talk to the api that is
hosted on node.js which returns to me
that string message so if i go and ping
that api separately which is localhost
9000 test api you can see this is a
standard message so here i've directly
ping the api that's hosted in node.js
now we are consuming it through the
react.js application and if you scroll
down you can see the message returned
from node.js into react saying the api
is working properly so the practical
impact of this is to actually host
restful services etc on node as a server
and you can go and consume the data that
is written there could be in string text
or json format directly into the
react.js acting as a client application
hello this is matthew with simply learn
and today we're going to cover react
with redux
so why would you use redux well the
reason why you want to use redux is that
redux actually understands and helps
manage the state of an object
and redux was introduced to help address
some problems that you're having with
react so the state for an object stores
values and properties that belong to
components that could potentially change
over time so
the state could be modified by actions
in your network uh there could be
changes to the re-render of the
component in the browser and the object
could also then potentially store
multiple properties
and then with redux it actually takes in
and actually will create a uh you know
take a
large application that you could create
with app with a react and breaks it down
to several components instead of having
this massive number of states you have
to manage and so every time that you you
know an application will then switch
from a current with a react you'd
actually be then changing the states and
this is a a really big problem because
when you're like doing that switching
back and forth there is the potential
for applications to be re-rendered which
reduces the efficiency of your
application and so this is why redux was
introduced
so you know what is redux so redux is a
way to be able to have a predictable
state container for your javascript
applications and allow you to run your
applications in multiple different
environments so whether it's a client
solution a service solution or a native
app solution and then more importantly
um or one of the key
elements that i like about redux is that
it's really easy to test and so with
redux you're able to match the state of
your tool
you can actually use it to work with any
javascript framework or library
and you can actually then store the um
the application and the components in a
state store which makes it easy to be
able to manage the state of your
application so in simple words redux
stores all the state objects in a single
store and organizes it it provides
information about the current state of
the application any changes in the state
the application can be described to the
store by the user and then it notifies
any modifications made to the state of
that application so let's jump into the
key principles of redux and there's
three key areas i want to focus in so
the first one is that redux provides a
single source of truth
um and that source of truth is uh being
able to store the state of your whole
application in an object tree in a
single store and this makes it easier
for you to debug and inspect
components of your application uh also
enables you to be able to persist your
app state for development and improve
fastest development cycles the second
principle is that state is read only and
that's why you're able to
describe more effectively what's
happening because it is read-only and
this ensures that no events like network
callbacks uh would uh uh create and any
issues with the code and the
re-rendering of your application
and that object actions are become then
just plain objects and then finally
changes are made with pure functions and
so what do we mean by this
so we can actually
take actions and transform the state
tree with pure reducers and we'll go
into a demo electron to show you this
but a reducer is essentially a function
that accepts an accumulation value and
then it takes back and returns that as a
new accumulation and this allows you to
have a single source of truth value the
user can return the new state objects
instead of mutating to a previous state
the user can
start with a single reducing as the app
grows it can then split off into a
smaller reducers
and then finally the reducers just
become functions so let's talk about the
pillars of redux
and so there are three key areas we have
the store the actions and then reducers
and then the store itself is the actual
main object that holds the application
tree state
and there are four key
states there's get state which turns the
current c to the store and when we
actually run the demo later on you'll be
able to see that we'll be able to open
up our terminal window and be able to
get the state store from from our
terminal window
the second state is dispatch and this is
a an action it's the only way to update
the application state and here we have a
action on a button change to actually
change the state of the application and
then the final two are subscribe
unsubscribe
and these are our ways in which you can
actually change the listener to the
state so an action is a plain object
that represents an intention to change
the state so with actions you have
payloads of information that send data
back and forth to your application store
so you can send any kind of data and
they can go back and forth and that
actions must also have been a tight
field that indicates the type of action
that has been performed and finally with
reducers reducers are
specified how the application state
changes in response to actions sent to
the store and so actions only describe
what's happened but don't describe the
application state change
they are reducer is a function that
accepts the current state and an action
and then returns a new state with the
action performed and then finally you
can use combined reducers utility which
can then combine reduces in an app into
a single a index
so let's look at the pros and cons of
using redux because nothing is perfect
so a pro for working with redux is that
redux provides a single source of truth
which is the store so there's no
confusion over where you're getting your
values
this then leads to having a predictable
and strict outcome redux is more
stringent about how the code is
organized this makes it easier to
onboard developers because there is a
very structured way of writing redux
code this makes it also then
easier for the initial render which
allows you to make uh your solution
really optimized as an experience and
then finally developers can track
everything that's going on inside the
app in real time the cons
so
one of the plate codes so this kind of
takes us back to the structured code
format it is um strict and it's set up
and it is memory intensive so with that
let's go in and look at a demo of using
redux to
reformat a react application
so in this demo we're going to use react
to show how redux can work first thing
we want to do is go ahead and download
node.js we're going to go to nodejs.org
to get the latest download the downloads
are available in windows mac os and
linux you can also download and
recompile the source code if you want
i encourage you to go with the latest
lts version it's the latest stable
version now there are other versions you
can use but that's one you would want to
use i already have it installed so i
just want to show you how that looks so
i'm just going to go in and put
node dash dash version it's going to
give me the version number so that shows
it's installed and we'll also use npm
which is node package manager because
we'll be using that validate that it's
installed by doing node m npm dash dash
version so okay so looking good and
we're going to go ahead and create a
folder um on our desktop um normally you
wouldn't put
a project folder on your desktop but you
know this is just for an experiment so
we're going to call this one redux react
it's going to be taking a react project
and we're going to show what it looks
like as a standard project and then what
it will look like
as a project that's being
taken through redux
so let's just move our cursor to the
correct folder
and so we're going to go to cd redux
react
and there we are we're in at the correct
folder using our command prompt uh you
use terminal on mac os
so let's just type in mpx and that's for
our redax and we're going to do create
dash react dash app so we're going to
create a default react app and then
we'll also install redux dash app
and these are the two uh components that
we need to be able to uh build out our
solution one is react and it's react.js
and the second is redux
and we hit return
and this is going to go ahead and
download the latest versions of both of
these applications and install them into
the folder that we just created on our
desktop
just give that a moment
and so it's installing the different
packages react react dom
react scripts
and there we have everything installed
great
and these are just different commands
you can use
and it's recommending that we select npm
start
to get everything up and running so we
use visual studio code to do most of our
work here vs code
is open source solution for scripting
and it's available on all the new
platforms now it is from microsoft but
it is open source
and uh there's just a ton of stuff here
but we're going to go ahead and open up
the folder we just created on our
desktop
and so here is redux react app
and we're going to select that folder
and on the left hand side you'll see all
the files from that folder which is
going to get rid of the welcome screen
we don't need that anymore uh you'll see
there's some commands we use we do uh
control plus
uh i'm not sure what that's called again
anyway it gets us to the terminal window
um
not an exclamation point
so you'll see that in our project folder
we have all of the files we need for our
solution we have both the node modules
and then the public files the product
files is just the application itself so
over here on the index.html you see the
index file there and we're going to
actually show what this looks like
inside
as it's broadcast from a web browser in
a moment now uh we're going to create a
very simple application here
and the application is going to look
exactly the same in both um uh just
standard react and uh redux react it's
the optimization that's gonna be
improved so we just did mpm dash and
start it's gonna take us to local host
call on 3000 give it a moment and then
we should get our
floating
logo showing that the application's up
and running up there we are
we can go ahead and head and edit app.js
to
create our application
okay so let's go in and we're going to
go into app.js
and we are going to create an
application called
newcomp.js
and we actually have some code that
we've already created that you can
download as part of this application
so but we're just going to type in here
import react
and then component
[Music]
from react
so i'm going to pull in our react
library
and we also import
connect
from
react
redux
and that's the
package that we're working in
let's
terminate the bat shop yes
and then rerun
npm
install
save
react
dash redux
and there we go takes a moment just to
install that
so our goal here is to show
how you can optimize your solution with
redux for the uh using the store and
reduces in redux
again
the the solution is going to look
exactly the same what's going to change
is the performance of the solution
and this is what redux gives you all
right so we're going to go ahead and
we're going to go in and type in class
new comp
extends component
and then we're just going to select our
constructor
props
and then we want to add in there
super props
and then this
state
equals
i have a message here
subscribe
to simply learn
very simple little app
don't forget to save your work as you go
along
and we're just going to apply some
styles
let's just make the
apply some font style
like italics
then we're gonna
make the color
purple
and let's have a button that we're going
to press a
button change
equals
this set state
oh sorry get state
and we'll have a message that comes up
basically saying thank you for
subscribing
there we go we have our button we'll
change the state here in a moment
and very simple
little application
and we want to rent that
on the screen
i just have some basic
html for where we're going to place
everything we use a div tag
for our app
again we're going to keep this really
simple
and we're gonna call
reference this styles for
this h3 tag
so our message is going to be subscribe
to simply learn
this will be created dynamically we use
our style i'm going to add in a button
click
action
subscribe
and nope change too many s's
save that
all right save now let's run
the script
you guys have js
and we're going to actually import that
into
our app.js script
okay
rid of this
and then
and we'll extend
the newscorp js
component into here
parent
font style here
and
i'll render this correctly
and i'll pull in the text
and styles
again it's pretty simple little
application
now playing from use called
so we'll actually have
a welcome screen a welcome line and then
pulling the two lines of code
all right let's
run that
npm start
and here we go
refreshes our
page so what we've just created is a
basic standard state object
and
let's see now oh yeah this is good now
we actually can show you that we didn't
actually write all the code correctly so
let's go back and fix that
because newport news
newscomp.js and we have to make sure
that we
have a correct export feature here so
that the image that the
everything can be exported effectively
import we also need to have an export
all right let's run that again
okay should take care of our
uh problem hey there we are so welcome
and then we have the standard state
object of subscribe to simplyline hit
subscribe and we change the text too
thank you for subscribing
okay so let's kind of go in and modify
this now so it goes from being a
standard state object to one that uses
store and reduces
so we're going to go ahead and terminate
our batch job
and since you reset everything
and what we're going to do now is
install redux
this is what's going to help us
it takes a moment to install redux
all right so we have redux installed
that's good
and now we want to
start
our package
and it looks the same but now we're
going to make some changes
so let's go to
our index file
index.js
our react dom
now we're going to add in
contour
so this is going to be our react this is
going to be our redux store so we're
going to create a new store
now it's going to be a reducer
and
we're going to
put
in strict mode
okay juice is not too fine let's go
ahead and define that
so
we're going to come over
to our new comp js file
and what we want to do here is we're
going to
take out the one class file that we just
created
and
i'm just gonna stripping it down here
now let's go in
and
let's map our state
to
props
equals state
and we're going to do return
message
is state dot message
and then
[Music]
construct map dispatcher props
and this is going to be our dispatch
and we're going to
return
and we have our button
change
for dispatch
and we'll type in what the message is
now we have message change
let's turn from the button okay
so we'll pass the value over
all right
and now we actually
connect
as part of our export and in our
connection
i'm going to do map state props
and map
dispatch props
all right now we're going to go in and
it's going to be for our new comp
now we want to switch over
and we're going to just change some of
our linking variables here
so serve to button change we're going to
do props dot button change
otherwise we won't be able to find in
our code
this is some pathing
and
[Music]
you go ahead and create a new folder and
this one is going to be our store
and again this is going to be our redux
store
we're going to call the store
reducer.js
and
const
initial state equals
this is what the default state will be
for when the page loads which will be
subscribed to simply then
and then
the reducer
we're going to place to where the
reducer is
and con's new state
and it's going to be
an if action
dot type
i'm going to change the message
there's unused comp
so that's the
action there we
pull that
so it's identical
and then new state dot message
equals
thank you for subscribing so
we have the default and now we have the
new message
again this might seem like extra work
but actually makes your
whole application much more efficient
and export default
juicer all right so make sure we saved
all our files which we have
and
now let's go ahead
so we have let's just inspect everything
it's all looking good
all right
now terminal window we're going to do
npm start and see what happens
and our web browser should load up
we have an error
that's good so now we're learning stuff
so this again this is all part of your
standard coding is just hunting down
errors in your code so let's go to
index.js
and
looks like
we're going to pull in here
so we have reduce and this should
actually be
spelled correctly there we
go okay all right everything is now
as it should be
let's go back
recompile
let's
rerun uh
file
and do we want to move our file let's
just go ahead and move the store
i'm going to update all the links to the
store
and we're going to be trying mainstream
provider
store
is referenced correctly
okay let's rewrite our application
and
there we are
so let's go back through
our applications running much faster now
we're able to manage our changes and our
elements for our applications different
objects
we're able to change the messages after
you click
and able to then create the new message
again this is a very simple application
but you can see how for more complex
solutions how this become useful and you
start using the different components you
create
for your whole solution
and that's our demo
if you wish to build mobile applications
and are confused as to which tool to use
then you're in the right place
this video on react native will explain
what react native is and guide you
through it
but wait before beginning if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already then
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
so here's what you'll be learning in
this session
first we'll understand what exactly
react native is
then we look at why react native is
being so widely used off lately
moving ahead we look at the differences
between react native applications and
platform specific applications
after understanding why react native is
used we'll understand some of the
prerequisites for building applications
using react native
then we'll understand react native
fundamentals like view state props and
style
and lastly we'll end the session by
looking at some of the industry trends
of react native
so let's begin
what exactly is react native
now react native is a framework that
combines the best parts of native
development with react to build user
interfaces
these applications that have developed
using react native are downloadable on
google play store and apple store plus
because most of the code you write can
be shared between platforms react native
offers a wide collection of ui kits and
makes it easy to simultaneously develop
for both android and ios devices
but you must be wondering why is react
native used
so let's look at some of the reasons why
react native is used
first up is cross platform
cross platform means that the
applications can easily be run on
microsoft windows linux and mac os so
you can build your code base once and
then run it on any platform as opposed
to software built natively for a
specific platform next up is performance
now the react native apps are compiled
into natively written code which enables
it to not only work on both the
operating systems but also functions the
same way on both the platforms with no
lags at all
moving ahead there's quicker development
now react native offers excellent
developer experience
it provides strong developer and
debugging tools with meaningful error
messages so working with this tool
becomes very easy
a large developer community now there
are several github repositories on react
native and groups on facebook
stack overflow is an excellent website
with several developers interacting
about issues on a regular basis
next up is wider audience now since
react native applications run on both
ios and android devices there's a huge
user base
and lastly react native has a great
career scope
considering the pace at which the
framework took over the market and its
simple approach to resolving development
problems the future of react native
looks more promising than ever
so these were some of the reasons why
react native is being widely adopted
so now let's go ahead and look at some
of the differences between react native
applications and platform-specific
applications
as discussed earlier react applications
work on multiple platforms while in the
case of platform-specific applications
as the name suggests these applications
are built for the specific platform only
developers have a stronger web
development background while in the case
of platform-specific apps they have a
very strong platform's language
background
in this case when you consider ios
developers have a very strong hold of
swift which is a programming language
used to develop ios applications and
talking about android developers have a
very strong hold on java when it comes
to react native it has a faster build
time and is less suitable for complex
applications
comparatively platform specific
applications have a slower build time
and are suitable for complex
applications react native is best for
small development teams with limited
resources
while in the case of platform-specific
applications it is best used by
experienced developers who have adequate
experience in building mobile apps
so now that you know what exactly is the
difference between react native and
platform specific applications let's
look at some of the prerequisites for
building apps using react native
first up you should have a strong
holding programming concepts like
functions objects arrays and to lesser
extent classes
now understanding javascript and all the
javascript libraries and frameworks is
crucial
and lastly you need to be familiar with
html and css concepts so as long as you
have a strong hold of these then react
native development becomes very easy
so now that you know what react native
is you've understood why it's being used
some of the prerequisites for react
native
let's look at the basic concepts like
view state props and styling in react
native
let's begin with view
now view is the most fundamental
component of building a ui
it is a container that supports layout
with flexbox style some touch handling
and accessibility controls
now view maps directly to the native
view
equivalent on whatever platform react
native is running on so here you can see
there's a simple code snippet and the
output for it so as you can see there's
a hello world message in a render method
and the same is being rendered and the
view component here is being imported
from react native
now view as mentioned earlier acts as a
container with support for flexbox
layout and other styles
so flexbox is designed to provide a
consistent layout on different screen
sizes
moving on to state now there are two
types of data that control a component
one is props and the other one is state
now props are generally set by the
parent and are fixed throughout the
lifetime of a component
but for data that is going to change we
make use of state
so here you can see you have made use of
the this dot stay dot my state in my
render method you can also use the set
state method when you want to change it
moving on let's look at props
most components can be customized when
they are created with different
parameters these created parameters are
called props short for properties now
props are passed from one container to
another as a way of passing data between
them
so here using the name as a prop
lets us customize the message in the
component so we can reuse our component
for each of our tv shows here
so this is how you can use props in our
component
lastly talking about style react native
uses the conventional javascript
styling for components so the style
names and values are similar to how css
works
now to style we either use inline style
or style sheet
so you can see here we've provided
inline styling with a background color
a color and a font size and accordingly
the output is displayed
moving ahead to our last and final
section
let's look at the industry trends today
talking about salaries the average
salary of a react native developer in
india is around 6 lakh indian rupees per
annum
and the salary of a react native
developer in the us is around 96 000 us
dollars per annum now as you can see
react native has a higher growth
trajectory compared to other frameworks
as a result is being readily deployed by
many companies
applications like facebook instagram
netflix pinterest uber uber eats among
others are developed using react native
in this session we would look at
identifying some of the differences
between the react native and flutter
frameworks let's start with
understanding the core areas of
comparison as part of this session we
will be looking at key aspects to
identify differences between both the
frameworks predominantly on the language
front the ui aspect the performance the
documentation the popularity the
community support that is available for
both these frameworks along with the
industry trends
in terms of the industry adoption for
both these platforms the core objective
of the session would be that at the end
you should be able to decide and make an
informed decision as to which framework
is the best among those available let's
start from a language perspective now if
you look at react react is basically
completely written and built in
javascript using the react.js api on the
other hand if you look at flutter it is
basically written in a very new language
called as start and we do not have uh
too many developers that are skilled on
dart however uh every browser and every
platform being shipped with
an in-built javascript execution
environment that makes javascript
platform the language of choice
for developers so every browser today or
every browser manufacturer would have
inbuilt support for executing javascript
programs similarly most popular
platforms mobility platforms like
android and ios have default support for
executing javascript programs and that's
the reason when you compare this with
flutter flutter uses start which is
predominantly a newer language and we
really do not have too many developers
who are skilled on this so actually is
the selling point
and the usb of react native because when
you work with react native uh you really
do not have to relearn a lot you don't
have a sharp learning curve most of the
javascript developers who are working
with means tag already works with html
css and dhtml can easily align to this
that as we have discussed
is pretty new in the industry and would
not have that much of penetration in the
developer community from a ui
perspective when you talk about react
native it's based pretty much on native
components for the android and the ios
platform and flutter on the other hand
uses a very proprietary uh set of
widgets and it has its own page
structure that needs to be set up so
it's a closed ecosystem as compared to
an open ecosystem in react native which
allows you to go and implement third
party widgets and ui frameworks as well
now this is really what uh allows you to
pick and choose with react native
because uh you can go and decide whether
you want to use kendo ui or a set of
terry controls or any other third-party
ui framework can be implemented but for
flutter you have a pretty closed
ecosystem and that's the reason the ui
components that are available out of the
box and built into the platform are all
that you can use from a performance
perspective when you talk about react
native it basically
is built and uses javascript out of the
box and that's the reason when you want
to write any code in javascript that
connects and tries to access native
services on that specific platform it
uses a bridge to do that but when you're
using flutter on the other hand flutter
does not need any kind of bridge so
there's no concept of you write flutter
code and then it uses a bridge to go and
connect to the native set of components
to interact with and this is what really
impacts the speed and the performance
aspect of developing and executing
applications between both these
frameworks because if you look at react
the speed of development is a little bit
slower when you compare that with
flutter and that's because it has an
intermediate bridge that it has to
communicate with and every layer of
additional communication and computation
that you put in between two tiers in a
application that you built obviously
would have a performance impact from a
documentation perspective if we were to
compare flutter typically has a very
well defined
documentation repository and it allows
developers to go through it in a very
simple manner so it's all structured
it's all organized unlike what you see
on react native because in react native
it actually since react native is an
open ecosystem and allows you to
implement third party widgets and you
can do a lot of configuration and plug
and play and that's the reason uh the
documentation also is not very strong
well organized and impactful and that's
the reason uh most developers would find
it a little challenging to go through
the react native documentation when you
compare that to the documentation
available in terms of flutter popularity
is always a key when working with
platforms and that should be a crucial
decision maker because when it comes to
open source technologies and you're
stuck somewhere you obviously go to the
coming to the community to go and find
out how best you can solution the
problem now flutter being relatively a
new entrant into the market it does not
have a lot of developer penetration and
that's the reason the popularity in the
community is not very strong react
native being there for a while now it's
been around for some time and that's the
reason uh it's pretty popular among
developers also since uh it uses
javascript it's a natural transition and
a progression path for those who are
working with html5 css and building web
applications or have been building
hybrid mobile apps find it very easy to
migrate to this because flutter requires
you to learn a new programming language
which is start and that is one more
reason why the popularity of this is
much much better on the react native
front as compared to flutter again if
you look at google trends
you could actually look at both of the
lines here the red line indicating
flutter it started on a very positive
note and then there was a plateau and
then suddenly a spike react native has
been much more steady in terms of its
growth and ultimately if you look at it
now both of them seem to be trending at
par with each other so the community
support as we were speaking about if you
look at stack overflow which is one of
the most popular websites to go for any
kind of uh developer
trends and movements and for a q a that
most developers would have you can
actually look at the number of questions
here and uh also uh react native is part
of uh github as its open source it was
released in 2015 and uh it's because of
the huge community support that it
becomes uh easier to implement this you
have a lot of confidence as a developer
when you start building on this stack
because if you're stuck somewhere you
will have a lot of help available on the
way on the other hand if you compare
that with flutter you can look at the
question count here on stack overflow
and this being a new entrant in the
market
it has a smaller footprint on the
community aspect but of course that
keeps increasing every day again from a
react native perspective and you talk
about stability in terms of stable
releases uh there again you would see
that react native does a much better job
as compared to flutter so the industry
tents are something which all of us have
to be aware of specifically if uh we
would need to make a decision in terms
of our careers the technology that we
are learning what is the growth aspect
what is the industry adoption and how we
could really move ahead on our career
graphs in terms of the opportunities
market the job market etc so again
getting back to stack overflow which is
the benchmark for understanding
technology trends in i.t sphere and
software development if you look at a
recent survey conducted in 2019 uh 62.5
percent of developers uh seem to have
shown interest in react native as
compared to a marginal rise of 65.4
percent where flutter seems to be doing
much better and of course that could be
due to the uh time frames that uh both
these technologies uh have been around
react has been around for quite a while
and hence the job prospects are much
better a lot of organizations
implementing this clutter has been a new
entrant and hence
slightly fewer opportunities as the
penetration still needs to happen in the
opportunities job market and
from a developer skills perspective so
these are some of the big names that are
using react native in their
implementations right from facebook to
pinterest to wix skype tesla insta
bloomberg uh you can actually look at uh
the implementation across industry which
is absolutely crucial when you're
learning something new because when you
want to join a large logo obviously if
there are a lot of logos using this that
enhances the credibility of your to your
learning puts a justification to why you
would want to learn this technology
flutter on the other hand associated
with big names like google sonos alibaba
the largest retailer out there from a
conclusion perspective if we were to
conclude on what we've discussed from a
language perspective uh obviously we
said react is much more popular since it
is a natural progression for developers
to work on javascript and move to this
as compared to dart which is relatively
a new language from a ui perspective the
open source plug-and-play capability of
configuring and adopting seamlessly to
newer platforms of widgets and
third-party ui platforms are much better
as compared to flutter which is a closed
ecosystem and depends on inbuilt widgets
to implement the performance aspect we
discussed because of the bridge from the
code that you write to the native
component access exists in react and is
isolated and not any longer required in
flatter and hence the performance is
impacted because of the additional layer
in between the documentation much much
better in flutter because it's a closed
ecosystem and they can control what you
can use react native being open-ended it
really has a lot of third-party
integration you can do and hence the
documentation is not really well
organized the popularity perspective
react native much more popular among
html5 css three mer mean stack
developers since it's all javascript
flutter needs you to learn new skills
and you need to spend additional time
for that from a community support react
native has been there for a longer time
as compared to flutter and hence has a
stronger community support as compared
to flutter and that translates into
better job prospects
in the industry for react native as
compared to flutter so if we were to
give it a score react scores much better
with a total score of 5 leaving flutter
with a total score of 2. so i hope we
were able to understand the differences
between the react native and flutter and
this will help you make better decisions
with planning your career and deciding
which technology you should latch on to
welcome to the session on react.js
interview questions through this session
we will explore the most commonly posed
interview questions that you would face
if you walk up to a developer interview
on react.js let's start with going
through and exploring the general set of
react.js interview questions that would
be commonly asked in an interview the
first question would be what are the
features of react.js now right through
this session we would follow a common
methodology where we would explore the
question and then look at the best way
in which you could have answered that
question if posed to you during a
react.js interview so starting with the
first question what are the features of
react so react has many extensions for
complete application architecture
support jsx is used with react to
describe what the user interface should
typically look like react is broken into
small components so you look at the
complete
application you want to build break it
down into individual components and a
component is typically a piece of user
interface like a function that would
return a stream of html characters
speedy performance is one of the core
features of react as only the updated
components need to be re-rendered on the
screen and not the entire page the
one-way data binding feature on the
other hand keeps everything modular and
fast the virtual dom is also a
lightweight representation of the real
dom which is again a feature with helps
speed up performance and avoids a full
page refresh and a full dom tree shake
which really speeds up performance so
what is jsx how do you answer this so
jsx is typically the extension used for
react and it's nothing but an extension
to the javascript programming language
because all that you can use inside your
browser for execution typically has to
be javascript because in html5 you
cannot have any third-party plugins
installed in the browser and that's the
reason the browser would only ship by
default with a javascript runtime engine
so by using jsx you can write html
structures in the same file that would
contain your javascript code as well
making the updates to the code very
simple so it's simple to update and make
modifications to your code because the
code and the data and the business logic
is all composed in a single file so
because the code and the business logic
is in a single file it makes uh updating
and incorporating change requests uh to
the code very simple and easy so it's
basically used with react to describe
what your user interface should look
like and it's what you typically would
term as the html template or the view
coming to the next question can jsx be
directly read by the web browser so web
browsers cannot read jsx directly now
why is that well the reason is simple
it's because they are only built to read
regular javascript objects and jsx is
not a regular javascript object it's a
react component so for a web browser to
read a jsx file the file needs to be
transformed into a regular javascript
object and for this there is a
javascript api called people which is
internally used by react so what do you
understand by the virtual dom that we've
been speaking about in react so react
gives a very lightweight representation
of the real dom the actual dom structure
of the page so dom is document object
model it is an api created by w3c and it
creates an in-memory representation of
the html elements as an inverted tree
structure a balanced tree structure
which is the fastest search algorithm
when you want to search for html
elements and do a dynamic update on them
but again updating the basic tom tree
structure of the page causes a full page
refresh and if you only want to update a
specific component you wouldn't need the
entire page to be refreshed and that is
where react comes in it uses a virtual
dom which is a layer on top of the
actual dom which ensures that only a
certain part of the page is refreshed
and that speeds up performance so when
the state of an object changes virtual
dom changes only that object in the real
dom instead of updating all the objects
and this is what makes things really
fast so why use react instead of other
frameworks like angular first of all
it's very easy to create dynamic web
pages dhtml where you can update the
view or the template at runtime the
components are reusable so you reuse
rather than reinvent the performance is
great
since you're working with the virtual
dom you don't need a full page refresh
the unidirectional data flow makes data
move one way there's no two-way data
binding by default and that's the reason
the page does not have to do a lot of
heavy lifting of remembering whether the
view is changing whether the the base
javascript entity class is changing and
that saves a lot of uh processing time
again to debug react is much more
simpler and that's what makes it more
popular in terms of its simplicity and
speed as compared to other frameworks
like angular what is the difference
between es5 and es6 standard so these
are scripting standards okay that are
defined by the european computer
manufacturers association or ecma and
all of the scripting languages are a
subset of the standard and are derived
from these standards to ensure that the
code will execute on all browsers and
the code that we are writing is
standards based so these are the few
instances where es6 syntax has changed
from es5 if you look at the es5 first
syntax at the top we're creating a
simple react class component and the
render function just returns a stream of
html content in ex6 there's a new
keyword that comes in which is extends
so you are extending from the base react
component and creating a custom
component and then returning a stream of
characters also the function keyword no
longer needs to be used so the exports
versus export also changes so you use
exports to export out class from a
module so that it can be accessed from
another module in es6 you simply say
export and the component require versus
import so you would require a
third-party component or an api into
your javascript file to use it in es6
it's replaced with the import statement
very similar to the syntax that we use
in code java so how do you go and create
a react app first you install node.js as
a base platform which you can download
from the node.js website next any text
editor of your choice could be atom
visual studio code or sublime text third
you create a react app using a command
prompt terminal depending on the os you
are using the command to give is create
hyphen react space my first app okay so
the command that you would give to
create a new react app is create hyphen
react hyphen app space and the name of
the application you would want to create
in this case it is my hyphen first
hyphen app and that could be a custom
name of your choice so what is an event
in react well on the web when you talk
about dynamic html it's all about
interacting with the user so the user
performs some interaction event with the
web page which could be a click of a
button a mouse move and these events in
action can be triggered by a user or any
system or could be pressing a key or a
mouse click etc and in response to that
event you would execute a block of code
which is called an event handler so here
we have class simple which is a custom
class that extends the base react
component the name of the function work
which triggers a simple alert message
box and a render function which returns
html when you click on the button we
would want to bind that to the event
handler this dot work and that's how you
connect a click event to an event
handler function what are synthetic
events in react well a synthetic event
is an object which acts as a cross
browser wrapper around the browser's
native event it combines the behavior of
different browsers native events into
one api which makes sure that the events
are consistent across different browsers
and this brings in the standard space
development to ensure in this digital
age the code that we are creating for
different browsers have consistency in
terms of its execution so here we see a
function action link we see a function
handle click which takes e as an event
parameter e dot prevent default ensures
that there is no error that the browser
is raising in case the event function
call is not directly compatible with
that specific browser so prevent default
is used to suppress any browser specific
errors or crashes and a simple
console.lock which will log into the
developer tools window which says you
just clicked a link and then we've got
the return where we are returning the
view to the html template where on click
we connect to this event handler called
handle click so handle click is
basically a wrapper and the entire
action link is
a wrapper object which is a synthetic
event we don't directly go and bind to
the on click and then associate a
function with it we actually associate a
synthetic object with it which binds the
base default event that could be
specific to a browser so some browsers
would probably understand an on click
sun another browser would understand a
click and to ensure that its consistency
of syntax and from a development
perspective the code that we write will
run on all browsers we need to take care
of using the synthetic events which
isolate the developer out from the
complexity of writing code specific to
different browsers so you just write
generic code which will work on
different browsers so how do lists work
in react so the lists display data in an
ordered format the traversal of lists is
done using the map function so here we
see there is a function called list of
names which takes a variable props as a
parameter props dot names uh will allow
us to get a reference to all of the
array of names that are passed constant
list names is another variable created
equal to name start map and
we are using the arrow operator which is
now an ecmascript standard and
again we are using the opening tag of
the li html element the key is equal to
the name attribute so the brace bracket
will bind that to the name attribute
then we just print the name itself and
we close the ally tag so that's the
names.map function and finally we return
in an unordered list the list names
themselves so the map function will run
through an iterate over the list of
names list them in the li tag the li tag
will get injected into the unordered
list and will finally get returned out
as a stream of html elements in the next
code snippet below we create a constant
variable names we are associating it
with a set of five names and uh we
simply say render list of names names
equal to names the moment we do that uh
we are using list of names as a custom
html element which is not system defined
it starts looking for the function list
of names passes the names added to it
iterates over it using the map function
which is an inbuilt react function
brings out all of the lists it's very
similar to a forward loop that you would
write for iteration in other programming
languages and then finally what you get
returned in the get element by id app is
nothing but a list of
simple names wrapped in a li element
that are printed on the view so why is
there a need of using keys in lists so
keys are very important in the code
snippet that we saw due to the following
reasons the first reason the key is a
unique identifier if you would want to
search for a name in the list it is used
to identify which items have changed
updated or deleted from the list so if
you want to perform cloud operations on
the data you would want to search for
which element do you want to update or
delete or change it also helps to
determine which components need to be
re-rendered instead of re-rendering all
the components every time and it
increases performance as only the
changed components have to be
re-rendered and not all the components
on the page what are forms in react so
using forms users can interact with the
application and enter required
information whenever needed so forms can
contain certain elements such as text
fields buttons checkboxes radio buttons
etc and forms are also used for many
different tasks such as user
authentication searching filtering etc
how do you create a form pretty simple
again create a custom component called
name from that will extend reactor
component we create a state variable
this dot state is equal to value we
handle the change by writing a handle
change event and we handle the submit by
writing a handle submit event in the
change event we just change the state by
saying set state of the value to
event.target.value event being a system
defined keyword passed as a parameter
and in the submit we simply alert that a
certain name was entered and we trap the
value that was entered into the form
prevent default to suppress the browser
from raising any errors on the render
function we return a form on the submit
we connect to the handle submit event
and we bind the data submitted from the
form to the handle submit event and we
pass the this pointer which is a
reference to the current context of the
view itself we open a label specify the
name we then specified input box as text
the value is set to this dot state dot
value and on change we simply connect to
the handle change event and bind to it
and pass the context of the text box
itself so the moment we change the value
in the text box as we are typing the
handle change event will receive the
updated value and set the state and when
we click on the submit button the handle
submit event handler executes and we
alert out the current value printed in
the text box and that's it so how do you
write comments in react when you're a
developer if you want to comment out
some code or if you want to set comments
to enhance the maintainability of the
code a single line comment is as simple
as given in most other programming
languages backslash astrid to open
astrid slash to close multi-line
commands follow the same syntax and can
span multiple slides to add comments to
functions in terms of what the function
can do and what are the types that it
can return what is the arrow function
and how is it used so an arrow function
is a shorter way of writing a function
in react if you look at the snippet on
the top my input on change equal to we
are connecting to this dot handle change
dot bind and that's the longer version
of how you can connect it to an event
handler the shorter version is on change
equal to e arrow operator this dot
handle on change so you don't need to
call the bind explicitly you can replace
that with the arrow operator and reduce
the amount of code that you typically
write how is react different from react
native so react and react native are
completely different react was released
in 2013 it's a web-based platform it is
html compliant it generates html views
it uses css for styling and it's based
on javascript html and css react native
on the other hand is targeted to
mobility devices it's meant to create
installable apps on android and ios
released in 2015 not based on html and
css and it basically requires the
react.js api to create these installable
apps for these mobility ecosystems how
is react different from angular another
popular framework by google so angular
created by google completely based on
the model view controller pattern works
on the real dom layer and requires a
full tree shake at the tom layer to
update views and components supports
bi-directional data mining the rendering
is purely done on the client side the
performance comparatively slow react.js
on the other hand created by facebook
it's the view layer of the model view
controller pattern it works at the
virtual dom layer and it sends faster
it's unidirectional data binding and not
two-way and the rendering is typically
what is done at the server side and what
you get is a response on the client as a
stream of html characters as an output
let's talk about and discuss some
questions around react components so
what are components in react so these
are the building blocks you can think of
them as lego blocks so you break your
problem down into small parts each part
identifying a certain solution of the
problem which is what we define as a
component so they are building blocks of
a react application and a single app
usually consists of multiple components
so it splits the ui into independent
reusable pieces that can be processed
separately a component is essentially a
piece of the user interface or the html
view what is the use of render method in
react so it is compulsory for each
component to have a render method if not
there wouldn't be any html for the
component to render on your view so the
render function returns the html which
is to be displayed within a component
like you see on the screen there is a
class app that extends the react
component and it returns a simple h1
element called hello simply learn and of
course do remember to export the app out
so that it can be accessed from other
components as well if you need to render
more than one element all the elements
must be inside a single parent tag like
a div or a form what is state in react
the state of a component is an object
that holds some data within it the data
would influence the output of the
component now how do you implement state
in react
so state holds the data that a component
renders on the web application for
example here we've created in the
constructor this dot state equal to and
this temporary anonymous object has two
attributes car and pi when we return we
simply return this dot state dot car and
this dot state dot by now this is how
you would create stateful components and
access the state properties within the
view how do you update the state of a
component by using the built-in set
state method you can go ahead and update
the state of the component so here we
have a simple render function that
returns the state itself state dot
message and on the on click connects to
a button press function the moment you
click on the button the button press
function sets the state to another
message so the initial message in the
constructor is welcome to simply learn
the moment you click on the button the
set state triggers and changes it to
best place to learn so the data on the
view would be updated what are props in
react well props is just a short form
for properties and that is what allows
us to pass arguments or data to a
component props are passed to components
in the way similar to that of attributes
that are passed to an html element so
how do you pass props between two
components so let's say we have an
app.js component on the top and a
main.js component at the bottom at the
top we are trying to return this dot
props dot car and the pipe so two car
and bike attributes associated with this
props of the app component in the main
component when you look at the render
function we are associating car prop
equal to a value of 1 600 cc and bike
prop equal to value of
150cc and to access it if you look at
the import statement we are importing
app from app.jsx and this is how you can
cross-access properties from one
component within the other so what are
the difference between state and props
well state holds information about the
components they are mutable they can be
changed they cannot be accessed by child
components and they cannot have state
props allow to pass data from one
component to the other as an argument
they are immutable they are read only
and props can be accessed by the child
component and they can have props as
well what is a higher order component in
react so these act as a container for
other components which helps in keeping
components simple and induces the
reusability factor they are generally
used when a common logic has to be used
by multiple components that's when you
group together a set of components
within a higher order component in react
how can you embed two or more components
into one this code snippet demonstrates
the app component which returns a hello
text and it has a custom tag called
simple the simple tag is defined in the
component below and it returns text
called simply learn and in the render of
the react dom uh we simply go and render
the app component so hello simply learn
would be the final output and that's how
you can embed one component into the
other using this methodology what are
the differences between class and
functional components so stateful
components would extend react component
in this case and if you could look at
the render it simply renders
this.props.title the constant stateless
component would be equal to props the
div tag returns this dot props dot title
so you can look at the style very
different in terms of class and
functional components one using the
arrow operator one using the traditional
class and render method so the class
component can hold or manage state
complex as compared to stateless
components can work all of the life
cycle methods of the component and it
can be reused the functional component
cannot hold a managed state they are
simple and easy to understand it does
not work with any lifecycle method and
it cannot be reused let's explain the
lifecycle methods of components we've
got kennish initial state which is
executed before the creation of the
component component did mount which is
executed when the component gets
rendered and placed on the dom should
component update which is invoked when a
component decides any changes to the dom
and returns true or false value based on
certain conditions component did update
it is invoked immediately after the
rendering takes place component will
unmount which is invoked immediately
before a component is destroyed and
unmounted permanently let's move to the
react redux set of questions so what is
redux
it's an open source javascript library
used to manage application state and
react uses redux for building the user
interface what are components of redux
the first is the store which holds the
state of the application store contains
state which defines the user interface
which triggers a set of actions which
are then sent to the reducer so store
holds the state action is the source
information for the store and reducer
specifies how the application state
changes in response to actions sent to
the store what is flux well flux is the
application architecture that facebook
uses for building web applications and
it works in this way the action is
triggered which is sent to the
dispatcher the dispatcher sends it to
the store the store sends it to the view
and the view sends it back to the action
and that's exactly how the steps would
continue in sequence so when we trigger
an action the dispatcher will get
notified once the dispatcher has dealt
with an action the stores listening to
it will get triggered the view gets
updated when the state of the store
changes user action at the view is sent
to the dispatcher to then be processed
how is redux different from flux redux
is an open source javascript library
used to manage application state the
store state is immutable it can only
have a single store and it uses the
concept of reducer flux on the other
hand is an architecture and not a
framework or library the store state is
mutable it can have multiple stores and
it uses the concept of dispatcher let's
look at some react router questions what
is a react router a rear router is a
package which is used to create routing
in a react application react router is
used for developing single page web
applications it allows multiple views in
a single application by defining
multiple routes in that react
application how is react routing
different from conventional routing
react routing has a single html page it
uses or the end user rather would
navigate multiple views within the same
file called a single page app the page
does not refresh since it's a single
page file and there is improved
performance since you are not navigating
across multiple pages conventional
routing each view is a separate html
file the user would navigate multiple
files for each view the page would
refresh every time the user navigates
which would hence result in slower
performance how do you implement react
routing you can implement react routing
using a very simple method considering
the above components let's say you've
got a component called app about and
contact so here you can specify the
route path if the route part is just
slash the route defaults out it takes
you to the app component if the route is
slash about in the url given by the end
user you automatically navigate and
activate and load the about component
and if the url is slash contact it would
take you to the contact component let's
talk about react styling questions how
do you style react components either you
use inline styling by using simple css
by simply saying color blue and that's
going to be the output of the h1 element
or i could use a javascript object by
specifying a constant simple style
object and specifying a keypair value of
color background color margin font
family and apply that object as the
style parameter which would result in
this styled output how do you style
react components using a css style sheet
so here's an external style sheet so
we've written all the styling rules in a
separate css file app.css we've imported
that at the top of the app.js react
class and lo and behold you have the
output simplified as generated on your
page let's explain the use of css
modules in react so a css module file is
created.module.css
is the extension the css inside a module
file is available only for the component
that is importing it so there are no
naming conflicts so dot button is the
css styling inside
button.module.css and that is what we've
imported from in the app.js file so when
you view the button style start button
is the styling picked up from the
button.module.css
file and with that we have come to an
end of this video i hope it was
informative and interesting if you have
any questions about the topics covered
in this video please ask anyway in the
comment section below our team will help
you solve your queries thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
you